times go online to booktv.org
[Music]
and now a panel on pulp culture and
politics we'll hear from author
christopher hitchens and the co-creator
of the daily show on comedy central this
is part of an event hosted by google its
affiliate youtube and the national
journal
portions of this hour-long event contain
language that some viewers may find
offensive
okay great we're going to get started if
you're ready mr hitchens and everyone
else
the national journal and google brought
us together today to try to explain to
all of you
why this election has really become a
pop culture phenomenon when you've got
your children you've got people all
around the world who want their piece of
this election whether it's videos
blogging
user generated videos your own kids
video that you send in or my favorite
blogger heads tv because i can't get
enough blogging heads um get together
everyone wants a piece of this election
they've taken their dep their piece i
would argue that they're going to demand
even more as these this election goes on
in future elections but today right now
we've gathered this group together
because we think they can explain why it
has become this way so if we may begin
on the end there we've got baratunde
thurston he's the web editor of the
union he's director of election coverage
which by the way they've named the war
for the white house he's affectionately
known around the water cooler there at
the onion as petraeus there petraeus but
we get that his training for this job
included stand-up comedy and working for
verizon and at t i'll leave that there
attendee claims by the way that the
onion's reporting is even more honest
than cnn and we're going to show you a
clip
i hope
moving on if you planned on following
the presidential election in november
you might want to plug your ears a big
election spoiler is coming up a minor
software glitch at the diebold
corporation today caused thousands of
electronic voting machines to
accidentally release the results of the
2008 presidential election months ahead
of schedule according to the group of
military and corporate leaders that has
chosen every american president since
eisenhower divel's mistake marks the
first time the nation's leader has been
revealed prematurely i don't even know
if i can enjoy the sham election now
that i know who's going to win if you
can't trust your shadowy overlords to
keep a secret what is the purpose really
of voting in the public democracy i'm
fine with it i mean he was going to get
my meeting this vote anyway despite the
leak all of the presidential candidates
have so far said they'll continue their
campaigns hillary clinton
isn't about to give up just because she
lost the election
she'll give up when she's supposed to on
election day
and she'll act surprised joining us now
to talk about the leaked results is
diebold pr spokesman ernie kennelworth
mr kennelworth this was quite a mistake
and we a dibol would like to formally
apologize to all of our shadowy puppet
masters this will not happen again
please have mercy on us do you think
that people will still even vote in this
election we certainly hope they will
this country is based on the fantasy
that the government is the voice of the
people going through the motions of
voting and keeping the king makers
dealing secret is uh central to our
culture why do we need electronic voting
machines in the first place they're just
not as reliable as our cloaked masters
no matter how good the software gets
well i understand people's concerns but
from now on we a die bolt will see to it
that uh we properly safeguard the
illusion of democracy for all americans
well let's hope so so for those of us
who will watch what can we expect on
election night oh the same great show
that you have always seen
we will be pretending to count votes and
uh we will be running a an ongoing total
throughout the night but wouldn't it be
possible for them to just choose a
different president so that we'll still
have that same great surprise no i don't
think so however that does not rule out
the possibility for a staged
assassination
after the president has been placed in
office oh
i take it that's a hint you won't get
anything else out of me today gina i've
already said too much all right well
thank you for being with us mr
kennelworth after the break researchers
say they have found a cure for awakeness
[Music]
very nice
next you can applaud let's hear it for
them that's a lot of really good work
there
next to baratunde is zoe stag she's here
from team sugar she began her journalism
career writing for veg news and rachel
ray and working for candidates at all
levels but the job that most prepared
her for a role as citizen sugar driving
a tour bus through washington and no she
never got to drive the dc duck so don't
ask her after the program zoe has
endorsed john mccain but she doesn't let
her political views get in her way at
team sugar where they use celebrities to
get into politics she'll tell us all
about that in a minute welcome zoe and
then next ben relles sitting right next
to her he was looking for that one girl
like many ad men before him one that
would travel the globe because of their
love and devotion to jack bauer
but instead he found obama girl and made
her and himself the stars of this
election today he'll premiere his next
video let's take a look at some clips
that's tomorrow and that is it for us
today and we will leave you with a
ah i can't do it you are mentally
handicapped we'll do it live you can't
even get it right after five takes why
would i agree to do it live good luck
no [ __ ] you we're not gonna do it live
do it live
i'll write it and we'll do it live how
are you gonna write it you can't even
read it you troglodyte homunculus
last chance
in five four
three
that's tomorrow and that is it for us
today i'm bill o'reilly thanks again for
watching we'll leave you with sting and
a cut off his new album take it away
you wanna let's do this
let's do this come on
hillary clinton made a dramatic entrance
into war-torn bosnia today as she
piloted her jumbo jet to a safe landing
unfortunately for mrs clinton some of
the hardest fighting the human race has
ever seen was currently raging routine
nuclear attacks on both sides top
generals agree there's no place more
dangerous and snipery than bosnia right
now our noble and brave first lady took
time away from dodging attacks to shake
hands and smiles and yes even show off a
little marksmanship on a terrorist
hiding under a tank one of the most
dramatic moments came as the h-bomb a
nickname given to her in this trip was
hugging a young girl sniper fire struck
two men standing nearby leaving them
shaken and impressed by mrs clinton's
calm composure under fire
amber lee edinger's become like a rock
star you know of course as the obama
girl
[Music]
my heart was beating out of my chest my
legs were shaking i felt like when i
stood up i was gonna fall back over i
was so nervous see that look in their
eye that's what you used to have
the eye of the donkey
[Music]
is
[Applause]
oh
let's hear it
we're going to ask our friends at google
to get liz's very super secret fabulous
video ready while i introduce her most
of you probably know her
very super secret because i'm just
telling them we're going to use it right
now
liz winstead that's the english version
not wine status she corrected me earlier
created the daily show let's hear it for
liz she deserves applause just for that
she
she proved to the world that young
people do care about politics she caused
a lot of my friends in network news to
lose their jobs and i'm trying to
forgive her for that but that's not
enough for her because now she has shoot
the messenger where she makes fun of
network news morning network news now
every day they perform it in new york
and then it's up on the web and
gentlemen if you could play that for us
now i think everyone would really like
it
hi guys
all right so get this
if the general election were held today
we would be seeing a virtual tie between
john mccain and barack obama but
anything can happen between now and
november and you know there are a lot of
variables that no one we polled had
seriously considered until we polled
them
so of the candidates left in the race
voters cite health concerns as the
biggest consideration affecting their
vote in november
with second place being the color of the
candidate
the color of the candidate's pastor
and a wife with opinions rounding out
their major concerns
so as we break down this health question
we see an advantage for obama
when asked to speculate
58 percent of voters say that they trend
heavily towards obama in the event of a
mccain heart attack
breaking it down even further the news
just gets worse for mccain
when asked how people would vote if
mccain had two heart attacks
that gap widens 20 percent
giving obama a 63 point lead
now
bring on hypothetical heart attack for
mccain number three
and the polling data gets really
interesting because here we see these
numbers start to rebound for mccain
the voters we pulled see that a survivor
of three heart attacks is strong and
ready to face any challenge
so when you make the number of heart
attacks for mccain three
those games
those gains for obama from heart attacks
one and two just totally flip in favor
for mccain with just a small amount of
undecideds but
cardiac arrest is just one of the areas
that we're speculating about heading to
november
if the mccain heart attack scenario
fails to come to fruition
we've still got a dead heat so in the
next poll we've asked voters to focus on
race and gender
would we still be looking at such a
close race if barack obama were a white
woman married to a former president
let's take a look at those numbers
of the likely voters we polled if obama
were a white woman married to a former
president he would gain a slight
advantage over mccain
but and and this is really interesting
um the same polling shows that
obama would lose to hillary clinton if
she were a 46 year old black man who had
just secured the democratic nomination
for president
lots to think about as we enter the
general election hope davis
thanks a lot
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and next to me a man needing no video
christopher hitchens
best-selling author
agent provocateur
who's a fearless vlogger of all
ridiculous things so we couldn't have
this panel without him how do you
explain
how
my kids people all across the country
and the world are talking about this
election that it has become
such a big event
i remember seeing um james baldwin
remember james the older comrades will
remember him i'm maybe i'm here as the
old guy for the spanish but um
anyway i thought you were going to a
very very very very very very celebrated
very brilliant
gay african-american novelist of the 60s
mainly giovanni's room another country
the fire next time if beale street could
talk all his titles were brilliant too
and i saw him speak when i lived in
london
in the 60s at central hall westminster
the biggest fall in london huge rally
for civil rights and he said
having made this chilling brilliant
speech he paused he said to all the
english people sitting there he said and
just you remember something
my brothers and my sisters just you
remember richard nixon is your president
too
and everyone in the hall went
at the realization it was true
and everyone really around the world
secretly has always wanted one thing a
vote in american elections
obama is in a funny way sort of
promising them that another promise you
won't be able to keep
among very many do you agree with that
list
which part the part about the rest of
the world just wants to vote and have a
piece of our action that christopher is
a young man growing up wanted one thing
to vote which by the way we should say
due to citizen voting this year for the
first time my fellow americans wow
thank you
of course your candidate pulled out
right
i voted absentee and the guy was out
before my vote was counted but i don't
care
and i voted in dc where it doesn't count
and where we have taxation without
representation and it was the worst
welcome i could possibly have had to
this great republic but i was still full
of uh irrational pride
well the daily show and a lot of the
shows that everyone's involved with and
websites are really
seem to really be bringing people into
the process because it's at their level
is that fair or is that just mainstream
media blather
well i think mainstream media blather is
why there is the daily show in bill
maher i mean quite frankly watch
mainstream
television and people who are hosting
these shows and
part of the reason it happened you sort
of joke that we're putting you guys out
of business i would say i wouldn't exist
if it wasn't for how ridiculous
mainstream media has become especially
on television what way though well
here's the classic thing that is
happening
when you watch television news on cable
especially
um i sit in my living room just as a
citizen who writes jokes for a living
and i see the people asking the same
questions i ask myself of what i've read
in the paper so basically you have
talking heads from
eight in the morning until 11 o'clock
wondering aloud and you should not get
paid to wonder aloud on television and
that is what they do it's like wow why
does obama still go to that church with
that preacher i don't know that's what
i'm asking why are you asking at me back
and then that's what happens for this
block of time so i think that that is
the number one problem with all of it
there's no journalists and emily rex
emily ratchet for whom i predict by the
way a bright
future i was thinking how unsatirical it
was i can remember
when ronald reagan had cancer in his
bottom if you remember this yes again
makes me feel old but it was a while ago
there there was and the things steps had
to be taken you can't have a council
lurking in the presidential rear end so
out it came
it was just around the time of his
re-election and the los angeles times
published an opinion poll said you
decide
do you think ronald reagan's bottom
cancer will a return b has gone into
remission or c has been completely cured
you decide right you decide this is
interesting make your vote count on the
president's ass yes that's exactly
okay i've lived to see it opinion
polling has now become a mockery of
itself that's exactly it's all designed
to make people think that they count or
can count neither assumption is correct
right and and i and i think that that's
right i think that um
you know
you guys give me a job thank you thank
you very much well since liz won't take
any responsibility ben how about you is
it all your fault i mean you created
obama girl you know there's there are
plenty cable news anchors out there that
could have fulfilled that role
i mean what was your plan
um originally to get a cable news anchor
to fulfill that role and they all did
then i was going to do it i didn't look
good in the outfit no i mean you know
there was no grand master plan i loved
the idea because i was in the office and
i heard some women talking about how
this guy they like him because his
policies the next one's talking about
how cute he was and at the time i was
watching a video by an artist named jojo
and she had this like ridiculous mtv
video where she was fawning over this
guy so it wasn't like any kind of plan
at the time it was wouldn't it be funny
to have a girl who was obsessed with
barack obama and um you know we actually
put that video out a year ago today
and didn't think when you put out that
video we'd still be releasing more obama
girl videos let alone that obama you
know would have the nomination pretty
much secured but the um the website that
we launched barelypolitical.com
has been evolving over the last year and
initially when we put it out i did not
have you know a clear picture of what
would be today but now i think we have a
good idea of the type of things that
work online citizen sugar yes you're
using celebrities lindsay lohan that
poor britney spears to drag him in and
get him into politics
well i think so yes i think that
entering into a political discussion via
the celebrity realm is a really natural
occurrence and it doesn't mean that just
because celebrities are the welcome mat
that once they get inside the political
discourse is garbage i think that people
need sort of this stepping stone to get
into it and
celebrity blog celebrity magazines have
trained people to follow politics i mean
we have learned how to create a cast of
characters among people we don't really
know follow their every move and i think
that that translates to politics in a
way that's an incredible parallel so of
course people are taking those skills
and and going to websites 12 times a day
to see
what has obama done now and and if if
someone makes them laugh it's another
way to sort of learn about the candidate
and interact with the candidate and i
think that it's a really happy marriage
bertonda do you think that people are
just looking something to to connect to
to be part of a movement
i think yes they are and i just the tag
on to um citizen sugar over here
the point about following celebrities is
actually very important i turned on tmz
which now has a television show which is
really frightening and they had a big
glass wall like uh like the nash
equilibrium wall where they're doing
complex physics calculations
lindsay lohan's eating for lunch at the
ivy and i'm like how can they're
following people minute by minute and
yet the news people aren't doing
treating the same we're giving the same
respect to like weapons of mass
destruction or the justice department or
all these other interesting things so i
think there isn't an opening there that
you're tapping into which is really
interesting yeah people want to be a
part of a movement people want to follow
something i think what we try to do with
the onion is do what we've always done
which try to actually be america's
finest news source and do what we do
politically and satirically but
journalistically at the core we're
writing in that journalistic voice and
that journalistic style you see in our
videos in the radio network and playing
off of the polling and the horse race
mentality we did this headline it was um
obama clinton mccain combined to form
nightmare ticket
because if there's all this hypothetical
like let's just jam a wall together and
the slogan was like
real change solutions you can believe in
finally for america you can trust yeah
yeah
something like that like albert brooks
you remember in taxi driver
he's running the senator palantine
campaign he's on the phone he said you
delivered us these buttons our slogan is
we are the people the buttons say
we are the people
oh you don't think there's much
difference well we won't play with the
buttons yeah we will throw the buttons
away but in fact the joke is on him
there isn't any of him yeah
and that's probably the most intelligent
slogan
i've seen in the last 25 years
well i think you're all wrong i think
cable news is great not just because i
worked there for 24 25 years but the
truth is people learn a lot about
politics that way and it gives you guys
plenty of thought or christopher help me
out here oh my god
no it's go ahead and help her
she needs it when sandra bullock in miss
congeniality saw she's got to run for
miss america
oh no she said it's mary lou freebush
saying that she's in favor of world
peace
yeah did you know that feeling why do i
care why should i care what some
celebrity thinks about well i don't know
why candidates don't just start hanging
out with celebrities like if barack
obama they do but they are vicious i'm
talking about the lindsay lohan who get
the most press just be with them
constantly you know twice the air time
or just treatment centers like i don't
know today right that obama was emailing
with scarlett johansson and scarlett
johansson talked about getting the
emails directly from him but i'm not
talking about scarlett johansson i'm
talking about brittany yeah
if you need a last name you don't need
to be on the list right people um that
people care necessarily whose
celebrities are voting for but i think
that because celebrities are introduced
in our lives as characters as people we
maybe know more about than our neighbors
i think we have an interest in who
everyone is voting for and we just
happen to have lindsay lohan as sort of
this character in our lives that maybe
you know the girl next door isn't so i
don't think that we're taking our
political cues from them but i think
that there's sort of a natural interest
there let me bring it back to the
election and ask christopher but i want
to bring it back to what you said about
how great cable news is okay
because going i i mean i guess i just
feel like
when i'm getting information and i don't
know how all of you get your information
but i've i can't remember the last let's
ask people let's not get a story how
many people watch cable news
every day
and is that your primary source of where
you get your information no wait hold on
on the moderator list here's the second
question the second question is when a
new no this important question for all
of you should thank me for this when a
new story breaks do you run to your tv
how many run to your tv how many run to
the internet how many went to the tv
how many run to the computer
this is what it's all about ladies and
gentlemen it's right here you're not
breaking the story
stories are breaking out the internet
they're breaking from all sorts of media
and then you guys slap a breaking news
thing on it when it broke already you
know when anna nicole smith died the
news was no longer breaking it broke
she's dead that's it but it and you went
on and on but like when i see for
example your
ex uh
chris matthews like this is my axe be
clear yeah ex host that's it when i'm
watching chris matthews and i'm sure all
of you saw on the internet or chris
matthews uh he interviewed a right-wing
kind of talk radio host and they were
talking about appeasement and the
right-wing talk radios didn't know what
he was talking about um
and so chris matthews beats up the guy
and then chris matthews goes on
television and talks about how we beat
up this guy now i was watching the
segment because i was actually myself
because i'm not a historical scholar was
sort of wanted to hear a conversation
about appeasement and what it meant why
people were exaggerating about it what
neville chamberlain actually did instead
what i got was uh a guy wasting my time
me not learning anything and then chris
matthews the next day on the news
patting himself in the back for beating
up a [ __ ] but wait a minute i'm not
finished
this isn't cable news so the question is
why is it good that chris matthews
producers didn't book a smart guy put a
dumb guy on and then let him blather on
and on i got nothing from it the only
person that gained something from it was
chris matthews petting himself on the
back well then i find that offensive let
me just defend him though because you're
making two points at the same time you
can't do that because you want
authenticity you want people to be real
chris matthews is real that's why he's
successful he says what he thinks you
may not like it you may not like the way
the guests came on the show he was a
surrogate for the campaign i wasn't
there then i had nothing to do wasn't a
circuit for the campaign he was a talk
show he was a
surrogate what do you say what you're
saying though is important that
the whole
cable tv business can be very upsetting
for anyone who has any self-respect i
mean
i i i forget it
i was going no i was going to i watched
cable tv only when they can make me do
it which is at the airport where i can't
not watch it so i got to the airport
because i was going to new york for cnn
they'd asked me on to discuss a very
serious subject i won't bore you with
what it was but i got i got to
national airport as bud board the plane
and the headline didn't say fat [ __ ]
dies but it could as well have done so
the nicole smith right which had checked
out right it's cruel of me to take the
ticket now and the hotel room because
i'm not going on tv tonight i know that
now i should really call and say i'm not
boarding the plane and i thought no
screw that i could use a night in new
york at someone else's experience
i won't call them till i get off the
plane at the other end and they said uh
oh great they're in the car yeah well
you know um you're not coming on i said
i i know that
i'm going to the essex house and i'm
going to order a very big dinner but
this unless of course you'd like to talk
about early course no i wouldn't yeah
right
but i mean you know they run the risk of
wearing out your patience right and i
think you know no one's saying chris
matthews isn't a nice guy or a smart guy
but at some point
whose responsibility is it
when there's guests that are on
who have not been pre-interviewed
clearly because chris matthews as a
smart guy because he challenged him on
it didn't the guy was not there and was
not smart on the issue and all chris did
was beat him up instead of somebody
getting a smart guy on the show
fairtending help me out here i'm not
gonna do that tammy i'm sorry but i
think i think i can add another kind of
example to this and why people turn to
the pop cultural the satirical side for
some of this coverage i mean all of us
up here represent some element of that
it's because there's something lacking
in some of the mainstream outlets you
know i saw cnn segment i was actually
part of a scene in the segment they were
talking about petraeus's testimony and
they spent maybe two and a half minutes
on patriarch's testimony about five
minutes on campaign slogans
and and the font choices and the color
and this is the day 24 hours my friend
but that relative but that relative that
decision
of twice as much time on logos and color
says something to the public and it says
something that i think with the onion
are very proud to say which is we
absolutely don't respect our readers
but we can say that
and be open about i think there's a
message that you get is the viewer or
the reader from one of those other
outlets of absolute disdain and it's
something that we can kind of have fun
with but there's something underneath of
that which also happens and it fills the
void i think too is you know
when you see chris on bill maher
and you see
real debate
in real conversations because you can't
craft a joke unless you have some
information and so people are making a
point
with information you might disagree with
the point but it does spark conversation
it does spark
dialogue but his show went off abc and
he's on hbo a premium channel i mean why
is it that he can't be on or anyone like
bill maher be on a network we've been
talking about cable but let's talk about
a network that was a network show there
was serious opinion issues people talked
about the show but he's off i mean i'm
not talking about the political issue
but there's a reason because the
american people want reality they want
to see things act out that gets back to
my question for christopher because it
people have posed this
yes the issue and the question is the
clinton campaign and i i'm by the way
i'm wearing a hillary clinton yellow for
you
the the question is did the clinton
campaign miss the boat in terms of
for example that the the videos they put
up on youtube everyone you know put
their videos up what is it seven out of
steve seven out of 16 candidates
announced on youtube but the videos that
they put up were the absolute opposite
of user gen videos that were just
regular people they were very slick
very highly produced someone said to me
made for tv movies do you think that
helped or hurt the campaign i don't know
why they call it youtube but all i know
about youtube is that anyone who wants
to see me
make an old speech again that i did very
well at the university of
chicago well
can go and do that and be induced to buy
my book it's a me tube it's for me
i don't know about you guys at all
but i like this me tube innovation i've
got to say
it's not the only thing the tension
campaign screwed up i think the main
thing that they screwed up and i really
really rejoice in saying this is that
uh the person they thought was their
secret weapon the great campaigner the
great political genius the great
ex-president revealed to a crucial
number of people something that most of
us already knew because he's a raging
psycho
and it's been very gratifying to see
people who could have caught up to that
ten or so years ago catching up to it
now when they think it was one
if there was only one reason why they
lost it'll have to be because of him
and that pleases me more than i can say
i feel
as if i'm going to have an orgasm in my
travels you think that
that while i'm working i do i've waited
a long time
do you think that part of that was on
purpose and how shocked they are sorry
do you do you think that bill clinton's
perhaps lackluster performance was to
was there any strategy
as they say in french in other words
subconsciously he wanted to lose do you
think so no i don't think so because it
would mean that he was in some awful way
back
um and i think he can't deny himself
anything like that i don't even think it
was lackluster
he
so the lackluster it wasn't it was right
it was ugly it was nasty it was it was
yeah it was very much there was nothing
what it was was there was a camera
following them everywhere following
every candidate everywhere and every
person i actually want to ask another
question about that since we're getting
so serious about the uh blogger the
citizen blogger maybe i should ask
citizen sugar this the citizen blogger
at um huffpost who is the one that asked
the questions of uh president clinton in
his angry response to the todd perdum's
article and vanity fair should she have
identified herself i'm going to ask
everyone on the panel i'll start with
you
interesting um
well i think that the
perhaps is going to be my answer because
um everyone has been empowered by the
internet to sort of be a journalist and
we need to start acting as though
everyone around us is a journalist
because we all have the capability of
publishing we all have the capability of
you know being in a fundraiser and
putting up the obama bitter comment it's
going to happen so i think that
maybe those rules and mores of the
traditional media don't apply as much
that we need to have a sort of base
understanding that everything we say is
public
veritende i uh i tend to agree that
that's the reality i think there's a
cost and a benefit to that and we're in
an awkward transition to the future we
know what the future is the future is
everything's live online all the time
minority report type of situation you
have access to anything you want any
form the politicians are now feeling the
brunt of that so everyone is a reporter
and they're trying to adjust and the
public is trying to adjust so what
happens now everything shocks us oh my
god obama said bitter oh my god mccain
smiled like oh my god
are these larger than life appearances
they won't shock us anymore when that's
every day it shocked us to see the
president on television it shocked us to
make a phone call across the globe but
now those are all normal behaviors so i
think the the reality that is live
streaming of everything is going to
become more normal and those
communications people who are up here
earlier are going to adapt their game to
adjust to that sort of new video ben
what i think is different it's the fact
that that this computer is sitting on
your desk it's not a tv across when you
have your feet up you got the kids
running around the dog there's 20 things
in the way no matter how big your screen
is right but when they're when you're
looking at someone
having a meltdown
and they're on your computer and they're
four inches it feels different doesn't
it it definitely does i mean really to
answer that question in the previous one
you know typically online something has
to have a lot of shock value to really
become part of the conversation which is
the reason why candidates advertising
which is typically so slick and
manufactured isn't going to pop on
youtube because what is it i'm saying
i'm for change in babies in the u.s and
you know for us a lot of what we're
trying to do is figure out ways to add
something shocking in it so the question
about you know should she have
identified herself well should she have
ethically i'm not really sure i'm not
from the journalism world but should she
have if she wanted to make a name for
herself that does work because had she
identified herself her answer would have
you know his answer would have been i
think what she did was inappropriate but
understand this as opposed to you know
calling her that's not what christopher
said he said he'd go crazy anyway right
yeah well you know he's not the
mr clinton isn't very tightly wrapped
and he's full of uh hatred and
loathing and unreason and he can't
contain himself anymore it's become very
clear yeah
and anything said
to a voter at a public campaign rally is
said for the record by definition and he
was great
are we talking about are we talking
about obama with the
with fowler walking going being at the
obama private campaign are you talking
about the well we were talking about
both the comments at the private i've
got a break i better break this to you
now we've been doing clinton for all
this time no no no no but and by the way
this is the google national journal
panel
oh my god
that everything is public and live all
same as when dick cheney doesn't know
the mic is on right and calls my friend
adam climber and [ __ ] and so on and
it doesn't realize
too bad
but don't we want them to be real i mean
isn't the whole point to learn who these
people are when we rather learn who they
are via this sort of medium then learn
who they are via their slickly produced
ad and a list of bullet points on their
website as long as we're ready for it i
think and that's the part that concerns
me a little bit is that i don't think
we've adjusted to seeing that side of a
candidate we still expect them to be
super human and super intelligent and
super articulate every single moment and
no one is
but as a voters we expect that of our
candidates even though we know we can't
do it ourselves they're not us they have
more money they have more education
they've got more training and management
so i think we're all due for a big
bubble popping when we realize that hey
their fart smell too
but what you said earlier was very good
also as as this happens more and more
and you see things like
uh
the president uh pulling at a door that
doesn't open you know in moscow right
people will also allow more for it it'll
be it will be less surprising
and it won't be it won't look so
brilliant to get it on the air either so
and that's there is a natural compass
yeah that uh correct we have to cross
that chasm of awkwardness
but seven million people
watched all 37 minutes of obama's race
speech
on youtube now that's there's plenty of
other media outlets where it was watched
seven million people did that list i
don't know about you but i'd kill for
that audience any night of the week
right
i mean i think that uh and ask any one
of them if they can quote two words from
it no well ask anyone if they did it at
work or ask anyone here how many did it
work
no no
okay then
ask anyone who didn't even watch all of
it what's some of it if you can remember
a single phrase from it who's got a
phrase racist grandma right here
yeah
apart from his grammy right
i mean there's a strategy behind how
they people said it was the gettysburg
address there's not a single memorable
phrase in it at all except for jumping
on grandma
anyway was the gettysburg address
memorable immediately yes i mean did
those people who were there that day
know that it was going to be what it was
they blogged it right after yeah
yes there was a there was a fight over
the uh figuring out what four score was
back of the envelope on which it was
written and uh and i think it was it was
recommended partly because
the opening speaker the curtain raising
speaker spoke for three hours
so the economy of the gettysburg address
in comparison uh recommended itself so
have a good warm-up act i think good but
the passage of time isn't going to make
people remember a word obama said in
philadelphia
one of the most boring speeches
then why did all these people watch it
because they want it to be true because
they want to be part of it well look
this is a guy who can make a speech
accepting the nomination or claiming it
rather saying this will be the moment
people will look back on as the time the
oceans stop rising
so just by getting the delegate count
he's arrested
the climate crisis i mean and no one
thinks it's funny except me this is a
megalomaniac
probably now the sea will stop rising
and that that'll do it yeah someone from
um south dakota just cast their super
delegate but i think there's an
assumption that seven or eight
so that you know then it must be viral
and everybody's watching it but you're
discounting the strategy that the obama
team has that they email it to a million
and a half people that they put it front
and center on their home page and so
then on youtube within eight hours it's
on youtube's homepage and then everybody
sees obama's grace speech and something
that might not have been sent around
otherwise suddenly it's a big quote
unquote viral video of the day but this
idea of viral as it used to exist of
this is how i send it to all your
friends is actually almost negligible
now that that rarely rarely happens
sometimes hucklebee will you know do an
ad with chuck norris and it's you know
so bizarre that it actually you know
crosses over and that to me is a really
interesting give me mary lou free bush
any time of him yeah i mean that's the
interesting dynamic is that like the the
candidates who were on the fringe like
mike revell uh you know and ron paul
were doing these really interesting
things online because they were willing
to take these chances and the candidates
like clinton and and obama even when
they tried to do something that was a
little bit different you could tell it
went through like 15 filters before it
actually hit youtube and and that's why
you know it didn't do that much and part
of the reason the crush on obama has you
know 50 million online views is because
it didn't have all those committees
along the way figuring out let's make
sure we don't offend anybody along the
way so you're saying committees are
wrong too let's see cable news networks
are bad committees are wrong
we haven't talked about senator mccain
and the republicans today we really
should what about their presence on
their web and what's happening in the
culture baratunde you're right in there
because you're more honest than cnn go
well here's the the fun part and again
i'll take it back to the journalism of
the onion is that while obama and
um clinton were doing this horse race
dance and the networks and everyone was
obsessed with that we had a good time
being able to talk about mccain in fact
if you could queue up in that video good
idea
let's show the video now from our
friends at the onion
he can get you to do anything he wants
shannon
i noticed that yeah
it's a killer smile
she does what you say
and a newsweek article released today
republican presidential candidate john
mccain said if elected he would cut 15
million dollars in government spending
by eliminating the need for the secret
service the decorated war hero said
quote you think i can't defend myself
from some whack job i've been to hell
and back and quote if someone tries
anything the secret service better be
protecting him not me mccain went on to
state that if elected during his
inauguration day parade he would ride in
a motorcade with the top down and if
quote someone even looks at me
cross-eyed i'll rip his guts out through
his throat and nail his ears to my
trophy wall in a conference call with
reporters mccain's campaign manager rick
davis called mccain very passionate
about his plans chow will also save the
government an estimated three million
dollars by eliminating the use of the
air force one now just piling himself
around as a decommissioned a4 skyhawk
the mccain campaign also released a
press statement earlier today which
includes a plan to save the nation an
additional half million dollars by
replacing the costly white house
security system with a series of traps
mccain will build himself out of wire
and sharpen sticks the 71 year old
vietnam veteran also issued a challenge
suggesting that instead of debates he
and obama be dropped naked into a forest
with only a hunting knife to see who
comes out alive putting a cigarette out
on his tongue mccain added the day i get
out tracked in the jungle is the day i
saw off my own balls
[Music]
[Applause]
so
i you know we don't like to deconstruct
what we do there so i won't go too much
behind but i think you see a lot of the
themes about mccain that are out there
and we've had an opportunity to to take
that on while everyone else is focused
on this side of the room and just to
back him up we did run that video with
the headline the onion is the only one
talking about mccain right now because
it was in the midst of the democratic
fight and they were the only ones who
were coming out and saying these kinds
of things and i think in order to
lampoon a subject as well as you guys do
you have to really know it you can't be
funny without the knowledge and you also
can't get the joke without doing your
homework do you feel like you're in
competition with colbert or jon stewart
along the way how do you guys do it
that's that's a really good question we
get that all the time and the short
answer is no we're kind of comedy
cousins because we're doing something
different they're really in that daily
news cycle of like this happened five
minutes ago here's our response and we
have a slightly longer arc to that so
it's a different it's on a different
spectrum of kind of the satire and news
game and what we try to do is write
things that will last 10 or even 20
years down the line but be tied into my
kitchen's video still on youtube right
right
tied into the zeitgeist enough that
it'll actually hey you might predict
something like we ran bill clinton screw
it i'm running for president and right
the week of south carolina though it was
written before that it just you could
feel it happening and so something like
that will last for a while when george w
bush took office i said this is i said
in this
presence and i ask forgiveness but there
are some shows that i think now people
laugh to show they get the joke not
because it's funny
yes they say so all john stewart has to
do is say bush's iq and make a face that
everyone knows to laugh
because that must be funny right but a
joke has not in fact been made no
information is has been produced no
uh
no background no backstory is required
it's a lifeline they might as well have
a laugh track
as do that um
well i'm not there anymore so i'm not
saying a comment but there is a term
called collector
which i think is real and it's when
people
hear something it's exactly what you're
saying and they go
and they clap like seals and it doesn't
evoke
out loud laughter hilarity like some of
the tapes we've seen but if there's a
recognition of you understand the
hypocrisy you're being shown
um but there also is the thing and i
feel
what chris is saying is an important
thing because
what exactly what you're talking about
separates really good satire doing the
homework and pointing out something um
satirically or just saying look isn't
bush stupid right i mean and that's
boring
i try never to do that i think that it's
not interesting and i think it's that's
a late night
comic monologue from the bigger shows
it's a pavlovian queue it just says yeah
is there a different rhythm to a
political joke
than a regular joke
a good one
a good one a good one i think a good
political joke tries to
uh
you know say something funny instead of
saying
mccain's old reagan's old you know i
just
you know hillary's whatever
you know what what what
i wanted people to say that are very not
very about her policies you'll feel
better you'll feel better if you're just
saying i'm not saying but i think the
other thing on anything on any joke and
maybe i'll even out carefully differ
with my hero over here and say that any
good joke whether it's political or
relationship is they have a lot of
things in common you know they're
communicating something they have to
meet someone's different premise they
have to be in someone's
experience but expenses does serve a
really important purpose in this
campaign in that it will let people have
discussions about things that they
wouldn't necessarily you're not going to
go to mother-in-law and talk about
abortion rights but you might go and
talk about what was on the daily show
last night or a hilarious joke about
abortion rights
but but new media political satire i do
think is different and that's to me
what's really exciting about it is
obviously satire has been around forever
and political cartoons you know hundreds
of years ago up to santa live and
everything now but with new media a
couple things i'm noticing one there's
this like conversation around everything
as soon as it happens you put a video on
youtube and there's 10 000 comments and
they're talking about new york times so
that kind of like interaction with the
user is really exciting to me the other
thing i'm finding with our videos and
it's almost the opposite of the clapter
where it's like oh if jon stewart said
it and it's about bush it's got to be
funny you know a lot of our videos are
embedded in blogs people have no idea
that we did it they have no idea what to
expect and a lot of times the blogs that
put them up there don't even tip off
what the joke is like that hillary and
bosnia thing most of the times the blogs
talked about it they would actually just
say oh guess what hillary actually
wasn't lying and just put the video
there so they got to kind of be in on
the joke to a degree and they weren't
you know tipping it off like jay leno or
letterman might on a late night bit and
say hey here's hillary in bosnia and you
know exactly what's coming by the way on
cable news we never fake that kind of
stuff
when it's a joke but if anyone has a
question if you dare take this panel on
please step over to the microphone and
we'll get to you so if you want to get
start moseying over there now please
feel free to do so brave souls out there
you brave soul
yes
get over there go ahead line it up my
friend we'll be ready to go bring it on
will we ever stop hearing that phrase by
the way he apologized for it again today
in in europe and the first time he
apologized what he said it was laura who
told him
that was a terrible thing you just said
his wife told him yeah she's it's
interesting how much influence she has
sir give us your name where you're from
who you're with and who your questions
for well uh my name is tony cerise and
due to the nature of the question i'll
plead the fifth on who i'm with because
it has nothing to do with where i'm from
but i used to i used to be in radio with
a clear channel radio station uh group
in out in montana and it was in uh
i can't remember if it was the summer of
2000 or 2001 but every single news
network was talking shark attacks
all summer long
and the total number of shark attacks
that summer had been six with something
like two fatalities how many in montana
none
but what was what was what we had what
we had dug up is we had found that
actually up to that point that year
there had been seven deaths seven deaths
by of people who had been crushed
by vending machines
because they lock their their candy bar
didn't come out so they start shaking
that thing and it falls over on them and
and they're done are you with baratunde
what's that are you a parrot sunday no
oh okay just checking and and and i'm
just wondering what uh you know what the
mentality is maybe in in
in in our news media today that just
prays on that on that on that fear
factor and and how they all do it kind
of in synchronicity i love it i love it
on the daily show now when something
comes up and they immediately cut to a
montage of every single news network
talking about the exact same thing using
the exact same talking points bullet
points and then they complain about
being fed these bullet points they're
going to use
so how do we get away from that or can
we get away from it blondes and peril
are sexy
you get a blonde in peril you can milk
that thing for a whole wild animal
most scary most scary words on tv
breaking news yeah all they have to do
is point the camera at some disaster
there's no work
no research no thought it's bringing you
but not even uh there are there are no
there is no school shooting problem in
america there isn't one really and if
the to say that it's been going down all
the time the the abducted children of
milk gardens fictional satanic child
abuse fictional but always works and
requires no thought no effort just that
a lot of innocent people get arrested
for crimes that they haven't committed
but to your specific question
to your specific question again
defending cable news
like they need to be defended but um
there's no pictures of people getting
crushed by the vending machines well i
didn't see anybody getting hit by a
shark either
and there are helicopters who travel
around the scene and people are
mesmerized how many people have been
mesmerized by a helicopter going around
around watching it on tv waiting for
something to happen because there's
nothing else on tv
how about satellite i'll give you a
couple brochures oh i would change the
channel i actually would watch someone
pulling a vending machine
i mean that's kind of i'm not so sure
about the shark attacks that's over too
quickly i always and you
he set it up that was a really good
question on everything it's on every
channel
i do politics i don't do sharks i'm
sorry i wasn't part of that trend i was
there
who is brave who is brave i want to
while someone gathers their courage
please go ahead walk over here's my
question well let's go to her first but
think about this ladies and gentlemen
this fall campaign this campaign has
been dominated by new media
you start thinking about so you can tell
the audience what's going to happen this
fall that's new that we should look out
for hi there go ahead i had a quick
question but you didn't say who you were
yet my name is sarah and i work at abc
news um oh abc news
hey i'm in the um.com digital portion as
well so
but it's a question that we have that my
friends and i have been talking about in
and outside the office and
the question is
what are the perils when candidates kind
of reach a rock star celebrity status
because i think one of the things that
we love about celebrities today is that
we love to watch their rise but we also
love to watch them fall
and what are the parallels of that and
what happens when you know bon jovi
right or brittany rises and falls i mean
brittany's not taking away your health
care or giving you health care so how
did that how does that parallel at all
and well what's the fault that the media
is going to focus on you know i mean i
guess i would ask uh
so often you know i wasn't at the howard
dean defining moment screaming but you
talked you could watch it on cable i did
over and over thanks to you welcome um
and but those who were in the room said
that it didn't seem as big as life as
the way the media portrayed it i don't
know it's like reliving richard nixon's
debate come on get in the modern media
get a tv look at it
but you know what there's a difference
between but that's the whole thing it is
politics is about media it's how you
appear on tv it's okay so anyone messes
up it's defined by the media is a giant
mess up and that's the fault the bottom
line is you shouldn't fall in love with
politicians they're politicians no
matter what they are you shouldn't
you know it's like how much you've built
like how much um sort of public leeway
you've kind of banked up you know how
much it's the the fourth heart attack
it's like how much are people willing to
forgive before it sort of changes what
it means and
and how people are going to respond to
it christopher well it's a matter of
whether you want charisma in a
politician
or not or whether
it should be just what the constitution
says it is
any citizen can do it you need only
average integrity you pick up the
garbage you defend the frontiers of the
country you take care the laws are
faithfully executed and you don't try
and be a star of any other kind
that that should be nice
that would be people think no i want i'm
looking for love in all the wrong places
i i want a politician who i can adore
who loves me or cares about me
um and that's that can be very dangerous
because that's the origin of demagogy
which is the origin of
totalitarianism it means somewhat
someone is going to one day promise you
a lot a great deal
um in in exchange for something rather
sinister i think there's no i'm sorry
i think there's something very
frightening about somebody who actually
would like jobs like that anyway because
it goes very much to your point where
it's like
they've sat down they've looked at
themselves and they said do you know
what's wrong with the world i'm not in
charge and that's
fatally bizarre so wait a minute you
don't like the cable networks right you
don't like the web videos and now you're
blaming the candidates what videos don't
i like i don't know ben wait no you're
just you
know you don't like you
sharks you don't like sharks i didn't
say i said i didn't okay first you
didn't like hillary this is what's wrong
with cable news she's saying you need
things i
you were turning against your moderator
and host
please come back to me i'll just what i
will do is i'll get in a fight with it
back to your question
um which is you know you see it
happening already i mean a to be
successful we built a culture i'm gonna
be a little serious i'm sorry where like
celebrity gets you places and we like
that and we like that they're distant
from us and that they're special they
eat places we could never afford and
vacation in places we could never get to
but we also love when they od and have a
thousand kids out of wedlock and crash
their cars driving cocaine you know with
cocaine spilling in their laps so this
will happen like the beautiful things
that you can guarantee and you already
saw the reverend right thing was a great
like test run for obama because there
was a lot of like positive stuff and
then all of a sudden was like do you
love america why aren't you wearing your
flag are you really a muslim like
where'd that come from i thought he was
like the super jesus guy
and now like you're questioning if he's
american
so that it'll keep coming back around we
we push him up we bring him down and
questioning if he's a muslim but after
the preacher problem
not yeah that case or in that case he
had everyone lining up to suck on him
and he had to do that he brought it all
on himself none of that was imposed upon
him reverend he decided to go to that
church he got married there he had his
children baptized there he gave money to
that thought but he stepped away too all
of it and when he when he was asked to
announce it he said well it seems like
the guy doesn't care enough about my
campaign so i'll discern him no none of
this was done by us to him everyone in
the press wished it hadn't happened they
still do that
still do i think and that's why that's
why the unquotable forgettable nothing
philadelphia speech is still considered
to be one of the greatest addresses by
any politician ever made and no one here
has yet quoted a two words from it but i
i just wanted to addre nor will they
ever
we're wrapping up go ahead ben i just
want to say it seems like it kind of
ties into the political satire thing
that a lot of times people like to find
one thing to hone in on the candidate
and that's their thing and i remember
reading the clinton they actually really
liked that they ate a lot of fries was
the thing that people picked on because
people weren't going to not vote for him
for that but the al gore being boring or
the hillary clinton being controlling or
felt like it was inevitable you know
when
when political satire kind of like hones
in on one subject about pers about a
person i feel like sometimes that is
what kind of starts what you're saying
the backlash and then all of a sudden
and i talked to one comedian who was
saying that they don't know you know
what what's going to be the thing that
people make fun of about obama i don't
really know if i've seen it yet but that
you know part of the thing i think we
were making fun of in the crush on obama
video was this idea of him as kind of a
pop star but there's going to be plenty
again no no there will be but my point
is i guess it seems like all of a sudden
like i didn't know al gore was boring
until all of a sudden sounded live
started hitting that over the head and
also i was like i guess he's boring and
you know you asked the question before i
wouldn't wouldn't you know wouldn't yeah
yeah wouldn't everything and um you know
you asked a question before about like
do we would be good
competitors i mean i for me when we
create videos i think we're like this
would be amazing if the onion the daily
show somebody there saw and liked it
like it's the opposite on our end when
we just start a year ago but i'm like
honored to be on the stage with this
group and for to a degree i think part
of that reason is i never felt like the
daily show or the onion like
pigeon-holed one person and then just
beat him over the head for that one
thing
and they and they found like that day
story and found something really
original and innovative about that story
to key in on and i always had so much
respect for that and that's what i hope
you know we can do a little bit well i
mean yeah i mean i hope that
in doing that and doing the new project
i'm doing now to me
political satire um it's just it's we're
it's we have a different mindset than
the annie and you guys are amazing
i i just rely on urgency i really like
to be able to see that something happens
breaking news do it yes breaking n yes
all the bells and whistles breaking
breaking news
we've talked a little bit backstage
about this we have a different challenge
at the end but we were sliding up that
skin when we did a breaking news mobile
text alert when hillary dropped out and
said you know senator hillary clinton
has ended up bid for president despite
having won already in february 2007
right and that goes out to a whole bunch
of people we have other things that are
kind of you know newspapers write obits
well before people die right just to
have them on file so there's certain
things there and we're with the website
and with doing things online we're also
adding new things we have a google map
we're actually at google and uh you know
plotting the campaign stops you should
really make a journalism handbook so
everyone here could follow all your
policies i want to thank everyone on the
panel if you'll help me thank you
great job
and next time we'll tell you all about
the future of the internet right thanks
for being
thanks very much for joining us today
folks uh if you can uh please join us
for a drink up on the roof
uh just go to the elevators and folks
will escort you up there again thanks
for coming
some sad news to pass on to you this
afternoon according to the associated
press the host who turned nbc's meet the
stolen and lost art belong a panel at
the new york times arts and leisure
weekend discusses what to do with art
from ancient civilizations
writer christopher hitchens and sharon
waxman who's written a book on lost art
are two of the panelists this is about
an hour and fifteen minutes
thank you
good afternoon everyone i'm tom kalaga
of the new york times and it is my great
pleasure to welcome you to the time
center for our eighth annual arts and
leisure weekend
over the next hour we explore one of the
most pressing cultural questions of our
time
namely where do the great treasures of
ancient art rightfully belong
we are privileged to be joined by three
renowned experts on this subject whose
work whether as journalists authors
scholars or leaders of some of the
world's great art institutions has done
much to shed light on this topic
you will hear much more about these
esteemed panelists from our moderator
as a new york times culture reporter
covering classical music and dance he
has reported on everything from the new
york philharmonic's historic trip to
north korea last spring
to elliot carter's centennial birthday
concert at carnegie hall last month
this past year he's also chronicled the
exploits of gerard mourier leading new
york city opera classical music patron
alberto villar being sent to jail
and on a lighter note the distracted
virtuosi who have inexplicably left
their multi-million dollar musical
instruments behind in taxi cabs trains
restrooms and even front door steps
please join me in welcoming our
moderator dan waken and our special
guests james cuno christopher hitchens
and sharon waxman
[Applause]
hello everybody
um it's good to be here i've lost my
voice this morning so that means they'll
have to talk more than me
hopefully um
so we're going to talk a bit about
works of art and artifacts in museums
and where they came from how they got
there and should they stay or should
they go
the jumping-off point is sharon's book
loot which is uh sort of a comprehensive
look at various issues um and
in reading it i i came up with sort of
two categories of works one
things that were
dug up torn away removed in the early
19th century
early 20th century brought to the great
museums in
paris london new york
and have become part of those museums
and sort of part of the fabric of that
the other category are objects that have
been found in recent years things that
have been suddenly emerged on the market
in 1980 1990 and find their way into
museums and are the subject of a
different kind of controversy
so i thought we'd start out with the
first category and we have some slides
and
i'm going to show a series of three
slides um if we can go through one two
and three and then maybe sharon can talk
a little bit about what they are and why
they're important sure well i think to
put the the issues of
uh category one and category two which
is uh objects that were looted or
plundered otherwise uh appropriated the
past 200 years ago 150 years ago are in
fact connected to these uh restitution
battles that we're seeing emerge on the
front pages or the culture pages of
newspapers and journals and magazines
today which is you when you have these
countries that uh were
the
where these things were dug up they're
called source countries that are now
demanding things back uh you have to
really go back to the origins of the
plunder or of the origins of the
creation the core creation of the great
collections of our great museums to
understand what's at the heart of this
which is what the book tries to do so a
great example of this is egypt because
egypt was literally
um
some people call it the rape of egypt
there's a wonderful book called the rape
of the nile by brian fagan one of the
early books on the topic that talk about
this the kind of free-for-all of a you
know just grab fest that egypt became in
in the 19th century after napoleon uh
invaded and conquered and then lost it
to the british and his he had a military
purpose of course for doing so but in
the course of doing that he just he uh
brought ancient egypt to the eyes of
europe which hadn't kind of been aware
of the wonder the wondrous beauty of
ancient egypt that we're all kind of
familiar with every day the sphinx the
pyramid well these were these were very
vague notions to europeans at that time
so
um
just to give you an example of the kind
of
outrages essentially that happened in
the 19th century in egypt um i was given
access to
by by egypt's chief archaeologist his
name is zahi hawas if you see anything
egyptian you've seen the guy he has his
indiana jones hat and he's constantly
very passionately excited talking about
all the beauties of egypt and what they
discovered and it's usually right before
some discovery channel special starring
him on television but anyway um
part of the fact that he loves being in
the media he's right there's a lot of
stuff out there that um that was taken
that was taken in kind of horrifying
ways and that we're not aware about
aware of it so he gave me access to all
of the tombs in the valley of the kings
um
which is where the pharaohs were buried
you probably know that this particular
tomb is the tomb of amenophus 3. it has
never been opened to the public
and i took this photograph
in pitch black love my camera
but you could just see
um that's that i really thanks the
digital technology that i was able to
get this image this is look at how
beautiful and of course this is not the
most uh you know if we had light in the
tomb you'd see how vivid the colors are
amanophus iii one of the great pharaohs
um and this is him uh side by side with
the various gods anubis etc and if we
can see the next this slide and then the
next one please you can see how somebody
came into the 19th century and just cut
out three of the heads of the pharaoh
boom boom boom boom
um and then let's we don't know exactly
uh who cut them out but what we do know
is that today next slide please
they are in uh the louvre and that is
the that is the head of one of those
three and all three of them are in the
louvre you can go see them today they're
in the sully wing
so um you know zahi hawas has asked for
five major pieces back from western
museums including the boston museum of
fine arts the louvre the british museum
and two german museums this is not these
these heads are not among the pieces
that he's asked for but you just get a
sense of um the feeling of disfoliation
that uh egyptians who are passionate
about archaeology and their past
feel when when the subject arises let's
let's give another example of that
number four please let me share and tell
us what this shows so this is actually
uh one of the objects that zahi hawas
does want back this is the zodiac
ceiling or that would that's the
replica it's a that black blobby thing
in the top is a black
plaster cast that the louvre sent
to the to egypt in the 19th century um
after
um
i was saying archaeologist an adventurer
and his agent
uh uh jean-jacques solnier
spent 21 days hacking this ceiling out
of the temple of dandera which is this
stunning temple that stands in the
middle of these marshes the nile used to
flow right up to it it's two th it's two
thousand years old um
and it is one of the earliest recorded
uh zodiacs that we have so if you were
to see it better um
well if you see it as it was actually
drawn in situ before it was blasted out
of there by napoleon's scientists who
came with it you could really see you
could see scorpio and libra you can
actually see recorded an eclipse at a
certain time in about 2000 about about
um about just before
the birth of christ essentially so
it's uh it's really an amazing piece of
history in addition to being an artifact
and it's in the loof today it took 21
days for the french to hack it out of
the sea out of the ceiling which is on
the rooftop of the temple of dandera
they finally used um gunpowder to blast
it out and that's how they got the thing
to france let me ask jim um as a museum
director should these kinds of artifacts
be returned to egypt
well first i think we have to recognize
that history is an untidy is untidy and
it's a complicated situation in this
case it's not just that and i'm looking
down here because we can actually see
the images here in front of us but uh
it's not just that the uh that this
period of time in the latter part of the
18th century early part of the 19th
century was a time in which the
europeans became interested in things
ancient uh in egypt but it's also at a
time in which by virtue of the europeans
becoming interested in those things then
that the local peoples became interested
as well they had lived for centuries
then amongst these things but of course
they
reasonably believed that the values of
their civilization call it um began with
with the prophet with prophet muhammad
and that these pagan artifacts had no
relationship to the life they lived or
the civilization
that they claimed
for themselves so it wasn't uh it wasn't
this was something that was prized and
as and as glory of
the ancient uh uh of the current
egyptians when the when the french and
the british were there it was something
that came upon later and in fact the
first as it were local history of
of ancient egypt was written by an
egyptian who had studied in france and
got caught up in the kind of fervor of
nationalism uh in in paris and sweeping
europe in the middle part of the 19th
century so
it is not its history is never so neat
and tidy as we would like it to be and
these these questions of restitution are
also questions about how and on what
terms might we rewrite history they're
based on the premise that uh
there's a way to correct the imbalances
historical imbalances of power we want
to
redress them in some way uh now so
i don't
i i don't think there's a claim for
these objects from
and using them generally speaking um uh
that have that were removed prior to
their
laws being against their removal in
other words we can now go back and say
this is
180 years before egypt passed such a law
so there's no legal reason why they
might be returned is there is there a
moral reason
uh that's the question is there more
reason what terms might there be moral
reason might it be there's a moral
reason because there's some
claim that the modern state of egypt has
on the remains of an ancient
civilization from which they have long
been divorced to which they have no
other contact than physical proximity
and only more or less fiscal proximity
because the egyptian empire of course
was spread much greater than the current
egyptian state i think the complication
and it's raised in the question asked of
this uh symposium do these things belong
to the to the civilizations that create
them first of all there's a big debate
in question whether civilizations create
anything or whether it's people who
create things and then we put them
together in the framework we call
civilizations but whether there is you
can map a civilization to the confines
of a current state
and i think that those are unequal
political uh realities civilization is
not political in those terms we're
talking about it the state is political
and they don't even share the same
geographic uh uh same boundaries and
geographical boundaries so
i i don't see there is a claim i think
the only way these things can be
returned is because it's to the
advantage of the current
uh uh possessor of these now that in
other words when the parthenon marbles
and christopher's written powerfully on
it will they be returned to athens only
i think if the british government thinks
it's in its
own best interest to do so i don't think
it's going to be on moral grounds it's
not going to be on our historical or
scientific grounds i think it's a matter
of public and political diplomacy
what you're saying is that the british
then if it's in their interest they
should return the marbles because they
happen to happen no no i'm saying they
will do so only when it is in their
interest i'm not saying should they do
so i'm just saying that's the political
reality of the situation there isn't a
legal claim on them as there's no legal
claim on this that can be decided uh it
can only be because the possessor
current possessor thinks it's in their
best interest to do so well the um
but not use up your function though mr
chairman please
the question i was hoping you would ask
was would there be such thing as
aesthetic grounds if we're discussing
art i think the aesthetic should have a
role in it
and
the case in the
uh
in the instance of the parthenon of the
sculpture of the parthenon is precisely
that the committee that i'm a member of
in london used to be called the
committee for the restitution of the
pathnome
it's now called the committee for the
reunification of them and i i just like
to say if i count a few words about how
that nuance
matters and the the sculpture of phidias
that adorns the this magnificent
building or did used to adorn it
um it's carved as a unity it tells a
story it's partly derived from
the path and i procession
um there are all kinds of
interpretations about how many
numbers of human figures there are in it
and whether they are the equivalent of
the greek casualties of a certain famous
battle and so forth but at any rate
it doesn't make much sense to have one
half of them in athens
and one half in london
um
you can't move the whole of the
parthenon to london to bloomsbury
but if for example
during the napoleonic wars the um
the panel of the mona lisa had been as
did happen to quite a lot of artifacts
um the next plundered and then sawn in
half by somebody
and we knew that one half of it was in a
gallery in stockholm and another in a
gallery in lisbon i'm pretty sure there
would be a mass movement of aesthetic
curiosity to see what the two hours
would look like if they were put
together probably the a strong guess
could be made they'd look better
um than they do so well i think the same
could be said actually has to be said of
the parthenon sculpture now there are
not very many examples of that but
sharon's just given you and particularly
vivid and beautiful and if i may say so
very beautifully illustrated it seems to
be perfectly clear that the louvre ought
to say it's a matter of aesthetic
wholeness and integrity can i disagree
with you
i mean i i do think the mona lisa the
example is um
um
not not appropriate in the situation or
not relevant because the assumption is
that you would have the entire thing and
it would be split in two parts and come
back together as the entire thing and if
that were the case likely it would be
resolved in those terms and the two
museums would share them that would be
the lot it happens many times uh in this
case and in the case of the parthenon
marbles uh they the the parthenon
marbles as you know very well would not
be restored in their entirety there
would be
fragments of them restored and there
would be great gaps
if we have slide 30 please
and and so there and that's the first
questions that it's not going to be
restoring the integrity of the parthenon
itself or of its sculptured program
but secondly um there's been no
suggestion and there's it would be very
difficult to do this uh to share
the entirety between athens and london
and it's not just london after all you
know among london's got the largest
uh bits of the of the parthenon marbles
outside of athens but they're also in
other places in europe and so forth so
it's it's not quite as yes
most of the smaller holders have have
given or are giving you that exactly
because the acropolis museum you're
quite right in saying that the
they can't be put back on the building
um and that also some of them have been
lost the entire thing can't be restored
but you will be able very soon to see
uh the whole of the sculpture of videos
in one place or you would be if the
british government would in in a gallery
that
overlooks the that looks at the past
you'll be able to get to to restitution
which is about
the rights of the shall we call for now
the indigenous if that doesn't sound too
colonial i mean the the napoleonic
expedition to egypt was a classical
orientalist expedition but it was not
just for pillage it was for
enlightenment for um anthropology he
attached his fleet in his army a huge
number of scholars map makers and so
forth it actually was is credited by
many egyptians with having so to be
dynamized what had been a very stagnant
uh province of the ottoman empire and
brought it into the in many ways into
the modern world
um
for example there was a periodic officer
his name was champonio who came across a
stone
in the sand
um
sort of try a three-sided bar
um
one
barb or egyptian heist with its and one
other barb or greek and i think the
other had he demotic
um
it was fairly easy to work out from that
how to decode
egyptian hieroglyphics which no egyptian
knew how to do because the egyptians of
that stage were arabs this they're part
of the arab conquest
um
every bit of every buddhist alien and
outside is the is the islamic arab
conquest as would the french or british
one have been now this question is
uh who are we dealing with in the case
of greece
it is to borrow t.s eliot's wonderful um
expression which is itself taken from
james joyce
it's in after strange gods the same
people living in the same place
roughly you can save the inhabitants of
africa
that their language is pretty much
recognizably greek
and that it's being spoken in the same
city on the same peninsula as
was prettier and sophocles
so that seems to be a rather stronger
claim um but why isn't any egyptian
claim because i think i think it's
perfectly okay the rosetta stone is in
the british museum it should stay there
i don't think it's about
i don't believe it's up to us to tell
the people who live in the borders where
these ancient civilizations
physically
exist that they are not the heirs to
that civilization why not the reason why
there's a couple of reasons why one is
it's not up to us to do genetic testing
on people and to say well you're not
actually the genetic error and therefore
it's not but it's not on the basis of
what makes that i have had so many
people write to me since this book has
come out during the research of this
book and and make the most racist kinds
of remarks along those lines so that
that's sort of where the conversation is
to say there are no more than to say
there are no more babylonians there are
no more syrians there aren't any no one
can make a claim saying this is ours
that would be the race surely
it is not a racist claim i don't think
the the comments that have been made
here at all but it's racialist in a
sense that it puts it in a racial
context and and and ties the connection
uh or the or the the legitimacy of the
claim to whether or not those people are
um actual the heirs of that civilization
to me that sort of falls in the category
of there are no palestinians back in the
ancient arab israeli conflict well that
you know they don't there is no such
thing as a palestinian which golden
mayor famously said i mean if the
egyptians
there's an important issue here which is
the civilizat the heirs to those
civilizations who physically live among
them are ultimately responsible
for the care of those artifacts if we
are trying to convince them that they
are not really connected to those things
then they can say well we don't care
about them and they'll allow them to
deteriorate and be destroyed and that
and i think there is obedience what we
think is that are they pardon me they're
not as obedient to what we say or we
think as all that
well that's true that's true too and
happily so but
if if we're trying to undermine the
scent their sense of connection to that
then that is ultimately a self-defeating
uh uh way of thinking for all of us who
cherish these treasures because
ultimately the people in turkey are
going to have to take the most care of
the antiquities that are in their
physical geography they can't what if
they can't what if well before that
that's true
sharon has a good story about that but
the question of civilization and turkey
is a perfect example of this because
what is the civilization that is there i
mean is it greek is it roman is it uh is
it uh ottoman is it modern republican
turkish uh how does one map this thing
if you think uh that the the greek
things ought to be returned to
with the greeks the greek civilization
well it turns out that of course for
hundreds of years the southern part of
italy was a colony of greece magnolia or
meghalayas uh the greater greece and so
those things that are then in the
southern part of italy ought they be
turned to greece because there are
greeks now if there is something sorry i
can ask that very easily okay then don't
let me save you some time perhaps
you answered briefly but i'll get on to
my second i'll get to my second point
very quickly that if there is some uh
let's say racial link between these
things if one can call if you can if
these things are imprinted with
greekness in some profound way and they
therefore on those terms ought to be
with greeks greeks don't only live in
athens or don't only live in greece in
fact greeks live in london and so if
there's a claim that they should be in
the company of greeks greeks live all
around the world and therefore these
things ought to be all around the world
it is to the benefit on those terms of
greeks that they should be in the
company of this where they live i i just
think that that those kinds what about
non-greeks who live in greece well
i promised i was going to make this easy
for you um
the government and people of greece have
never demanded the return of anything
except the parthenon novel well the
remainder of the half of the parthenon
sculpture wrongly called elgin it has to
be called elgin under under the terms
under which parliament i think illegally
bought the sculpture
um the elgin family insisted they have
to be called that in the collection it's
the parthenon marvel can we tell why do
they only ask for the return of that
well first i'll say why they don't ask
for the return of anything else they
because there's one one reason you give
me a alas
um
large parts of anatolia
what's now is mia smyrna uh large parts
of italy um and so forth uh we're once
part of greece um that's the first thing
the second thing is no museum of
civilization anywhere in the world
the museum purported to show how our
civilization as humans evolved would be
complete without some greek artifacts
and the greeks think that that's
excellent they want there to be greek
sculpture all over the world in diaspora
like this it's just that it makes no
sense to have half of
a unified piece of sculpture that's a
piece of literature as well as a piece
of sculpture it tells a story
in one place especially when it comes
from what can be reasonably called
the national temple of the greeks
the national temple the national temple
of the people of egypt is not the
pyramids
temple of ancient
egyptian
civilization before the arab and muslim
conquest right of which it isn't
symbolic in the least well you can't
move the pyramids happily so that's all
right but but the point of the national
temple of greece is extreme reporting
christopher's book is powerful on this
uh but you have to remember that uh the
the history of this of this uh this this
part this temple this temple was a greek
temple as we think of it today for um a
number of years it was for equal number
of years a a church a christian church
it was for equal number of years um a
mosque it was the it was blown up by the
venetians the mosque was no longer
usable on those terms so they created a
second smaller mosque on the site when
finally the greeks
won independence from the ottomans they
created a kingdom with a 17 year old
bavarian king
who hired his father's favorite
architect the bavarian architect leo von
klenza whom you all know from being the
center part of munich to create the
national symbol the national temple the
acropolis and the parthenon and he gave
this great speech in the company of of
the 17 year old bavarian king who said
that on you on the on this sacred land
we have removed all the emblems of
barbarity from it because the first
thing they had to do to create a
national temple was to get rid of all
the accretions of the byzantines and of
the of the of the ottomans
and so so when when these national
monuments are made they are literally
made it's a political act it's not
a a cultural act it's not a historical
act it's not a scientific act that was
made
an historic sentence the historic temple
of of modern greece
after all it was athenian it wasn't uh
you know it wasn't spartan uh it wasn't
another city state monument it was an
athenian monument and also it's a temple
to a danish religion that's all yeah
right
if the sculptors were in athens today
you wouldn't suggest that they be
removed to another
place so they'd be so they could be
shared with the world or shared with
other greeks
um you know what i think chris i'm all
for it i mean you're all for it uh yeah
i think i think we ought to be arguing i
think we ought to be uh uh ought to be
arguing more about how it is that we can
work to share the world's artistic
legacy with the world all right i agree
with that but i think that there's so
many self-serving arguments uh that come
from the museum world about these issues
and what happened to the parthenon uh
it's all very genteel and very and very
civilized today but what happened at the
time was a really uh violent act
actually i mean you had lord elegance
people
hacking the sculptures off the top you
see along the rim of the building which
is now empty they've all been taken down
because of the pollution they can't be
outside anymore but the the meadowpiece
they were hacked out and this was
actually you could there's no really
valid legal argument but you really
there are legal people who like to argue
about it because it seems pretty clear
if you read that the permit that was
given him at the time that he
absolutely breached the limits of he was
supposed to take the sculptures that
were on the ground and from day one they
started hacking at the building i think
if you we if we don't kind of bring
those
parts of history into the open you can't
really talk honestly about what is the
right thing to do with these with these
sculptures today we all we all believe
that we should preserve them we all
believe that we should share them we all
believe that we want them to be
available
to as many people as possible all of
those are values that have to be
balanced with
recognizing history placing it in
context the integrity of the building
itself as a piece of artwork
as a as a as a piece of history and as a
symbol of um what is the
what we all look back to in western
civilization as the kind of the
beginnings of democracy itself i mean
there are those are all values that have
to be balanced but i think that we can't
just pretend that what happened to the
parthenon um at the hands of colonial uh
empires and a very um
you know obsessive
lord who was a diplomat and an envoy of
the british empire is it was not a very
violent act
why isn't that enough just to be open
what if all museums just
said you gave the complete truth about
the acquisitions
i don't believe they'll do let's say
they did though would that be enough and
would that sort of solve
well i'm not the decider here so
i think that's the place to start the
british museum does a very good job of
being very clear and transparent about
the history of of these objects and i
have to say that you know we have to
recognize and
elgin's associates who remove these
things and we don't have the the actual
firm and the actual document we've got
as is because we're reproducing in the
book that we've got the italian
translation that's held privately by a
british citizen so we don't we're not
really close enough to understand what
the original document was and what
license it was given to his associates
but they just didn't do this overnight i
mean this took weeks and weeks there's
something surreptitious
and so if they wanted this not to happen
if somebody wanted this not to happen it
could have been prevented you know this
wasn't something that just was stolen
the greeks pointed out there is that
athens at that point was under foreign
occupation yeah by author by turkish
authorities who regarded it as a
rather backward province and certainly
for the most part didn't care
about the the greatness of the heritage
so but they were legitimately the
ottomans
some years to go before it's independent
legally yes um but that's why it does
matter i think that it's very clear that
elgin
uh over
over interpreted should we say uh the
terms of what he'd been allowed to take
away
some some stones some small stones of
little value i think are the ones that
are mentioned
um
then of course he
the version when she takes them back to
england gets sunk
the first shipment sunk yeah that could
have been all she wrote
so as it happens it's possible to
recover this though it might very well
not have been which is why i i argue uh
for the distribution of things uh
because you want to distribute the risk
to them if they were all in one place be
that one place london or berlin 1945 or
or new york and 911 or or baghdad or
kabul today you're concentrating the
risk the risk to of their extraordinary
destruction destruction of great deal of
them is great if you distribute them
around the world you distribute the risk
for the people i've already said that i
agree with you about that as do the
government and people of greece they
want a greek jasper of sculpture but i i
can't think that i really understood you
correctly when or that you understood
chad's question correctly when she said
if the
whole sculpture of health and was now in
athens
and it never been that you would still
be in favor of halving it and
partitioning it and taking office of
bloomsbury
well in this case uh first of all you
know that the place was a wreck and a
ruin before elgin came to it but let's
assume that it was pristine and
everything that was made for it was
still on it no one would ever argue for
its removal from an art from a an
architectural monument uh you would
argue instead for portable objects to be
shared and distributed so that's to
clarify but but in this case
it was never
the children come in the
splendor you know the exhibition is
constantly on the move yeah anything
that's mobile and portable absolutely
but in this case the hypothetical
is you know is only that i mean it had
not been an entire monument for a
thousand years yes before elgin it had
been in a ruin for 200 years before
elgin for sure but it had been a church
it had been a mosque it had been all
kinds of
armstrong which blew up yeah yeah the of
course the the juvenile gallery in in
the british museum was hit by the nazis
and destroyed the day after the marbles
had been moved into the london
underground system yeah so they were
just they're very nearly open there's no
safe place and of course that's why they
shouldn't be only in one place all their
patenter and veneer was removed by being
cleaned with wire brushes
uh barbaric actually not not museum
like twenty percent british museum has
never been able to give a decent account
of the way it vandalized the marbles
while
they were in its care so it's a it's a
very the more you examine the british
case that they helped to save them by
taking them away the more shall be that
case become let's move on to another
more portable piece um let's look at
slide 15 and maybe sharon could talk a
bit about this and yeah
yeah just to show you that that that
this is a pretty complicated question
and i myself am not
on one side of the issue or the other
this is a story that i tell in the book
about the return of um a cache of
beautiful gold and silver objects from
the lydian civilization it's referred to
as the lydian horde and i'll just try to
give you a very summarized story it's
wonderfully colorful yarn but basically
um
there was
a cache with about 360 pieces that were
dug up and smuggled out of the country
and sold to the metropolitan in the
1960s and kept in their storerooms and
never acknowledged because they didn't
quite you know they were waiting in to
see if they could kind of
guide it quietly into their collection
without anybody noticing this is at a
time when these kinds of things went on
much more commonly than they do today
and there was a
turkish journalist who's the character
you'll meet in the book if you read it
oscar najar who had heard about this and
there were some leaks of this that had
been out in the times of london and he
spent um 16 years dogging this story 16
years going back to the town uh the
small one horse town called ushak in
central anatolia asking about it nobody
would talk to him nobody want to talk
about it little by little they opened up
he's a political journalist he did this
in his spare time
and then he actually was posted to new
york or he i think being a freelance
journalist and moved to new york and we
visited the met all the time
occasionally to see if these pieces
would ever show up on display because he
could never get an answer out of the med
as to whether they had this cash uh
called the lydian horde or not and uh in
fact in 1985
he was visiting the museum and saw that
they he saw pieces that he recognized
because he had by that point he'd
already made very good contacts and good
friends with the townspeople of usha and
they had described the pieces to him so
he knew exactly what he was looking for
and they were on display labeled east
greek treasure which is not actually
what they were from the libyan
civilization which is um
precedes the greeks but anyway
he flew back to turkey took the evidence
to the greek culture to the turkish
culture ministry and turkey actually
sued the met
for having illegally bought smuggled
treasures so this became acosta level
was the first major case
lawsuit under american law of a major
american cultural institutions during
the course of discovery they found that
in fact the board of trustees at the met
knew perfectly well you could tell from
the notes of their meeting that they
were buying something that had been
smuggled so before anything went to uh
court the met cave they gave the lydian
horde back and it was returned to turkey
with great fanfare lots of parties the
president himself opened the box and
big press conference children drew
cartoons they met balloons lots of
people started suing first uh asking for
stuff back as a result it was on display
the lydian horde was on display for two
years in ankara before being sent back
to this town of ushak history is
beautiful where it belongs this was a
slogan that came that that was sort of
widespread in turkey that oscar najar uh
made popular and this is the uh
masterpiece uh one of two masterpieces
of the lydian horde it's a golden
hippocampus it's this big uh it's
absolutely beautiful and in 2005 uh 2006
the story came out a small story came
out of the turkish press that the
masterpiece of the living hoard which by
the way that's an image that is printed
every day on the front page of the ushak
daily paper so it's become a symbol of
the city
and it's on their tourism brochure and
everything
that this masterpiece had been stolen
from this one room museum in ushak
and that uh who was suspected in the
theft but the director of the museum
himself we have the slide i don't know
if we can find him but there's a picture
of a guy in front of a glass case that's
uh
that's sixteen sixteen chasm chasm
there he is thank you
uh the director himself that's him
showing standing in front of the case um
as you can see the it's uh i don't know
if you can see but the lock at the very
far left is probably not as good as the
is the lock on my high school locker
let's look at 18 to see the lock
oh yeah can we see it
no that's yeah yeah that's the lock
those are the br those are also two
bracelets also from the lady and horn
anyway cousin was the guy who had gone
to new york he was deposed and he
explained how it was so important that
these treasures come back to turkey
because they were part of their cultural
identity and absolutely had to be back
at home where they were taken from qasim
got divorced he ran up a lot of debts he
started gambling he started holding
parties in the museum with dubious
ladies and then he ended up uh like the
getty yeah
it's a little bit like the gandy gettys
chapter 10 different one yeah yeah toga
parties at the ghetto yeah so
anyway
as you can see anyway he replaced it
with a counterfeit thinking nobody would
find it would find out but in fact that
one's about 10 grams heavier than the
original so guess what they found out
cosm's now in jail the hippocampus has
disappeared the met's been embarrassed
everybody loses that's that's what
sometimes happens when we return
stolen treasures to countries that are
not really um
capable of taking care of what they have
so that's just a small morality tale to
counterbalance the um you know
post-colonial indignation that some of
us may have over what we should return
or not return there's the re there's the
realities of
um
exhibition preservation curation and
what and and the things that the great
museums can do that countries that don't
have the same resources may not be able
to do
is it worth the risk
is it worth the risk
what do you think yeah
i think it is that
uh well if
given that this one condition that i
didn't get universal agreement upon
earlier is is taken into consideration
or a fixed condition can be satisfied
which is it's its emotional meaning to
the people involved um a very recent
example would be actually within the
united kingdom uh the stone of schoon
spelled scone
it's a historic coronation stone uh on
which would kneel the kings of scotland
when scotland was an independent country
it was taken by english conquerors to
westminster abbey and used used in the
coronation of british kings
and english kings um
it was stolen just before the the
coronation of a present queen
by some scottish nationalists and taken
away but was recovered by the police and
brought back under a recent british
government it's been returned to
scotland it's
it's part of the pertinences of the new
semi-autonomous scottish parliament that
seems to me to make absolute sense
it means something to them it has a
continuous presence in their history
um people would always have felt it
unnatural for it to be
colonial or conquered property
do you think it's a good thing they gave
the lydian horde back even though it was
stolen
i mean you make you make it you make it
hard for one to say that
enthusiastically
incidentally but see i would take even
uh can i just ask what what is the epoch
of that jewelry
um it's about
2500 years old
it's really it's very very beautiful
and it's also one of the many
civilizations that lie beneath the soil
of turkey that really doesn't have a
connection to modern day turkish culture
at all but that's why i would take a
contra view i mean i think i i i do
think uh there's great empathy for
uh the return of things to people for
whom those things still have great
meaning in fact in this country we've
we've passed a law to require museums to
do that called nagpra national uh the
native american grave repatriation act
so
sacred uh things and and human remains
mostly in natural history museums have
been given back to native americans when
it can be proved in fact that there is a
connection between those people that's
partly because there's a living
relationship with those things
but the problem in most uh with most
ancient uh cultures around the world is
these things sharon mentioned that
there's it's there isn't a living
relationship with these things there may
be some
national political pride in the return
of these that political pride would
probably be felt by those in the
dominance uh
political position in turkey i don't
think the kurds in turkey for example
would feel that same way and when we
identify something as greek or italian
or turkish or whether they've been there
longer than the turks yeah the kurds
yeah for sure so you run into this
problem of ethno-nationalism of
something that is defining of a national
culture
on the basis of
the dominant
power so uh if there were an immigrant
and that immigrant let's say came from
central asia who wasn't turkic but he
came from some place in central asia or
let's say it was an african did he feel
the same way toward these things or to
other kinds of things i think we're to
be very careful about
racializing
christopher's early racializing this
thing it's a it's a the political
construct of what is cultural property
it's not
a scientific one it's not a racial one
it's whatever those in power in turkey
feel to be their
property they don't do the same
with the kurds for example you know that
that isn't important to what it means
the power in turkey thinks it means to
be turkish
what about looting looting seems to be
really the at the heart of this whole
thing when it comes to more modern works
how do you prevent looting restitution
uh
does that stop looting or a bar on trade
yeah well i think um
how do you stop looting
it's a very good question and that
that's really been the subject of these
lawsuits that we've seen uh over recent
more recent when i say recent things
that were taken over the past 40 years
including the lydian horde that's the
kind of lawsuits that we've seen that
italy has filed against
the getty criminal charge what's not
really a lawsuit what they've done
actually is played much more uh hardball
than just a lawsuit against an
institution what they've done is they
have criminal charges that are against
uh a former curator herself so you have
one curator marion true who's still
still 19.
still today on trial for
charges of fraud and have things having
to do with uh having acquired stolen
antiquities for the getty so you have a
career curator harvard educator spent 24
years as an esteemed member of the art
art and academic
community did lots of great things for
greece and italy as their partner and
somebody who had devoted her life to
that so now finds herself on criminal
trial for having not lined her own
pockets but for having essentially done
her job the way she believed was
acceptable by the norms of the time
more or less
and
so
the getty and this was done very
consciously by the italian government as
leverage to get the getty to return
pieces that they wanted back so
it was part of a campaign to stem
looting and smuggling
from
from italy itself and i think that it
has succeeded
in stopping museums essentially from
from buying antiquities i think the
antiquities collecting is down to a
trickle at most major museums you can
counter that if you think that's not
true it's certainly true at the getty
statistically speaking
and i think it has stemmed looting in
italy and the question is is there
another way other than because her you
know marian true's life has really
ruined her career her reputation is over
she lost her job and she's
financially um ruined as well
so
i i it seems to me a particularly
sad outcome for uh a fight over
two thousand or two you know two
thousand year old objects seems very
2200 year old objects very very sad and
isn't there another way but it has stem
looting and at the same time looting is
still
absolutely rampant rampant in iraq
in
places like albania where there's very
little supervision
places like bulgaria it has lots and
lots of untouched
places where greek treasures can be
found
so
looting goes on because people want
beautiful stuff and they always will and
there are measures to stem it but i
don't think you can ever
cut it off completely what about
countries like turkey where looting
continues and some do we also in italy
does that somehow negate their rights to
demand things back if they can't keep
track of their own stuff
well i think so actually yeah i think if
they can't keep tr if they can't control
looting in their own country then i
think that they completely undermine
their own argument that they ought to
have things returned to them that's my
question yeah but i would i want to
underline and emphasize that with
reference to um
the behavior of the turkish authorities
in occupied cyprus
um in the island of cyprus the
what they call the footprints of
civilization the traceable evolution of
the different humans so is that as long
and continuous it's an archaeologist's
paradise almost as good as china in that
respect you can see
thousands of years
proceeding in an orderly way after one
another and um
after the illegal turkish invasion and
occupation of the northern tier of the
island in 1974 a huge number of
mainly greek but also some armenian
orthodox churches
with wonderful icons and
in
systematically in a very organized way
just denuded that anything of values has
been amputated
and taken out
and turns up on the open market the
government of cyprus where it can tries
to buy these things back it's rather
humiliating
sometimes prosecutions can be and have
been brought but in really it's it's an
international disgrace because all of
this is being done
under the cover of law
um
by an actual recognized government
member of the united nations a candidate
member of the european union and a
member of nato i think it should be
subjected to sanctions for doing this
i mean the looting is a very complicated
uh situation because as as sharon says
as christopher says you know looting is
not an idle pastime i mean it isn't a
couple of people with those metal
detectors out there you know on holiday
uh and it's not a choice that one makes
you know am i gonna be a doctor or a
looter you know it's it's uh
it it's typically because there are
failed circumstances in which one lives
it's either because your life has been
ruined by warfare sectarian violence by
poverty by corruption
uh you're eking out a living in some
certain way the looters themselves are
not being rewarded
as you know the the the organized crime
people are who take from the looters and
so forth so we have to realize that that
stopping it at the borders
uh policing the site
growing an alternative economy all these
things are very very important to stop
this and no one condones looting it's
the destruction of knowledge it'll never
be restored once these things are
wrenched from the ground you've lost any
knowledge that could be gained from the
context in which they would have been
found and excavated but there once was a
practice that encouraged scientific
excavation uh and that was called
partage and that was comes from the
french word meaning sharing of things
and from the latter part of the 19th
century through the first half of the
20th century foreign excavating teams
mainly from europe and north america
would provide scientific expertise
financial resources
employment like locally they would
excavate to document the excavations and
share the fines with the local
authorities this is the way by which the
collections
at the university of pennsylvania museum
at the university of chicago museum many
of the collections of the metropolitan
the british museum and and in berlin uh
the music game in in paris are reformed
but not just outside the found the
country the source countries it's also
how the baghdad museum was created the
kabul museum the cairo museum the local
collections were also built the same way
with the rise of nationalism at the end
of the ottoman empire first and then the
end of the second world war secondly
partace is all but stopped
because there's a national claim a
political national claim on these
antiquities as being national cultural
property and that has
prevented or discouraged in any case the
scientific excavation of of these sites
and certainly the sharing of these sites
and has concentrated the risk to the
found material again as i said earlier
in one place be it baghdad be the cobble
uh wherever it might be so i think the
rest of restoration of partage which
will run counter to the nationalist
um resurgence but the rest the the
restitute of the return of partage would
be extremely important in this
well then you must be i mean like i
i do agree with you and i was going to
point out myself that the iraqi national
museum
was only made possible because of
british colonialism right it's gertrude
bell's idea the americans didn't have
nationalism and think of themselves as
having national museum or even a patron
each one
um
but then you must surely be in favor of
the idea of a
museum of the acropolis
in which as far as
which as far as possible everything
featuring to
uh having to do with the pertinence of
said building and so on is with the
cooperation of the british government
made available to
wouldn't that be a classic instance of
what you recommend
i i think it's the reverse of what comes
out of the british museum would be a
co-sponsor
right yeah but it's all it's returning
these things to one place rather than
sharing these things between places i'm
arguing for sharing these things between
places not returning them to a single
place i think you know what i i first of
all i've heard a lot of people talk
about the restoration of partage um
i
i can't really think of
that that's a bad idea except that
except that it looks backwards and i
think that we have to look forwards
we're in a very different world today
than we were in the 90s
20th century
is archaeology is looking backwards
surely
well good points
[Laughter]
i mean in the united states it always
sounds good to say no we should put this
behind us and move on and think of the
future
but yes but not with our heroes
yes okay that's true that's funny but
what we're really talking about is what
we're really talking about about is
possession and museums
we're talking about access not
possession it could be talking about
has to do with possession no no it has
these things could be lens they don't
have to be i understand that but the
concept of partage has to do with who
gets to keep the stuff you know who
shares it
means to share but the practice was when
um but looking forward we can talk about
sharing
that's exactly what my point is that we
can take we can
bring the the good uh aspects of what
worked about partage and incorporate
that into new policies as we think about
different ways of possession or
different arrangements that will allow
us to share more instead of being on
opposite sides of a tug of war which is
kind of where we're at now with lawsuits
and all that kind of thing happening and
people going to jail or the threat of
going to jail or the threat of
suspending excavation permits but i
don't believe that looking backwards to
as i've had many conversations you know
with the heads of of the great museums
and we have talked about this on other
panels as well about uh the ideals of
the enlightenment and what museum what
the great museums are really about a
universal museum i i think that we have
to find new paradigms a new language to
talk about
what is the right thing to do with
antiquities and how to treat them and
how to share them in a global world in
the 21st century
that's my only point i agree and not to
put you even more on the spot uh i have
to ask about your collection of the
artists due to chicago are there any
claims no on any of your items no
um
i like
you know i i guess i could be uh funny
but probably dangerously so and to say
that that's an indication that we had
not been as uh ambitious uh a builder of
collections in the first part of the
20th
century it is the case that we don't
have uh claims uh uh against anything
except when the french are going to ask
before the syrah back yeah
why don't you explain what that is the
grand shot which is a painting that was
acquired by trustees of the of the
artists to chicago in the early part of
the 20th century uh it how it can you
know it would now not be possible to uh
remove that painting from france because
france has a a law that uh would uh
claim it as as french cultural property
it didn't then
it listened to anything that was uh
again looted or served it's just it was
allowed to be purchased uh there are
there are reasonable laws of
that are
for the regulation of cultural property
in the world britain has a a very good
one uh and right now there's the great
case of course of the
politicians uh the duke of southern and
with the national gallery in the
national galleries of scotland uh
together trying to
buy this for their and to share between
those museums but if there's a a work of
art that's judged by um
a panel of british authorities to be of
great value to britain
uh it can prevent the export of that
object
let's say that i wanted to buy it i
wanted to buy it for 10 million dollars
they could hold export license for a
period of time that period of time is
variable let's say it's six months a
year whatever it might be
allowing the a british museum or
consortium of bridge museums to raise
that equivalent amount of money that 10
million dollars for it to be returned to
remain within britain uh so that so that
they that's a kind of it's not a
retention law or it's not an open export
law it's something in between japan has
a very uh uh interesting um
uh law as well by which it categorizes
objects as highest um uh national
treasure national treasure you know near
international treasure would like to be
national trade whatever they might be
you know coming all the way down this
thing it won't be natural and it doesn't
allow the highest category of thing to
be exported in japan but allows
percentages of each and greater
percentages as you decline down the
thing so they do want there to be a
diaspora of japanese objects in the
world but they also want the right to
claim a portion of them
as important to japan
what are your policies on acquiring
artifacts
uh uh well the first thing we have to do
is we have to inquire deeply into the
provenance of the object because we have
to
adhere to national laws uh and so we
have to make sure we first we have to
get as much information we can for the
person who's offering it to us whether
it's a dealer or whether it's a
collector or something we know how did
this object come into their possession
how did it come into this country tell
us all you can about to show us all the
documentation you have on that we then
have to try to decide from which country
it might have come and then try to
contact those people we have to look
through the databases stolen property we
do all this research um it has to be to
confirm what sharon said it has had a
chilling effect on the acquisition of
antiquities in this country it hasn't
had a consequent benefit to stopping
looting in the world but it has
prevented
objects undocumented objects or
insufficiently documented objects from
coming into public collections in this
country they have gone elsewhere
elsewhere
not in britain not many places in europe
but in the middle east in the far east
these things are being looted they're
going somewhere but they're not coming
into public collections because private
collections
well they're
i don't even think they're coming to
many private collections in this country
has to be yeah i don't think private
collections in this country anymore
i mean i was in the uh
i was in the arabian gulf in dubai in
the united arab emirates recently and
it's just uh it's a free it's a it's
it's a wild wild west over there you can
buy whatever you want there were um in
the main hotel in abu dhabi this is a
five billion dollar hotel called
the emirates palace there's just uh
um
the train after the train
an obscene number of antiquities for
sale by actually a dealer based in
beverly hills but i i spoke to some art
experts while i was there because i was
so shocked by what i saw i took pictures
of all of them because i every
imaginable civilization
but um the conclusion was this stuff has
to be fake because there was so much of
it it was just absurd but maybe some of
it's fake some of it's not but not even
it was actually on display in the lobby
of of the most of the sort of the
marquee uh center of the social world of
abu dhabi
and they're constantly little news uh
releases of a shipment of smuggled art
uh intercepted at the dubai customs and
that kind of thing when i was actually
when i was in turkey interviewing the
the minister of museums and monuments he
had just gotten a whole shipment of
stuff that had come from turkey had was
stopped in dubai he gave me this whole
sheep of photographs of antiquities that
had been smuggled out of turkey from
dubai and i said well you know why do
you think it was in dubai he said i
really i don't know
they just seem very clueless about it
very strange it's an entrepreneur nina
burley has just done a very interesting
book about
the industrialized faking of antiquities
um in the holy land in in israel
palestine
where
interestingly often the motive for
faking it is not just financial it is to
try and establish um a nationalist or
racist uh or religious claim in other
words here is here is this box of
remains that says
the jesus family
and so that that was actually i think
the new york times almost fell for that
story um
um
this shows this shows that this shows
that shocked
this shows that king this shows that
king david was a real person which means
we can build a settlement somewhere else
etc
um so
there's a sort of triple layer of
corruption uh attached to it it also
shows how gullible people are
interesting
i suppose we knew that yeah no i think
it's a i i sort of something i became
aware of as i was traveling through um
the ancient world was how much uh
collecting excavating and um
displaying artifacts is
so closely tied to the nationalist to
the national narrative whatever that's
meant to be and i it made me wonder uh
how much gets ignored in the excavation
process as not serving kind of the
national myth whatever the national myth
might be
uh and that i i don't know the answer to
that question but it did occur to me as
i was
reading about the hittites and the
hittite pact between the hittites and
the egyptians and how the
israelite nation
also
had an alliance there and i just thought
gee i never saw that reflected in any of
the museums that i've seen in egypt or
in israel for that matter and i thought
well probably it's not very convenient
for the national narrative of each of
those countries today so that's
something else to kind of think about
always bearing in mind also that every
artifact in the kabul
national museum and afghan national
museum in the same week as the
demolition of the um
was destroyed on purpose because it
didn't fit with the
islamic concept of what a national
patrimony would be this this stuff was
by definition profane
because it didn't reflect uh the prophet
um so but thankfully they were that's
another reason why i think um
one always has to qualify this idea of
are we dealing with assyrians or not or
just people who live where syria used to
be
i think it's a good time to go to some
questions
and the the key thing is to go to the
mic because otherwise you won't be heard
um
or recorded so i think we'll set up the
mics there
and if you could just come up and as
always keep the questions brief and in
the form of a question
um
very appreciated uh
and if maybe we could um yeah we took
off the slide good
okay since you got there first go ahead
thank you um i'd like your
panel to to answer uh or comment on the
looting that was done in baghdad
when the american troops entered
anybody wanna i was actually in baghdad
uh for i used to work at the washington
post at the shortly after
the baghdad museum was looted
and uh it's been very hard to
get the story straight because the story
that was put out at the time was the 120
000 pieces were stolen and that was the
entirety of the baghdad collection uh
matthew bogdanos the american colonel
who was sent then to kind of set things
right
um has done a very good job of
explaining what actually happened there
are uh to my knowledge still about four
to five thousand pieces that have not
been returned in fact so so it was a
much it's a much smaller number all
still a horrible number a couple of 20
000 something like that pieces many of
the most valuable pieces
were uh
thought stolen it turns out were
actually
saved by the museum staff and hidden in
a bank vault
as by the way as was also the case in
kabul um the i just visited this
beautiful exhibit of the bactrian horde
that was saved by these heroic heroic um
museum staff in kabul also they put it
at the risk of their own lives under the
taliban in the afghan in an afghan bank
but any event the main problem uh so
there are still about four to five
thousand pieces that are missing some of
them very uh valuable and um
uh
uh singular pieces of that museum to my
knowledge but the bigger problem i spoke
recently about the book in washington
and the iraqi ambassador
came to that talk and he he said he
confirmed to me what i've heard for also
from um archaeologists and such which is
that the looting going on in baghdad
in iraq generally is not having to do
with the museum but is extremely
destructive and rampant and uncontrolled
right now
uh i have two questions on a related
topic
deterrence first you mentioned uh
obliquely about punishments and
making looting a crime i was wondering
if you could
talk about that a little more and
do we need to raise the stakes to deter
looting
with punishment and secondly
are there any mechanisms that exist to
reward looting that is to say
give rewards to
would-be looters to keep
uh treasure or um
archaeological fines in situ
thanks it's just that this would be like
giving poppy farmers something else to
grow that kind of thing
well there's an awful lot of money out
there from museums and philanthropic
organizations to preserve yeah uh
archaeological fines so i i don't know
if there's any mechanisms out there that
exist like well yeah no i think that
that's an important part of what we were
talking about earlier as a part of the
solution to the problem is to create
alternative economies because this is a
real economy in certain situations so
obviously there are means of doing that
it's on a scale and it involves
uh you know the investment of
governmental uh resources not museum
resources you know but the scale is so
great would be on governmental or
non-governmental organization resources
but certainly that's part of it to the
question of uh upping the um uh sort of
penalties on looting as a disincentive
uh it it generally is and i probably is
always uh everywhere against the law to
loot it's certainly against the law to
to remove uh in some cases against the
law to own privately in some cases
against the law to to export
but there
even in where
in places where the penalties are the
greatest punishable by death in china
for example there's still looting going
on people still take risks when they
think there's a benefit to them to take
that risk i mean people
can you know uh commit all kinds of
crimes uh in this country because they
think they won't get caught
whatever the penalty might be so i don't
know that penalty by itself is
sufficient i think it's an integrated
uh uh regime of of carrots and sticks
it's going to make it work the other
thing is is that there's no uniformity
of penalties so
and it's wielded often for political
reasons as jim has pointed out as in the
case of marion true there you have some
very ambitious prosecutors who've taken
laws that have been on the books in
italy that had not been enforced uh
pretty much forever and have wielded
that you know
very aggressively
against for example marion true but
what what is also the case is that there
is just a patchwork everywhere and
there's no international law there's no
kind of consistency
to for people to either um you know
adjudicate disputes or to know what the
what the penalties might be
overall and this and it's so it makes it
hard because you know for example you
now have egypt trying to pass a law that
would allow it to prosecute people the
same way that italy has been and that
greece has kind of done pretty sort of
half-heartedly so
you don't really you don't want to be
tried in the egyptian judicial system i
promise you
on this side
yes um over the christmas holidays i
went to cambridge the fitzwilliam museum
to see
an extraordinary
gold jewelry which had been excavated in
an area called vani which is now in the
state of georgia
it was an amazing
extraordinary exhibit any rate they said
that at the end of it's going to go to
greece and then it's going to go to
los angeles but after that it's going
back to bonnie
did those people
have
a place where it can be kept safe and
share it with the rest of the world i
mean do they have a a good
system for
antiquities there
in georgia i've never been to georgia i
really i don't know
i don't know i hope so
there's well there's there's a
so there's so many incredible treasures
in the area of the former soviet union
uh some of some of it
dates from the colonial period when they
took things for their own national
museums themselves
some of it is dates from world war ii
and has to do with the stuff that hitler
spent a lot of his time gathering up or
that the very angry soviet troops sort
of took in triumph back you know to
to the mother land and that germany
wants back from russia so you have all
kinds of restitution battles between
germany and russia today that has to do
with uh objects that originated in
neither country
so but i don't know about the georgia
museum without knowing about that part
of the caucasus it sounds as if they've
got one idea very clear which is nice to
share
and send things on the circuit and if
they don't have such a system now well
we've got to assume that they are as
capable as anyone else of developing one
and it's clearly they respect their
patrimony so i think the answer is
provisionally yes it looks as if they it
looks as if they are on the right track
i mean anyway there's no there's no way
of um
they won't get one unless they're
allowed to handle it themselves
put it like that thank you
i got a sense of uh how art museums are
being sensitive about what they may
acquire now
what sort of responsibility do you think
the art auction houses have that they
don't bring pieces to the market that
are hot or otherwise inappropriately
acquired
very good question
i think that
i think the auction houses have an
extremely checkered history of
that and when they get caught then they
stop
so i think that basically we you need to
have oversight and measures in place
that um
that keep them from
from uh
you know basically that you know they're
they're in business to make money and so
if they get a beautiful object you know
for years and years they would sell the
objects of
rob and simes for example the guy who
was involved with a lot of the getty
purchases who has
who was kind of at the top of the art
heap in the antiquities world in the 80s
and who's now kind of vanished in a puff
of smoke and he worked very closely with
the auction houses
and um
so i think that's a very valid point
they just have to be uh monitored and
governed
like like everybody else because the
temptation and the money is so great so
that when they get an object that says
owned by a swiss gentleman unnamed um
that's
usually a warning signal that that peace
has no providence it might well have
been smuggled for example but sometimes
it's
undisguised i mean in the case of the
little church in the
byzantine church in cyprus called cana
korea
a real gem place very famous for its
iconography this iconography was
stripped off
and turned up just under its own name in
an auction house and i think austria i
can't remember there's a scandal that it
should even have been no no no museum
would have dreamt of touching such a
thing it was quite clearly stolen
property and it was also
a terrible desecration because actually
these panels were
painted to the shape of a certain part
of the church so they don't make any
sense on their own they're not they're
not really beautiful anymore
um
like the horse of cellini it's on a sort
of dull plinth in the british museum
it's supposed to be looked at from below
at a certain point on the acropolis it's
meaningless when it's been denatured
anyway i think one of the ways of
getting your characteristic combination
better adjusted would be to remove the
incentive
for looting that is supplied by some of
the more promiscuous auction houses just
say you know you won't make money this
way
thank you
i've spoken very well about the issue as
it relates to art and architecture i was
wondering if there's any pressure for
the return repatriation of egyptian
mummies and i ask that because the
united states when native american
remains are involved there is intense
pressure to either leave alone or return
those ancient remains and it makes a big
media splash but i haven't heard
anything about egyptian or russian or
french claims
it's very interesting i mean i i myself
i've had a couple of people uh forward
thinkers such as yourself ask me that um
when i've talked about the book
because there is there's such a debate
over native american remains and and um
the proper disposition of those remains
i i've not heard the a whiff honestly of
discussion
of
whether displaying mummies is a
desecration of a of a
a corpse or of human remains
uh from the egyptian point of view i
don't know if you you've read anything
of the kind but i i've had a couple of
young students say well shouldn't this
be you know scandalous
and i can't quite wrap my head around
that i mean lots of things are 4 000
years old and um
i mean in effect the fact that we're
showing
uh
king tut's tomb is
a desecration of the ancient egyptian
religion these things were never meant
to be opened and looked at by members of
the public
so
um
i think
that's a discussion
that's probably the another turn of the
wheel or the evolutionary wheel if you
like in terms of how sensitive
culturally sensitive it's appropriate to
be when you're balancing
knowledge and history and understanding
of the arc of human
civilization
yes several years ago i was in addis
ababa and i was seeing the um skeletal
remains of lucy and then i later i
thought i was and then i later found out
that that is actually kept in a vault
when it's in that museum but then it was
traveling over to houston where it would
be on public display so i think this
this theme that's come up in this
discussion about whether countries
actually have a system to to display
things to the public is an important one
um in that case it was great that it was
going to travel but my question was a
follow-up on your comment on abu dhabi
because thomas krenz spoke recently at
colombia about the really great infusion
of
money of investment into the art world i
think he said that the government of abu
dhabi was putting 600 million dollars
now into contemporary art purchases and
at the louvre and the guggenheim and
others are starting to do these mega
museum projects there so could you talk
a little bit about when you have such a
very new investment do you see the
potential for
more to happen in the in in the wrong
direction as far as what you mentioned
you saw in the hotel there yeah i'll
kind of be curious here what jim has to
say about this too first of all
having just finished a big piece on this
exact topic i can tell you that the
correct figure in abu dhabi is 27
billion dollars okay is what they're
spending to develop museums on saudia
island 27 billion dollars
1.3 billion is the louvre abu dhabi
alone and maybe yeah that much for for
purchases for the guggenheim that tom
krenz is working on
but um
i think having talked to the cultural
officials in dubai and qatar and abu
dhabi they have no sense of any of these
issues i really have that strong feeling
they are creating uh probably 10 to 20
major world-class museums by world built
by world-class architects in the next
five to 10 years it's going to be a huge
kind of shift in the balance of power or
as a kind of a a place for art and the
the world of art and culture
and um among those that they're building
are so-called universal museums which it
would be similar to at least in
principle a louvre there will be an
actual louvre of course uh you know
british museum like the met and so
presumably that means building
antiquities collections i don't think
the problem is if you're building
contemporary art collections then
they'll just acquire art like everybody
else and they'll borrow art of course
from the louvre and that kind of thing
um and and and benefit from traveling
exhibitions
i don't know if i did not get the sense
that there's anybody in that part of the
world who's thinking about the the uh
you know the sand traps that might await
them in trying to create an antiquities
collection today
the only
comparable museum that has had that kind
of ambition has been the getty in modern
times and they've run into a world of
hurt in doing that so i think that's
definitely something to to
worth asking about i don't know thank
you
well
i mean i think what sharon said is
probably absolutely right i i think
there are other interesting questions
related to it and that has to do with
motivations for
this great investment uh in the arts in
that part of the world and of the
participating parties in it
uh the louvre as you know is a part of
the cultural ministry of france and and
it is a political
arm of the government as it were and it
was very clear
when the cultural minister announced
this relationship that the french wanted
the louvre to be there because
they wanted to have a player in the game
in that part of the world you know
recognizing that the british in the the
us
were there on other terms at that time
military and economic let's say the
french wanted to be
at the table and they were going to be
at the table on cultural terms have a
presence it was a it was a a frank um
statement of
the politicization of this
uh um this activity when it comes to the
guggenheim you know it's part of the
business plan the guggenheim as far as i
can tell i i don't know it in detail but
it's it's not it's not for why we might
wish that this uh was happening we might
wish that it was happening because it
was going to be bringing
the world's cultures representative
examples of the world's cultures
together in one place to build
understanding among
arab peoples and non-arab peoples in the
world uh to the greater glory of
humankind uh
you know it does seem to be that as
christopher said it's an entrepreneur
the ambition is to create what i
understand people who've gone there to
see it the people who are coming into
the museum or for whom the museum might
be built are not local people for the
most part they're people they're
creating destinations cultural
destinations tourist destinations
hotels golf courses you know uh
things that are relevant to an
entrepreneur so
i think a larger question in addition to
sharon's questions is really what is the
motivation for doing this
okay we'll make this the last question
thank you what are the five antiquities
that egypt would like back from the west
and whether status about what is the
status of them going back
so the rosetta stone at the british
museum
the zodiac ceiling which you saw which
is at the louvre the bust of onhoth
which we have about two social [ __ ] at
the number six
this um
if we're gonna show six we should also
show five because it would you can see
that he's in uh
the british museum of the boston sorry
the boston museum of fine arts and was
one of the architects of one of the the
great pyramids the second largest
pyramid and then there's yeah if we look
at five i think you'll see where he came
from so he was he was taken legally from
here um in a sanctioned uh dig in the
20s but he would be put back where he
was used was laid to rest
in a full view of this magnificent
monument that he built uh and then
there's
and there's of course three major
pyramids that everybody knows so there's
the bust of hamiunu who designed the
great pyramid is four and five
mississippi thank you boston for
cheating he's only on the cover of the
book of
nice thank you for the reminder
um who is in berlin and the status of
them is
the official request is that they be
loaned for three months for the opening
of a new museum which egypt so
desperately needs that they're building
at the foot anybody who's been to the
cairo museum would know that uh they're
building it uh in the in
the region and the environs of the
pyramids
the
boston has said no uh the bust of
hamayunu hildesan has said yes they will
loan it the bus of nefertv has been
deemed too fragile to travel i don't
really believe that but anyhow that's
what they're saying
well i think but i actually think they
might be meeting to discuss it but they
they're i don't think they've officially
rejected the idea but they have said
it's too fragile to travel the zodiac
ceiling is considered too fragile to
travel and the rosetta stone is um i
think that there it's under
consideration
the latest
okay thank you very
[Applause]
oh
much
and sharon will be downstairs signing
books
[Music]
this week on q a
journalist and author christopher
hitchens
[Music]
christopher hitchens what's it feel like
to be 60
very much the same as it did to b59
these are arbitrary
dates in a way edmund wilson wrote
an article called the author at 60. he
wouldn't even say myself at 60 or
everyone wilson at 60 or
i had to be the author at 16 which i've
i've i'm going to read later on this
week
you're just days into the 60th year um
what's life i suppose i would add one
thing i mean since did you ask
in a funny way i never expected to live
this long
why and the even more strange thing
about it is
well i can remember when 30 seemed very
old to me
and i was probably only early 20s then
and
that thought kept on
decade by decade and also i didn't used
to get the blues as some people do
as decades turned
with 60 the risk of it is you say ah i
remember the first time i met brian ram
and came on c-span that was 28
years ago and you think ah i may not
have another 28 to come
that hits you a bit more than it did
when you were 40 let's say what is life
like for you
at present yeah well i'm writing a
memoir so i'm having to go through all
this anyway
and again great stretches of time are
involved and the realization that
first i've seen more days than i'm going
to see seen more sunsets and dawns than
i'm going to see i can live with that i
always knew that was true
no point being in denial there
but if i didn't have
children to date things by i think it
would seem very arbitrary but what makes
it real is that is
realizing that i have a son who once was
on this show with me you remember
he's 10 years old who will be a quarter
of a century next month he'll be 25
years old what's he doing he's working
for a think tank in london
called the center for social
cohesion bit of a mouthful name but it's
essentially says that
religious groups shouldn't make special
claims that there should be a national
and common citizenship
without being denominated by
by faith
you have two other children i do have
two daughters in fact at present
i can say i'm the father of two teenage
girls
but that'll change in september when
sophia will become 20.
and perhaps even more dramatically
antonio will become 16.
so what has been your
this is not heavy-duty policy i know but
what has been your
kind of mission with those three kids
well how have you what kind of a father
have you been to them
um
pretty
indifferent i suspect i mean i
i always feel that
i get better with children the older
they get
i think this is probably true of a lot
of men
um
though why would i seek shelter in the
majority i don't normally try and do
that but a striking thing let's say
about women is about both my wives is
that they know what to do when babies
occur they sort of know what to do
very few men do they think
somehow it seems to be a
female thing when they're little and
when they even when they're growing up
um i think this is probably true to an
abnormal extent with me as it was with
my own father
you had barely noticed him until you're
a bit older and so what i hope to do
to redeem how little i was involved in
the infancy bit is to be
a pal and as prop and a stay and force
as they become older
it's
i think
so far
go back to the memoir from yes
where are you in that when's it due and
how much time have you spent on it and
what's your approach to it i i spend all
my time thinking about it and quite of
my time writing about it after all it's
about me so i i can always
spare the time
and
with luck it'll be turned into my
publisher in the fall
and
that'll mean it'll be published sometime
in the spring or early summer
of next year
so but give us the approach you're
making i mean tell us one thing that's
going to be in there that
we don't know
oh i couldn't tell you just one i mean
the theme is um that of
a divided self i haven't got a title for
it yet but if it was a pop song title it
would be called um
both sides now i suppose something like
that that i've i've often felt myself
exactly
split down the middle and um able to see
which is an advantage both sides of
every question
able also to take one side and take it
strongly but sometimes feel the
temptation
to see it from the other as well
and this has been the case
with other aspects of my life finding
out late in life that my mother was
jewish for example i had a second
identity
spending quite a lot of time with a wife
who was greek and trying to become
in part a member of another society
language and culture another another
looking for another second identity
there taking pleasure in
in if you like having it both ways which
maybe would be a good title for the for
the book
your first wife you were married to her
for how long
um don't let me hesitate unduly because
i was with her for longer than we were
married if you know what i mean i
remember we got married the year i moved
to the united states which was b81
and but we'd been
a team for longer than that for a couple
of
years
and we were separated in 89 and probably
divorced a year after and where she
lived today in london
your second wife carol blue was blue
you met her where in los angeles
a native city and what were the
circumstances i was on a book tour
um when people say to me just while i
think about this the thought we were
just having people say isn't it a bit
early to be doing your memoirs because
i'm after i'm nearly 60 and as you
haven't said yet i don't look it but i
know you were going to say that um
you you suddenly think yes maybe it is
early but you can't wait till it's too
late so if you're ever going to do it
i'm going to have to do it now
i i want to speaking of how you look i'm
going to go back to 83 our first
interview on book notes together in 83.
you have this yeah i want you to see
what you look like let's let's run this
in case i'm accused of concealing it um
let me say it now this
if i haven't said it already um i've
already said i was a member of the
labour party in britain the labour party
is a member of the socialist socialist
international that's the the family of
socialist parties that comprises
francois meteorol the sandinista
movement in nicaragua
the british labour party the swedish
socialist party and many others
i still consider myself a member of that
political family and
i don't feel that
coming out with it on the air is as it
were a confession it's just an
affirmation if i'd known you were so
interested in my private political views
i'd have put them near the top of the
show
i said that was book notice it wasn't it
was a calling show yes uh and that was
one of the first times we talked about
so i'm just coming away my friend um
having looked at that deplorable young
man what what did i mean by saying
private political views surely i should
have been saying there's nothing private
about them
there's a slip involved there a funny
one
sorry you were saying no i just uh i i
do have a bone to pick with you wolf
yeah it's a shelter
you promised me i haven't seen you in a
long time you promised me that when you
became an american citizen that we would
go to monticello and i would interview
there uh thomas jefferson's home and i
never heard from you
and you ended up where did you go
i was very lucky i was invited to
take my oath of citizenship at the
jefferson memorial by the title basin
um on his birthday the april 13th which
is also my own
um
though actually of course he was born
under the old calendar so by the time he
died his birthday's april 13th
it's also the birthday of shame as he
knee
you draw a world here foreign and i i
took a representative group of americans
along there um but i thought it was for
you to call me not me to call you
well it's not too late i've been invited
to give the jefferson lecture to
monticello i've been
a couple of times since i wrote my my
book about him why i hope i'd really
really like
to to take you up on that
why
are you an
american well for a long time i lived
here with a green card
that a platinum green card actually one
of the old ones that never ran out so i
didn't have to renew it heaven
had a european union passport
i had three american children american
wife all this um i thought i don't need
to no one needs to change this
i got to the point where
when i came back to dallas airport and
went through immigration i went joined
the right line
citizens and
residents they'd say welcome home
that's what i felt
um it was after
9 11 that i began to feel that i hadn't
paid the full price of the ticket
that i was in a way cheating on my dears
and that's for two reasons one
at that point and afterwards the united
states began to be subject to a
fantastic campaign of
slander and defamation people would say
it's not true that the united states was
attacked the american jews blew up all
the israeli jews blocked the world trade
center
all the bush administration did um
were the countries run by cowboys and um
thugs and
jewish neocons i began to and feel
really protective of the united states
and i was i'm not going to hear you say
this
is my country you're talking about
somebody thought that's actually true
so there was there was that and then i
thought
because we're now going to have to talk
about war
and about fighting and fighting back
if i'm going to stand up
and say that i think that we ought to be
sending
our
armed forces overseas
i think i probably should be someone who
could in the last resort at least be so
called upon to do so actually you can be
drafted if you've got a green card
you can't
uh but it felt a little more solid to me
to be of course no one's gonna
the army hasn't been found yet that
would draft someone like myself i mean
not even the good soldier
schmeich but as a matter of principle
and also that i should be voting and
eligible for jury duty and all the other
um both duties and entitlements
so i didn't feel comfortable until i got
that done
did you vote in this last election i did
i i turned up early
you want to tell us who you voted for i
voted for the senator from illinois
why
well
um i'm not any longer a registered
member of any party or and don't have
any ideological
allegiance any longer but
and in a way mccain's position on the
war was more close to my own but i
thought obama would learn more about the
war than mccain had mccain's position
was
actually rather an eccentric one about
afghanistan and about iraq
um i thought obama showed signs of
having the right stuff on this i have to
say as an admirer of senator mccain's i
thought he was um
too
how do i put this without being implied
i mean too exhausted to be running for
anything frankly
um and that his choice of running mate
was quite simply ridiculous
no much worse than ridiculous insulting
um not serious i didn't think a serious
vote could be cast for the republican
ticket on this occasion
so that made that bit easy um and
then
i suppose i've thought for a long time
the united states has been ready for
ages to prove that it will vote for a
qualified black candidate let's get this
done
um
i didn't think there's anything very
surprising about it i mean all through
the year people were saying things like
oh the bradley effect will kick in
even if the bradley effect doesn't the
polling machines will be fixed
if the pulling machines aren't fixed
then someone will take a rifle and take
the brother down no no no no no
very interesting and impressive to see
how easily it got done and how natural
it seemed when it was
and though i didn't i didn't get as
emotional and moist about that as some
people did i it was an ingredient in
making it a pleasure to vote for him
that plus i like him as a writer i
should say
i like the way he talks i like the way
he writes i'm i'm impressed by his
just command of english which is the
thing that matters to me the most did
you read his two books i did yeah
what do you think well i thought the
first one was much better because it was
written when he didn't know he was going
to be a politician and the second one is
written
under the awful knowledge that he's now
in play
but even given that you can tell he's
written it himself
he's taking the risks of making various
commitments
he'll have to live up to and he's got a
sense of humor sense of irony
um and a
really very
really admirable grasp of of the
the language it means the most the day
we're recording this your name came up
on the morning call-in show it did
before we show the clip uh i i don't
think i'd ever expected you to be
a fellow at the hoover institution
how did that happen at stanford and
politically how did that happen well um
the hoover institution is very very very
serious about war and revolution that's
what it's founded to consider
and war and revolution or encounter
revolution um are the great subjects at
present or among them well they're never
not but they're
particularly salient now and
i've taken
i don't think a very forward position
with a very determined one
that we are at war
and that we're at war with the
totalitarian enemy um and that
part of our study must be how to train
not just soldiers but citizens and how
to fight in this war are you still a
follower i'm what they call a media
fellow visiting phil i mean it's it's uh
the roger mertz visiting fellow
um which means that i'm i go and talk to
potential journalism students i can talk
about literature with people there if
necessary about politics too but i
regard it as one of the
academic and intellectual arsenals of
the country here mark thiessen's uh
hoover fellow let's listen to what he
said about it this morning
he wonder when waterboarding to see what
it feels like to prove that it was
torture in so doing he proved it was not
torture a common sense definition of
torture is if you're willing to try it
to see what it feels like it's not
torture so if i told the christopher
hitchens i'm going to pull your teeth
out with a plier see what it feels like
would you try it
he wouldn't try it i said i'm going to
pull your fingernails off to see what it
feels like to try would you try it no
you wouldn't try it i'm going to put
electrodes on your body and put it puts
a few hundred thousand or a thousand
volts through your body would you try it
no
yes i know what he means i mean there's
another
trapdoor if you like underneath my
journalistic investigation of
self-investigation of waterboarding
which is i knew when i went in that i
could stop it at any time by making a
special signal to my
tortures myself
but there was only one way i felt i
could advance the argument which is to
see roughly speaking what it's like and
for example in reply to mr thiessen i
would say
you've heard this said i'm sure
waterboarding simulates uh drowning
or the feeling of drowning doesn't do
that at all you are being drowned just
in slow motion
um everything in you immediately rebels
against that it's a survival question
where is that is that the porpoise-like
figure of um
uh that is somewhere in the mountains of
um eastern north carolina with a group
of people who
a team of people who have
had let's say
field experience of this what does this
feel like right here when they're
pouring water down well it feels as if
your last breath is about to be drawn
and your whole you don't really have any
choice in the matter you have to
everything rebels you have to you have
to make it stop as fast as you can
um
my second reply to mr season would be uh
you're just now saying
i think that's pretty much yeah they say
that um
college sheikh mohammed lasted for
something like uh 90 seconds i'd be very
surprised if that was true unless he was
trying to get us to kill him and they
also say they
did it hundreds of times yes yeah that's
remarkable
um
the other replied makes mr tueson on
this point because he's making a very
serious one after all i was ready to do
it again and because i felt so bad
about having lasted so little i felt any
hitchens
any son of commander hitchens of the
royal navy
should be able to stand up a bit more
than that so i made them do it to me
again and i lasted a bit longer this
time
but
um
and you could say again well if you
could stand it for two times it's not
torture but the united states has always
said of any regime that uses it on on an
american that it is torture and that if
we catch the person who did it or
ordered it we'll seek the death penalty
and has done so
uh several times
so that
it's not a matter of whether it's
medieval or not
fingernail pulling um
the rack and so forth because if you
allow these things if you say you must
do them because there's a ticking bomb
or if you allow this thing excuse me you
must do it because there's a chicken
bomb the guy's a terrorist then what's
to stop you saying we'll bring on the
red hot poker or the pincers so put all
this in the context right now what do
you think of
where the obama administration is on
this the memos and and
you know what would you do about the
past
well i
at the same time i was taking my oath at
the
jefferson memorial to become an american
citizen i was a member of a
and by the way
with me was a young marine as a witness
i wanted him a friend of mine who had
been in anbar province uh crushing the
life out of al-qaeda it turned out to be
a successful campaign very proud to have
been a supporter of it and of general
petraeus and the sir but at the same
time i was a member named member
of a lawsuit
brought by the american civil liberties
union
against the national security
association against the nsa and
on illegal wiretapping and i was one of
the eight plaintiffs
and it seems to me that that's what it
is in a way to be an american
that you have the right to in fact the
duty to do that and to question the way
the government is fighting your war
or treating you as a citizen even if
you're strongly in favor
of um
every measure that's taken to resist and
combat
terrorism
islamization
and the
totalitarian regimes that have in the
past supported or underwritten
so right now should
what should this town do about what
happened in the bush administration
well
i mean i'm not a friend of the cia as
you know that would have been the the
young hitchens who just saw back there
the one with the fringe and the
socialist international kid yeah would
would i'm proud of what he was saying
about the central intelligence agency i
mean this is an agency that
gave away nelson mandela's um
whereabouts and identity to the south
african police when they couldn't find
him let him in for 25 years of
imprisonment that was the cia
murdered the elected to help to murder
the elected president of chile
countless other horrible crimes in
greece uruguay cyprus elsewhere
not only that
these are criminal things but um
repeatedly told us that the soviet union
was an economic superpower right up till
89 that it was entering its golden age
and so on
was a
fantastically successful country when it
was falling to pieces uh george tenet on
the day of 9 11 said
to senator former sergeant borin the
first thing our head of intelligence
said on that day was looking at the
towers go down
and the planes fly in he said um
it's quoted in woodward's book directly
he says um i hope it's not those guys
from the flight schools in the midwest
who he knew about and hadn't done
anything about
so they try and cover their traces
and their failures and their betrayals
by torturing people
so they can say hey we've got results
that last this will not do we can't have
that so someone has to go down for this
i think
the one
i would i think the cia should be closed
and padlocked anyway and should be
restarted
i don't think it's
even susceptible to reform
and i think that's been proved by all
everyone's tried to run it since
janet um and then i i think i have a
special hatred for the the shady lawyers
who try to think of excuses
um try to think of
half-baked legal
reasons why we shouldn't honor the
geneva conventions and had those passed
on to men in the field
who were under orders
but i i wanted to i want to clarify it
and calm down i've been to guantanamo
and i've been to abu ghraib
uh
evergreen was much worse understood i
was saying i know
and there are many worse cuban prisons
on the other side of the line in cuba in
guantanamo there's a political prison
there too
but that doesn't excuse us
want to go back to and this program is
not meant to have any
major theme it's just to
snapshots of christopher hitchens life
in preparation for the memoir indeed we
got this off of youtube you were on
scarborough country um
a couple years ago at the nighttime show
and uh let's watch this and get your
reaction
let's bring a little light to this uh
instead of all heat let's bring a little
light to this conversation and talk
about trans
okay thank you thank you so much
chris
hold on guys stop god bless us all just
stop and let's have a meaningful
conversation instead of people talking
okay well you know what christopher i'll
never make that mistake again matt
here's here's the question okay
merry christmas and good night
your your reaction to seeing it i think
i left that one i think i actually
walked out of that one i thought look
either have me on ask my view or don't
but don't tell me what to say don't tell
me what you think all the time i
actually corrected mr scarborough i
think i improved him slightly as a as a
host and um
and as a
talk show person
he made an obvious mistake um
and you know everyone gives themselves
permission to behave absurdly when
religion is mentioned and he's just
another
one of those who do by the way when are
we going to mention my new paperback
version of my auntie cardboard when
you're going to put the title and
everything on the screen
what are we going to say find bookstores
everywhere we'll do we'll do it shortly
we're going to go back to 98. i want you
to see uh i haven't thought of it until
now one of a relative of yours let's
let's watch this
one see spans washington journal the
hitchens brothers are back one on the
right coast one on the left coast we'll
start here on the right coast with peter
hitchens what do you make of all of this
well apart from all the laughing i've
been doing i'm beginning to feel that
i've come out here perhaps a little too
soon it doesn't seem to be developing as
fast as everyone in london thought it
would it's filled me with a new respect
for the american right
i'd upsell now thought of them as rather
an unpolished crew the sort of people
who tour the country
calling for um
sexual abstinence among teenagers for
example but now it seems that they can
infiltrate a well-heeled liberal babe
from beverly hills into the white house
get her in to see the president on this
just as he's come from church with his
daughter
get her in to see vernon jordan just the
day before she signs an affidavit and
get
him to get her in to see revlon just the
day after she's signed
on the jotted line this is this is
genius
talking about monica lewinsky that's
your brother peter uh
that was well apart from the tie which i
it's better not to wear one than wear
one like that i think that's me at my
best actually i mean saying okay
if if you believe the liberal theory
that clinton was set up and monica
lewinsky was a stalker that's the sort
of stuff you're going to have to believe
what's your relationship with your
brother these days
um not bad um
he's
like all hitches a man of principle
um able to turn a phrase in print and on
the air um
the main difference that we have
is that he's a
i wouldn't say born again but he's a
very decided
fundamentalist christian
not of a fanatical sort but of a
a very very decided very determined
episcopalian conservative sort
um and with people like that i can never
be completely at ease i just can't
now he lives where he lives in oxford in
england but he commutes regularly he
lives between oxford and london where
his his media base is and what was his
reaction when you found out that your
mother was jewish
well
we found out partly because our
grandmother my mother's mother
had outlived both my parents she lady
went to great age
and because peter had married a jewish
wife
and when he took her to meet my
grandmother
my grandmother said oh she's jewish
isn't she and peter sort of bridled a
bit and um my grandma having no reason
to keep the family secret any longer so
well i've got something to tell you so
yeah
so as peter brought me the news
i think i was i don't know why i say
this but i have a feeling i was just
very slightly more more pleased and
interested than he was
why
well among other things he he and his
jewish wife had both converted to
christianity
so
it it was a bit more turning over the
luggage in their hold
then it wasn't mine so your grandmother
was yours my wife is jewish also
your grandmother's jewish yeah and that
and then your that would make your
mother jerusalem yes indeed if you will
if you believe it if you believe in
mosaic law the law of return and the
nuremberg laws and i have problems with
all these three laws but
yes it's a matrilineal
uh succession and i would not i'd
certainly never if i was asked if i was
jewish
whether the tone of voice was friendly
or hostile i would never say no
we'll never be able to deny it we'll
want to we'll get closer to your book on
this clip with anderson cooper when you
appeared on there and uh talked about
the death of jerry falwell i don't know
if you remember this one
i remember
the event quite well yeah here it is
christopher i'm not sure if you believe
in heaven but if you do do you think
jerry falwell is in it
no and i think it's a pity there isn't a
hell for him to go to
what is it about him that brings up such
vitriol
the empty life of this ugly little
charlatan proves only one thing that you
can get away with the most extraordinary
offenses
to morality and to truth in this country
if you'll just get yourself called
reverend
who would even at your network have
invited on
such a little toad to tell us that the
attacks of september 11th were the
result of our sinfulness and with god's
punishment if they hadn't got some kind
of
clerical qualification people like that
should be out in the street shouting and
horroring with a cardboard sign and
selling pencils
from a cup
i don't know why i was so lenient on the
little rat bag
he said he came on the television while
the
downtown manhattan was still smoldering
there was cell phones screeching under
the rubble
people still alive and he said this is
because we allowed divorce and
homosexuality
the hell with him
you know
what i went on to say is that if he
could have been given an enema
he could have been buried in a match box
and that's what i didn't get time to say
on mr cooper but i got time to say later
on that's what i meant how much of what
you say is calculated
none i mean i mean i mean in the sense
of being in it's not done for effect if
that's what you mean but i mean i don't
say anything no it's a very good
question i ask myself a lot of the time
because i'm often
on the on the telly and on the radio and
i often have a book to sell and
i don't want to suspect myself of just
being doing the doing things for effect
um if i ever go further than i mean to
and i say something that is is um
cheap or overstated i i always will try
and come back and correct myself and say
okay maybe that was
i mean i don't do things just for
you you'll put your purse in your lips
no i would just i actually wanted it i'd
like to find a gift or phrase if i can
and try and make it
stick make it memorable i i really
wanted to ask you though when
there was an occasion where you and
someone else really were
i don't the word mad doesn't describe it
but you're furious with one another or
you really had a confrontation that was
personal and serious and deep
on the air
anyway you know just in in life i mean
people that watch television never know
how much of it's a gimmick exactly and
that's what
that's where one wants to suspect one's
own motives
um
this will seem odd but i'll answer it
like this i'm reviewing a book at
present um
of
essays by henry fairley perhaps you
remember him
quite good
english-born essayist often in the new
republic in the especially in the 80s
90s um he was a great writer and a great
polemicist but i used to think that
sometimes he would feign his anger he
would he would think you know i need to
get a piece i need to get paid i need i
need to get an article done
he would he would invent a subject to be
annoyed about and
i i just think that that will always
show
so
i suppose i have to submit myself
in answering your question
not my own verdict that you're inviting
but to the safe keeping of of the good
taste of the audience i mean if the
people who read me and watch me if they
think i'm doing this because i just want
to make splash
well they're entitled to think that and
i would i would obviously suffer
a decline in respect
um i don't think in fact i give off the
impression that i i do this for effect
but back to the other part of the
question though
what's the biggest
most serious feud you've had with any
individual
and it was real i mean that they weren't
phony and you weren't phony and it was
i guess it would be with with
henry kissinger and his
what
defenders
can call to mind of the recent past i
wrote a book saying that i thought he
should be arrested and put on trial and
that if he was he'd be convicted
for crimes against humanity and for war
crimes and
he
made a very crude reply to me on on
television and point in fact saying
that i was everything from a holocaust
denier
to a person who trashed jackie kennedy
in fact on both those charges as you
know i i can't be indicted but i
eventually got his lawyers to issue an
apology
about this and i took it very seriously
indeed and i hated him hate him
and i hate that the toadies in the press
and and in the academy and in publishing
who've helped smooth his power you hate
him hate them hate him and what's the i
can't i mean i feel it's an insult that
such a person is around is is deferred
to is consulted is treated with
politeness in the academy and by
by our profession and um
and
um
in the
in the publishing industry i've said
i've never met him
yes i met him two or three times he's
never been induced to speak to me
um but he's sometimes had to be in the
same room
with evident bill grace
i think no that's probably been for me
the most
long lasting and deep going and
most
hate-based
um
relationship i've i've had with anybody
you asked about this book we did not
actually ask you on the program to talk
about this i know you didn't but i'm not
going to let you get away that's fine no
i just it's uh
how many copies of hardback did you sell
um a lot about about 350 000
you know and the title is god is not
great it's not a paperback and what kind
of sales do you expect of this oh i
would hope even
larger because the
subject has become even more acute than
when
i didn't i didn't broach it i mean it
broached itself
the battle between
civilization
and civil society and theocracy is
becoming every day much more intense
and much more urgent
and the number of people who will come
now to a public debate on this i go to
do this
kind of debate about twice a week now
is growing all the time in the audience
for the argument is enormous
why
well
i think for two reasons one is religion
is the most interesting subject of all i
mean
if you have a friend
you or an acquaintance you know an awful
lot about them
depending on whether they attribute
their presence in the studio to
the laws of biology
laws of nature
laws of evolution by natural selection
or whether they think that they're here
because of a divine plan it's a big
difference
philosophically morally
and so going into this means you raise
all the most interesting all the most
fundamental basic questions that's the
first thing so it's never a boring
discussion and second or shouldn't
should and the second is that at the
moment if you open the newspaper and see
how the parties of god are behaving
around the world everywhere from russia
to
iran to even certain parts of the united
states where they think they ought to
influence the education system
that people are i think becoming fed up
with being pushed around by
um ordinary mammals who think that they
are better than us because they have god
on their side
enough with this it's a very it's very
insulting it's very threatening
it's very stupid and it's becoming
and now we have the chance that
apocalyptic weaponry
will fall into the hands of messianic
states or organizations armageddon
type
forces um
clear and present danger did you ever
believe in god no
did your parents
yes they must have done at some point
well i think my father probably must
have done
i don't know this because of course i i
always have this doubt about people who
even affirm that they believe in god do
they believe in it all the time do they
believe in it every day
do they never have crisis of faith why
do they have to keep on going to church
to prove that they believe if they why
isn't it simple to them would you say
that but i mean my father came from a
very strong baptist
family he must when he was young i think
of
being a believer what about your
children
i wouldn't ask them
nor i hope would they want to ask me i
mean they shouldn't obviously my
children do now know
they have to know what i think because
it's well known
but i would prefer that they did not i
think they have
should be able to make up their own
minds
about this world i mean my daughter my
youngest daughter for example younger i
mean to say goes to civil freedom school
where um
they're not made to be quaker where they
are taught about other faiths
so if they make up their own minds
that's all i want for them i would never
dream of imposing it on
on them and
they really ought not to know what my
belief so at least until they're
of the age of reason it's repulsive to
me to hear people saying you know
[Music]
what you see in the newspaper a muslim
child was killed or a catholic child was
killed in northern ireland or protestant
child
how do we know this about them what
choice did they have in the matter what
i mean is a child victim of a filthy
religious war
was killed i want to show you a picture
that uh
was in our first book notes book right
here yes i don't know if you remember
that when i was still a smoker yeah
that's in timberlake's bar remember it
is near dupont circle and if you'll
notice this is in the middle of the day
you've got your computer there you've
got a martini on the bar and you've got
a cigarette in your mouth and it got
like a
i don't know sumo wrestler
as well would you do that today no i had
to give up smoking i didn't have to but
i made myself go about two years ago
what about the drink and with the booze
i
find it's a better
servant than a master
experience well i actually
though
um
i say that in that tense
i've always thought that it's very
important that it be a master servant
relationship in other words you should
get more out of it than it gets out of
you
i found alcohol
um
interesting it makes other people less
boring it's
a great recommendation than it has
some people can't write or talk or do
anything much when they've had a few
drinks i without boasting i can say that
i can and sometimes that i want to
it can be um an inspiration to me and i
know that it can i know this from
friends and from relatives and from waja
episodes in my own life
it can be very bad to have too much to
dream
uh but i have it
as a i still think as a friend and an
ally and not as a
as a boss or a foe how how do you
this is a almost a
question for a classroom but how do you
make your money
on a in other words if somebody's
watching saying boy i'd love to live the
life of christopher hitch
there must be now but when they you know
i'd love to have that life of words and
writing and speaking and all that
how do you and can you make a decent
living doing what you do you can if it's
all you want to do in other words once
you've decided that all you want to be
as a writer
and once you've learned that all you
need really as a writer is to be able to
talk
to speak to have a voice
many of my students say is that all you
need
you just have to be able to talk and i
say yes but how many of you can
how many of your friends do you enjoy
listening to really do you enjoy
listening to yourself
i mean do you try and talking sentences
and stuff they they realize it's not so
easy but once you've discovered the joy
of that or in my case just the fact that
i knew was all i could do i never wanted
to do
it doesn't matter i didn't mind when i
first came on your show i made a few
hundred
blocks out of it but i knew it i was
doing what i wanted to do
you didn't make a hundred bucks coming
um no but so i knew that i was making a
few hundred bucks
out of writing but it was what i wanted
to do so there was nothing to
now i'd do better and if you want to
know exactly how i do it it's this um
um vanity fair the best magazine in the
country in the world in fact the
english-speaking world
pays me a monthly retainer to write them
a column
about 10 out of 12 months of the year
and so i know i've got that much
it's not a fortune at all but it's
pretty generous and i can i can count on
it
the contract is renewed every couple of
years or so
um
and they're they're fairly decent about
letting me write for other people book
reviews so forth and then it's got to
the stage now
where people will actually pay me to
come and talk to them
which is better than i had ever expected
i mean i'm going to be talking anyway so
to be paid to do it is pretty amazing
how many speeches a year would you give
well since the religion debate got
really going and became a big national
argument now a big cultural question i
would say it's probably
twice a week
um
and i do pro bono speeches of course for
good causes
um the liberation of iraq for example i
spent a lot of time arguing in public in
favor of the overthrow of saddam hussein
didn't get paid for that
this book if you if there were 300 some
thousand copies of this and you pick up
two three bucks a copy that's pretty
good money may is that is that and then
the odd some of my books have done okay
but i used to be box office poison for
publishers i mean i wrote some books
that i was quite proud of but george
orwell was one i remember and it didn't
really sell at all except among well
fans um
this one right and then i
yes thank you i actually found this on
the remainder table i'm sorry to tell
you that
as long as it doesn't have an
inscription from me inside saying
it does not saying to angela with
undying love or something
i hate it when that happens what about
your book i'm sure uh that it causes
controversy when you go on mother teresa
did that cell oh that sells a lot
especially at christmas time
uh christmas time yes uh ex or lapsed
catholics uh give it to their families
for christmas on a regular basis every
year it's the gift that keeps on giving
and then i teach i teach at hoover
and and i'm a visiting professor at the
new school in new york i love doing that
i really do
i learn a lot from teaching that's the
whole point i mean you go through a book
with your class you think you've read it
50 times
the 51st time you'll always still notice
something you wouldn't have noticed
before you never do read the same book
twice helps you to write helps you to
think does your wife work i wish it paid
more teaching was better paid than it
than it was because order that i had
didn't have three children
because i'd love to spend more time
teaching and less time
just
you know feeding the beast there's your
wifer
she's a screenwriter
which as you know means that you're
never quite sure
whether you've sold the script or not i
mean so the things are always in play
she's an angelina
i i have a question uh
do you know i know you're not expecting
this uh i didn't i i wasn't expecting
any of them i i know but we didn't none
of this was controlled it sure isn't but
have you ever gotten
on your wikipedia site
no you you mean
the christian
wikipedia no you have never looked at it
no
i i don't surf much anyway
i just wanna i i got on and it's 20
pages long
and but and you know how this works
no this is an area i'm very poor on but
there are several websites
i know about me
i just said there's a wikipedia one
there's a there's a website there was
called
hitchens watch or something that's
unfriendly to me there's another one
that is more friendly
i i don't have time for this to be
honest the reason i ask you this is
because when you google the name
christopher hitchens or you google
anybody's name more than likely the
first couple of
of uh places to go is wikipedia and
wikipedia is written by almost
anonymously by maybe in your case
hundreds of people right
i got i found your first wikipedia site
uh and you were first up at least
according to what i could find on the
records in 2003 wikipedia is seven years
old i just wanted you to hear what
people said
seven six years ago yeah may 18 2003
first item
christopher hitchens
you see we as readers don't know who
wrote this
but it's a it's a just before we go i
would say that when i look at wikipedia
myself
on a topic i know something about i
generally find it so i may be giving a
hostage to fortune here i generally find
it amazingly reliable well it's not a
question of reliability this question
they can characterize you here and i
just want to i want to read well they're
free to do that back in 2003 what they
said what they whoever they are
christopher hitchens is a british-born
american journalist author and
self-proclaimed political gadfly
that's not true
well i'm not so reclaimed okay but here
we are you know uh you never said this
is this week in wikipedia and i've just
owned the word guideline so they're
wrong right there okay but well that's
changed how does one get it corrected
well let me read to you what is today
that's gone they have to go back and say
today it says christopher eric hitchens
yes born april 13 1949 is an author
journalist and literary critic
how we doing
well current boring but uncontroversial
i know currently living in washington dc
he has been a columnist at vanity fair
the atlantic world affairs the nation
slate free inquiry
and a variety of other media outlets
and it goes on and this is it you know
talks about your book god it's not great
and all that but then it gets downer
says in 2009 hitchens was listed by
forbes magazine as one of the 25 most
influential liberals in the u.s media
the same article noted though that he
would quote likely be aghast to find
himself on this list unquote and that he
quote styles himself as a radical
unquote not a liberal
how we doing that's all right but it's
getting to the point where
you're getting publicity for getting
publicity
which is to me
um slightly boring i mean well it's
there's too much of this stuff now
it's all sort of reputation about your
reputation often wikipedia has nothing
to do with being exciting or boring
because they have so many people get
their hands in the pie on this thing
yeah
they might as well say there's a
perception that rather than the
following is the case well because i
don't know i can't see why there's so
much of this stuff but yeah well i know
there is it goes on forever and ever and
i just you know i was interested in one
will life
they have the different categories
literary review
hitchens and the nation staff
and then they quote one of your old
friends alexander coburn
what's your relationship with him now
i haven't seen alexander since his
beautiful niece's wedding where he
officiated a little while ago um
we used to see a lot of each other but
we live on remotely opposite coasts now
he's in northern california and i'm in
the washington machine on the on about
the third page of wikipedia
fourth page it says among his most
severe critics his one-time colleague
and friend alexander coburn a weekly
contributor to the nation on august 20
2005 coburn wrote what a truly
disgusting sack of you-know-what
hitchens and there's another four-letter
word yeah the guy who called sid
blumenthal one of his best friends and
then tried to have him thrown into
prison for perjury
a guy who awaited until his friend
edward saeed was on his deathbed before
attacking him in the atlantic monthly a
guy who knows perfectly well
the role israel plays in the u.s policy
but who does not
scruple to flail cindy
sheehan as a larushi and an anti-semite
because maybe she dared mention the word
israel
he's really
he's
nearly right about that i mean the sack
of et cetera is
better anyone's opinion but
on the um
criticisms of syed
i didn't publish them when he was on his
deathbed um
except in that i kept on publishing and
we had he and i had a couple of
long-standing disagreements and those
didn't change when he was ill and they
didn't indeed change after he died when
i published a sort of
estimate of him um
i thought a fairly generous one but
which included the criticisms it's
actually rather silly of alexander
to say that i think because if you look
at his journalism he would rightly be
proud of saying that
he's often written counter obituaries of
people who've been overpraised and
chosen precisely the moment when the
there's a lot of sentimental garbage
being published to say come on this guy
wasn't so great so it it's silly of him
to he he gives a hostage to fortune in
saying that you know
i caught out in a lie um on slate you
can check it out um it was exhaustively
done with all kinds of threats she had
said she thought her son was killed in a
in his a pro-israeli war a war a war
jewish war war for israel she later
tried to pretend she hadn't said this
in an email and um so i caught her
i caught her twice um
it's i think it's beneath alexander to
be
defending someone as cheap and demagogic
as her i mean who who remembers now the
cindy sheen campaign honestly
and what if we'd listen to her
if we listened to her and pulled out our
troops as a result of her hysteria
iraq would now be run by al-qaeda
and we and al-qaeda could have claimed
to have driven us out in ignominious
shame instead of which al qaeda has been
defeated and humiliated
and iraq is at least on course to become
many shoals ahead of it a decent society
no one no one can possibly wish that
cindy sheen had been listened to then or
any other by the way i'll be glad to let
you see this is 20 pages long one of the
longest that i've seen in wikipedia so
they're defining you and when you go out
to speak you'd be surprised how often
you might be introduced with the
information that's contained in here yes
well
i'll i'll bear it in mind but i'm
now that
this youtuber knows all this stuff
it's hopeless to even want to in fact
fortunately i don't
want to have any control over one's own
image let me ask you in our time
remaining yeah what
um
in your historian you've looked
talk about the world where do you fit
911
in events that have happened in world
history
i mean how would how is this going to
fit 25 years from now i think it'll fit
with a couple of other events
um
one that to me gets more and more
significant as time goes where you also
very kindly had me on
14th of february uh 1989
um
the ayatollah khomeini's fatwa against
salman rushdie there's a new book by a
man called kanan malik
an author in britain
about the fatwa against roshi and it's
called from fatwa jihad
and
i think that
the hinge moment in history the time
when things were turning in a major
cultural way historical way is somewhere
between
89 and 2001 when a a wing of islam at
any rate a certain arc of the muslim
world
decided that it was a war
and then it took a little time for us to
discover that we were world war ii
but history does turn a bit more slowly
than that there aren't
when you have a moment like sarajevo in
1914
say or
some apparent flash of or the bastille
in 1789
or
lexington um what these flashes
illuminate is a scene that's already
been prepared
already been set
and there's that's the way i think to be
a historian the way to look at things
one of the questions that i i know i
used to love to get the audience's
reaction to is
on our cullen show is america the
greatest country in the world
or is how how would you answer with
spyro agnew was supposed to have said
the greatest nation in the country
something that govidal has a wonderful
take on this um
it's something to be
uh
proven rather than stated it seems to me
something to be demonstrated rather than
a firm
but yes i would say in this sense um as
someone who used to you know take pride
in being called a revolutionary
maybe
sometimes for good and sometimes for
slightly calorie reasons but anyway i'm
not ashamed of it
but where's the russian revolution now
it's gone
where's the chinese revolution now it's
mutated into something completely
opposite different to itself the cuban
revolution is more abundant the best the
french revolution well it was what did
have a great effect on the enlightenment
but it was and i wouldn't denigrate it
was french
the american revolution
the one that says
build your republic on
individual rights not group rights have
a bill of rights that inscribes these
makes them available and legible to
everybody
um separate the church from the state
separate the executive the judicial and
the political branch do all these things
it doesn't sound like much but it's
really a very revolutionary idea there's
hardly a country in the world that
wouldn't benefit
from adopting those principles
i think that gives the united states a
really good claim
to be a revolutionary country as well as
of course paradoxically it's a very
conservative one
certainly makes me very glad very proud
to become a citizen of it
what's the
flag in your lapel
that is the flag of kurdistan the
kurdish people are the largest
people in the world the largest
ethnic group if you like the largest
nation
um that don't have a state
and then the gatari and kuwaiti royal
families have a seat and a vote of the
united nations the the kurdish people
who are perhaps as many as 35 to 40
million don't have any diplomatic
representation at all but they are a big
part of free iraq
and so i i wear the flag as a sign of
solidarity with the the revolution in
iraq that
removes saddam hussein defeated al qaeda
and is trying to build a republic
we've got just about a minute left uh
you're always traveling
where's your next trip
um i don't know
sorry for such a boring answer my last
trip was to athens maybe that's better
so just come back
i'm trying to write something about the
new acropolis museum
the greatest new museum
um in
for a long time in europe be opened on
21st of june it'll contain all the
sculpture
and treasury of of the parthenon and the
other temples of the acropolis and
it will it has room for all the stolen
sculpture taken by british imperialists
like lord elgin
to be given back so we can see how all
that sculpture is symmetrical and
supposed to be seen the same place at
the same time and i've done a piece of
vanity fair about
how wonderful it will be when we can see
all that
i suppose that better mention this book
one more time if you would god is not
great how religions poison everything by
christopher hitchens
uh we are out at fine book stores
everywhere
and and then thank you for for joining
us it was a pleasure
as always
[Music]
for a dvd copy of this program call
1-877-662
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
q a dot org
q a programs are also available as
c-span podcasts
[Music]
i i'm not going to embarrass you last
night
i lost my virginity as an independent
reporter i don't think you could get
away with it all
this time now you know millions of us
you can be really dangerous
there's a great reporter there
come and meet these people come here
i want to introduce two people to you
all right come here thank you john barry
come come forward
this is paula gordon
major uh media star in atlanta and
throughout the nation david young is the
president
the emperor the king
of hacienda and john barry
is one of the greatest come here one of
the greatest reporters
who ever refused to accept my i was
he was the star on the sunday times
head of the inside team well i i must
tell you both i have taken a sneak peek
and read the book
i already have an
right admirer actually went to the store
and bought it good wow real money real
money i'm not i'm not used to that i'm
used to people sending me books i'm
sorry i um
well worth it thank you ma'am
john is in the book
uh he's in more than the index you know
well sir harold has been very kind and i
came just for this oh
good don't go home
okay
john is um
a fantastic writer
and i can tell you hundreds of stories
about him you know in his presence even
but most most of the schedules
no no but i mean i'll never forget he
knows this when the french uh entity
goal riots took place in 1968
and we had a job getting in but anyway
we got reported in photographer and a
flood of paragraphs
etc came in
and we did eight eight or 12 pages and
he pulled the whole bloody lot together
seamlessly
i'll never forget it
you know i said i don't think i've done
that myself
what i remember about that is that one
of our reporters tony garagey
tony oh my god right who was who's
eccentric back even then
he on the flight over to paris
um
his colleagues from sunny times going
with him
realized that he was dressed in a
business suit
but was wearing track shoes
and had a crash on it and he had a large
hold all beside him
and they said tony what's in that and he
opened it
and it was full of cans of baked beans
and they said
you were going to one of the capitals of
the food world he said i know but it's a
revolutionary situation you have to be
prepared for anything
extraordinary
he's the publisher of scoop
so that he must remember that
yes the ira books was all bad
it's very good
of course it caused a lot of trouble as
i recall yeah
a lot of angst and heartburn i know that
was a really marvelous job but let's go
into the fire so you know what it's like
dog earrings or your pages do you know
how much i mean how much time that would
spend that would spend
for three hours
oh it's huge
christopher is the only person i've ever
interviewed where i got to ask him
questions about so when did your mother
stop talking to you
stop yourself before it gets to that
anyway
young gentlemen waiting
it's been getting on so well with the
website
and i'm waiting now for tapan i know
and when that's done i i can't put
anything to you email to turner no
i i have no coming over i've absolutely
i have no energy until i've got rid of
everything okay
you know i get up at six i was up at six
this morning okay no problem i am
working on
no problem i will do i know i'm even
i've got other possibilities including
i think it's worth going back to
bloomberg and asking for 10 million and
they're going to ask the lloyd blank
boys for 10 million
will is it i mean welcome this man
hi harry and jobet i'm so glad to see
you here i love your necklace
oh
i want to ask you about that beautiful
photograph of the cover yes it's taken
by snowden one of my
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes you are lovely you know chris
buckland we're just chatting hey oh
hello harry evans nice to meet you
you can't carry that without my signing
yes i can i'm an irishman
you've played the cover on it so many
times of course i can
i don't know why you're staying up
partying partying too late so you'll be
fresh tomorrow morning
anyway foreign it's good today i'm glad
i'm glad to be doing this we're doing
c-span i'm doing something here should i
sign it howie no
hold this little press club when you're
here yeah i'm coming to the right
competition
thank you very much
indeed it out to
uh i'm going to say something here where
did you come are you originally from
london
are you from oh you're from derry
oh i want to introduce you to somebody
john barry our insight reporter
who did the major book perspective on
ulster
which was a huge
controversial book
most i'm sure you'll like it actually
he's here i'm going to show you
i'm very interested to talk with you
about your perspective on where
newspapers are going
in particular with regard to the
changing uh
business model uh well i'd like to talk
about that he knows all the ancestors
harry told a great story of going to
harvard
and the kids saying to him
i don't need you i can get all i need on
youtube that's right you remember that i
put i do not only do it i wrote it in i
wrote a chapter in the book on the
future of newspapers i had to take it
out because it was changing too quickly
you know
anyway here's to ireland
i have
one for your press club this week what
are you at the press club this week yeah
yeah i know i've got the best of luck
all right are you going to the book fair
yeah i'm going to sign focus that's
wonderful
i have one third irish one third english
and one third welsh blood well you know
the irish have a lot of sympathy for the
welsh we know that if they've been able
to swim they've been irish
the welsh and the irish compete in being
able to speak i know
i'll see you bye
hey
is that a book
you can't buy the book without me
signing it i got one oh you got it okay
well i'll sign it anyway
who should i make it out to and i will
tell you that secretary powell is
wandering around looking for you where
is he okay well he was behind us
he came by saying where's harry where's
harry
where i'm gonna find him now it's two
name trevor
[Music]
very nice to see you how are you
very nice to see you
in america
where is colin powell
hey harry
i know i'll introduce you to my wife you
told me if i was in washington
so here i am
great to see you this is a very
important lady
steven seagal runs wnet as far as the
news and the content goes in new york
and sherry is the head of the national
portrait gallery
wonderful
come and let me meet this collins
i've got to say fan colin powell he's
here somewhere
hilarious
would
you know what another thing which has
been maddening about publication in this
book is that people say why why haven't
you aged as well as colin powell
it was photographic in the book
hello my dear
congratulations thank you
thanks for helping so much everybody
anything i could do baby
we're
foreign
the world
and marie and all of her kids have h1n1
so they're but they're recovered
my daughter had it and they they gave
him some tamil food on their farms
you going to give a speech yeah in five
or five minutes or so
gina was going to give this speech
he gives a lot of speeches at home
this is his first drink of heart like
really the first drink of life okay i'm
sure he from from earliest days yeah
you know
again
oh my god
i'd say
i didn't know how to send you one it's a
is it as good as good time
they said a few things
because i love that one yeah
i don't know it's one
quite very romantic in many ways about
newspapers
and it's
i'm not attracting as many people
[Music]
as i do
we have done
congratulations on your new book thank
you the new york times took good care of
you i thought
yeah it was nice very positive review so
the best reviews have been in the uk bro
because they yeah the guys knew me and
they described how hilarious and
ridiculous it was to work for me
and that guy there uh
torture in northern ireland we've
investigated it
well just so much
put a bit of weight on it
the littlest book he ever wrote was with
us called war story i thought i looked
to him
very nice to meet you debbie nice
[Music]
paper tomorrow morning
because we we're testing political
correctness all the way the washington
examiner i know we're going to talk
later i'm going to just sit over there
people want me to sign books and stuff
which i'm speaking or something like
that right you have to speak yeah i'm
going to speak now well very nice to
meet you
please thank you
oh [ __ ]
i can introduce myself
i just put together a lawyer who worked
for ralph nader
and came over to deal with this limited
issue oh he did oh god i've got news for
him i heard your interview on npr yeah
okay if i put with love is that all
right oh please
i will be honored
well keep it from my wife i will be
honored i will not tell you why
not
ladies and gentlemen uh
welcome julian irons are delighted to
see you all here at the british embassy
and of course a special welcome to
harold evans and
tina brown
we at the embassy are delighted to be
participating in the launch of harry's
book my paperchase true stories of
vanished times
an ella drive title
the book covers and i've started reading
it the book covers
a huge amount of ground from harry's
childhood in the north of england and
for a time you won't know this
you were living in eccles a few hundred
yards from where
julia later grew up in wynton
then on to his professional career
as a journalist editor publisher and
author
but this isn't
just another
autobiography this is also a biography
of the newspaper industry over many many
significant decades and the book
describes that
uh
almost industrial process of producing
uh a newspaper over um really the best
part of the um of the last
of the last century now all that um has
in one way vanished but the book is
decidedly not an obituary for for print
journalism
um mark twain said i'm not an editor of
a newspaper and shall always try to do
right and be good so that god will not
make me one
uh
harold evans's 14-year tenure as the
editor of the sunday times and then for
a year as the
editor of the daily times of london
produced work of really extraordinary
high standard
in 2001 journalists named him the
greatest
british newspaper editor of all time
and
he
he championed what yesterday's review of
the book in the new york times called a
crusading style of journalism in which
he and his paper afflicted the guilty
and championed the innocent
and
people of my generation who got
interested in national and international
politics very often did so because of
the sunday times because of its flair
its cultural leadership and its inve
investigative zeal
but this is also a transatlantic story
harold evans's first encounter with
americans i read the other day was
during the second world war in
manchester and his heartless fellow
fellowship in 1956 began a lifelong
association and he and tina have lived
here for nearly 30 years although tina
doesn't remember it julia and i were her
contemporaries at oxford and she had a
knack of stopping the traffic there just
as she's done here ever since
harry's american career took him to
u.s news and world report a number of
other top publications to random house
and from publishing to writing including
the award-winning the american century
now
you harry and tina are both now american
citizens i'm not holding that against
you
but you retain extraordinarily close
links with the uk um this embassy and i
wish the book every success it's a
remarkable story so ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming sir harold
evans
[Applause]
i've just got to adjust i can't be
elevated so i have to
allow
so
this
uh
thank you so much for those
excellent words
it's always good to come back to britain
which is where we are because this is
british territory you understand
and not to go through the formalities of
proving who i am
which is what happens of course when you
go through any security
the lucky nigel is so lucky
because it's true
julia down
lived very close to me
and he's lucky because we never met
because who knows tina what might have
happened if i'd met
the gorgeous julia who was a
became a scientist and like me ended up
in the united states
tonight really it should be a
celebration
not of me frankly
but of reporting
that's what my book is about it's about
what newspapers can achieve
not what an editor can achieve
but what the reporters
on the ground can achieve
that's why i'm particularly honored
tonight
to have ben bradley here who represents
journalism at its best and many other
excellent reporters here
i'm also glad of course that we are here
with the week which is a synthesis i
think
of remarkable quality about what's best
that's going on at the moment
because few people apart from me can
read every newspaper every day
and so the week provides that synthesis
and guide
as well
so celebrating reporting means actually
which all of us know what reporting is
as northcliff said news is what somebody
somewhere
wants to suppress
everything else is advertising
and
and in fact of course those of you who
are in journalism will know
the truth of that what i'd like to say
one of the reasons when i was writing
this book i wasn't really i did get
nostalgic what i got nostalgic for and
what i've written what impel me along
especially in these times when people
are questioning the value of
print and what it might do
and
what i was able to achieve was not by me
it was by these reporters so when we
were campaigning for thalidomide victims
who were born without arms and very
often with our arms and legs
are a government-approved prescription
and we won a great battle against the
drug companies and against the attorney
general and my beloved britain i'm still
by the way dual citizenship so
i don't know that's going to make it
life difficult for me now but um
we were able to do that because the
reporters in question
actually studied the chemistry of
thalidomide and i remember going along
to the offices of the insight group and
seeing the molecular structure of the
divide there and frankly nobody done it
nobody looked at how the disaster
occurred
ralph nader was here tonight was a
tremendous
support in that campaign and a lot of
people were supportive in all these
campaigns
the dc-10 air disaster
the largest air crash in the world at
the time
congress began to invest yesterday then
got bored
so the truth about what happened to
create that terrible disaster
was left of the press and i'm proud of
what the reporters on that particular
story did or take another one
i'm sure i said nigel never knew kim
philby that's why okay even relax
and and exposing that great cover-up and
the damage he did
and the lives that he lost was extremely
tricky and i want to say again that was
a question of reporting
now straight reporting is very important
and investigative journalism is only an
aspect of it but it's a
very difficult form and in the sunday
times we found a team was a great way to
do it
and one of the things i'm very proud
that the paper achieved
was to bring some kind of
understanding of the history and the
currencies
of what was happening in northern
ireland
and john barry who's here tonight the
head of the inside team
and his team working through some of the
most difficult circumstances ever
produced a fantastic
book and report called perspective on
ulcers
when i was prosecuted by the ira
i which i was for suggesting that
some of the members were stealing money
i had to go to belfast and
most unfortunate the guys who were
escorting me
took a wrong turning and said get down
you're in danger
so i got down but it reminded me of what
the reporters on the spot were doing
every day
so that's what we're here to celebrate
tonight just at a time and i've seen it
happen more and more when really good
reporting is being squeezed out of
existence
often by
meat meatheads i call them people with
more
i would think the newspaper is a great
way to make a lot of money as it was
isn't any longer and to just know
uh that
a reporter or a newspaper would go in
for that so it's very i think we have to
keep reminding everybody that journalism
is not dead the delivery vehicle will
change and so it must change
so that's very important and i've always
been very grateful
that my publishers little brown gave me
the time
to try and set out
what a newspaper can do
not just the sunday times what good
newspapers can do everywhere we have
here tonight
a very distinguished indian editor
called avexaka
whom i knew
in the 1960s
and he went back to bengal and has
created a most wonderful
publishing empire television and
investigations and again absolutely
central to the conduct of indian
democracy
is depressed so
uh when we drink tonight let's drink two
reporting and thank you very much indeed
for all of you for coming tonight
[Applause]
yeah i'll send you a kind of please do i
just need your regrets
you have a lot of fun with it was that
important to you it wasn't just
going to be reporting
i'm so pleased
this is quite funny colin powell's in
this book here you'll see him thank you
very much thank you okay richard good
bless thank you very much paula
hey hello
deborah nelson i was margaret carlson's
producer at cnn and i enjoyed your uh uh
dream jobs conference last week oh he
was there he was there of course
everyone else it was great
margaret is a great job in getting him
now it's deborah isn't it yes debra
i'm matt panter with senator gillibrand
oh you are yeah i love her how have we
met before
yeah i know i wasn't able to make it to
the dinner at your home no i thought you
were uh comrade came there but uh
but we're in the same dirty business
so
i'm looking forward to reading it well i
hope you're doing
it takes a pretty good it gets a bit it
it takes a bit it's quite long thank you
for the call oh thank you thank you very
much thank you you look great
anyway there's a picture here you look
absolutely
are you taller than i am yeah he is
[Music]
this man he used to be a journalist yeah
i know for god's sakes
you're so great
you are so great i mean i'm really
honored that you're here oh good god
what are you signing yeah
yeah hey i sent you one my son ralph how
are you
thank you
thank you
hey tina's here you know
tina was looking for it looking for him
you want the three of us yeah yeah come
on come on you have your uh struggled
against
the official secretary all right i know
i didn't mention it you're right the
body's a success all three of us are
here
survivors
uh this is for you ralph
i put
what i truly believe is the correct
description
you got a good review yeah i'm doing
fine great too yeah yeah and also in
this chicago sometimes did you see the
parade yeah
chicago sometimes but you know sydney
mentioned never met him
let me hey
thank you so much i'm just so pleased to
see you
guys
hey congrats
i didn't intend to show murdock being
kicked in the face
harold evans is the former editor of the
times of london and the sunday times
he's also former publisher and president
of random house for more information
visit randomhouse.com
fork slash store
coming up next book tv presents
afterwards an hour-long interview
program where we invite a guest host to
interview the author of a new book
this week george packer and christopher
hitchens talk about george orwell and
his work mr packer selected the pieces
that appear in two recently published
volumes of george orwell's writing
facing unpleasant facts and all art is
propaganda
mr hitchens an essayist for the atlantic
monthly is the author of why orwell
matters
[Music]
welcome to c-span book tv's afterwards
program my name is christopher hitchens
and i'm here in the for me on a custom
role of
interviewer and producer
of
my friend and colleague george packer
who's produced two volumes of the essays
of george orwell appropriately
picked and introduced and commented upon
and so today orwell is our subject and
so i wish we had more than an hour
um
i'm guessing that you would have read dj
taylor's book on george orwell i haven't
oh what a shame it doesn't matter
because
what i wanted to
say from his um book was
something that i have a feeling you'll
agree with taylor writes at one point
says when i read other people writing
about george orwell i keep thinking hey
this is my author you're talking about
that do you ever get that feeling
um i do
and um it we all have a
you and i and a few other people we know
and some we don't know are part of a a
really
fanatical group of orwell lovers and
it's very personal and
i started reading orwell
uh maybe a little late it was in my
early 20s but it was at a critical
moment when i needed
a kind of a model i needed to know how
does one become a writer and so i just
read straight through what was then
the only
collection of orwell's
essays in journalism the four volumes uh
collected essays journalism and letters
and just read straight through it was
like reading a an autobiography um and
you found yourself being personally
addressed i felt very close to the voice
of those pieces and i think
those are where you get closest to
orwell uh to his voice to what's
essential to his
really what in his character is um
strong and
worth emulating and i became a slavish
emulator and imitator for a while in my
20s i think it's a good way to learn how
to write just to find a writer you feel
some affinity for and just
master their pro style their rhythms you
get get the the the cadences into your
own
nerve system and and then
try to find your own way into it but
that's the closeness orwell produces in
people like me and you and so yeah we
feel a little bit proprietary uh when we
read other people um
write writing about him too but not when
those people get him right and i think
your book why orwell matters gets him
right you said in that book orwell got
the three basic questions of the 20th
century right imperialism fascism and
communism and
that's um that sums up his
political and literary achievement as
well as any single i would feel they
derived from each other in other words
from what he saw about imperialism
especially the sort of
sexual repression and racism that it
involved i think he found it quite easy
to
decode the appeal of fascism and and the
danger of it it was to some extent an
extension of imperialism not purely but
to a good deal
yeah uh um to a good deal in in many
ways that was the case and then
because it's funny he hardly writes
anything about fascism he seems to just
assume everyone will know that it's evil
and needs to be fought against
there's almost nothing
strange there's always no analysis of it
um he takes it for granted that it's uh
completely unacceptable but it's in the
course of fighting against one kind of
totalitarianism
he discovers that there are many people
claiming to be his allies who are not
yes and actually there's a there's a an
almost equally dangerous illusion taking
place on the other side of the murals
that's right and he turned uh the same
you know withering
uh scrutiny on his own side that he had
turned in on a much easier target nazi
germany fascist italy um franco spain
and
that was when he made most of his
enemies
on the left and all the way to the end
of his life yeah now i realize i haven't
said quite enough about you i should
probably said some of this at the
beginning but um for those of you who
don't know him already or know his work
uh mr packer well first came to my
attention actually as a novelist writing
from
africa um in fact and
like all well um was capable of fiction
um
very enviably as well as of
the essay the long essay form by which i
would think you're now probably reaching
a larger audience mr parker's work
especially from iraq
um
and other parts of the world but
especially from iraq and the new yorker
has
got him a great deal of attention and i
believe you now have a collection of
essays
a new book out called interesting times
writings from a turbulent decade but
back to fiction um you probably over
praised me there i did write two novels
um they were read by about 35 people
and although i learned a lot from
writing them i did not learn to be a
novelist i don't think um
orwell wrote uh a batch of novels in the
1930s that were in the tradition of
anglo-american realism
and
i love them i i don't know how you feel
about them but for me keep the
aspedistra flying uh is
just a marvelous book burmese days is
the one that really lasts the longest
but you just don't feel that orwell's
working in his most natural grain in
those novels you feel the essay is sort
of pushing
through the
uh the the illusion of fiction all the
time he has something to say he has an
argument to make he has something you
know a proposition about the world all
the time and he doesn't have the
restraint and patience of a natural
fiction writer and that's why we can be
grateful that he once wrote in
i think why i write that if he'd been
left to his own devices he would have
been a kind of 19th century british
novelist like his heroes dickens and
kissing
but events and the turbulence of the 30s
and 40s pushed him into becoming what he
called a kind of pamphlet here
yeah
um
and and by the way i should have to
interrupt it's one of the very few
completely unconvincing things i think
he ever absolutely i was just gonna say
that because
really it was not events to push him in
that direction it was his own
inclination
um his also it's a very rare case of him
being
too conceited in other words he said if
it wasn't for all these polemics i have
to write i could have been charles
dickens will come on you know that's a
bit much
um the burmese say it was saying in
burma that he flattered them by writing
three novels about their country
burmese days yeah animal farm in 1984
right i actually heard that line um in
burma um last year when i went through
yes orwell is still
a huge presence in burma all the more
i think now there's a young generation
who did not learn english well growing
up they came after the generation that
was schooled by the british they've been
they've had their futures utterly
blighted
by the totalitarian regime there and
orwell speaks to them not just because
he wrote about burma
but as you say because he wrote about
totalitarianism 1984 has so many echoes
in burma today and so you can actually
find animal farm being sold discreetly
in book stalls on the streets of rangoon
and so he's a kind of he's re-emerged as
a hero to these younger burmese writers
after being condemned for his
supposed imperialism by the the hunter
and while we're on
contemporary hotel terrorism which we
might as well
stay with for a bit um i've been in
north korea and you know when one goes
as a reporter one hopes to avoid cliche
so i thought i'm going to try not to
mention 1984
because everyone says it's an orwellian
state funny use of the word of williams
yeah but in fact the great thing about
totalitarianism is that it is a cliche
it seems to do the same thing over and
over
north korean state the same year that
that 1984 came out i think and it's as
if someone gave him the novel in korean
and said do you think we could make this
work and he thinks we'll legend over
we'll sure give it our best shot
it's it's absolutely remarkable life
imitated yes it's the same when people
in countries like this come across
orwell as the north koreans one day will
they're amazed i think the greatest
compliment perhaps ever paid to one
writer by another in the 20th century
was by schezwave muwash when he in the
captive mind
when he wrote um about the situation in
stalinist poland he said there is a book
in circulation it's called 1984. it's
you can only get it privately
circulated with great secrecy and fear
if among the inner party
and he said i personally was very
surprised as we all were to find out
he'd never visited
the soviet union because how could he
get that texture how can you get the
texture of it also right without
having had this experience
remember
1984 is about the circulation of an
illegal book within the inner party
so it's it's extraordinary that is a
great question how did orwell know he
lived almost his entire life in england
he um traveled a bit through europe at
the end of world war ii he had his years
in burma but other than that he was very
parochial he was confined to the island
and and yet he wrote in
his essay on arthur kessler
that the british writers of his
generation had failed to understand
totalitarianism because they had not
lived it the way kessler salone
camus and other continental writers had
and so he was sort of criticizing the
you know what he called the parlor
bolsheviks uh auden spender et cetera
for not
feeling what it is to live under that
kind of regime orwell
felt it but he had the same other than
his years in burma and his
suffering and hard times in the 30s
which they did not have he had the same
education and lived in the same england
that they did and yet he did feel it and
that's a
it's a bit of a mystery how he could
have known it so well i think i have a
possible solution and also a slight
correction to you um
in reverse order then um
or correction first um not as insular as
all that after he did spend a lot of
time in the far east admittedly as a
colonial policeman but i think being a
colonial cop gave him an insight into
the master servant
indeed almost master slave relationship
very useful in describing
some of the again dirty secret sexual
underlay of totalitarianism then
um he was in spain and he was in
barcelona at a time when the communist
party did briefly take over and there
was a police terror that's right and
third very important he noticed that all
the truth about spain had been written
out of the record and he wrote in
looking back on the spanish war he was
really afraid this was becoming a habit
now in europe
but if the leader says something never
happened then it never did and you can
see the germ of 1984 done partly by the
father of your old nation colleague um
claude coburn father of alexander yes um
and by um
not just by communists i mean quite a
lot of other people fell for the line
that the
the communist party was the best
defender of the spanish republic and
it's only very recently that the
archives of
both franco's system and the stylist
system have been opened and we do know
what happened in those may days in
barcelona and actually what what orwell
said was happening was in every detail
true yeah he refused the lie but then
the second point i want to make is about
going on with his insularity
is his first um
uh real book is uh written in french
found out in paris and it was originally
a french book
he spoke very good french he spoke at
least two
indian and burmese languages it wasn't
written in french he wrote the essays in
it the sketches in english he wrote a
couple of little essays uh for a small
french publication called le progres
when he was in paris
including a long essay on colonialism
that's right that's right and then
wrote the manuscript of down and out
which uh
he
which was rejected by
um t.s eliot
and um some of the other major did it
reject that in person no it was rejected
by um
yeah i think it was elite he was at
faber in 1931 or 32 and and rejected and
then rejected animal farm yes many years
later
so he and orwell had uh as did um
connection harcourt brace in
america one of the best rejection
letters i think ever written
every aspiring writer should have this
rejection letter
paste it in their hat to consult it says
dear mr orwell thank you for letting us
look at your manuscript animal farm
we unfortunately it's impossible to sell
stories about animals in the united
states that's right and so in the
country of disney
uh they could make such a factual
ceremony and they really thought it was
a story about the family and then animal
farm became a very good cartoon film um
so it is they they they were wrong about
that commissioned by the ceo yeah but
just to get back to
the experience of reading orwell and and
the essays in this book um
when i started reading him and i don't
know if you had this experience
i didn't know much about fascism or
communism or imperialism i was looking
more for an example of how a writer
carried himself in the world and how
to transform
experience into sentences and how to do
it in a way
that didn't call more attention to
the self than to the experience and you
know in again in why right orwell wrote
good prose is like a window pane another
maybe dubious claim but
helpful in the sense that
his words are always pointing to the
thing and not back to
the the self and they reveal so much
about a character i mean there's
something almost
um
you feel you know him
uh when you read his essays you feel you
know how he speaks you can hear his
voice you know his irritations you know
how he's gonna react if you say
something is almost alive with you even
though there's also a certain remoteness
to orwell he doesn't let you in
on everything in his life he doesn't
talk about his marriage very much in his
writing he doesn't talk about his child
richard orwell he doesn't talk about his
parents some of the basic things that
american memoirists make you know um
gold out of that
are the subjects of book after book for
orwell were kind of off limits he was a
bit constrained maybe by
late victorian shibboleth that way but
nonetheless you have this very strong
sense of the person behind the words and
that
was what first drew me to him and makes
those essays you know worth reading over
and over again i should perhaps have
done this by now but um
just for those of you watching us this
is uh george's first um selection it's
called all artist propaganda and it's
about orwell's essays and then another
one called facing unpleasant facts
which is
his more polemical stuff we might say um
i've comment on both the um titles by
the way yeah
when orwell writes about himself he says
well when i got started all i knew i had
was
a little literary ability and a power of
facing
unpleasant facts i remember thinking a
power of facing
is very good i wanted to call my book
that for a while
um it's all something almost biblical
about it yeah it's an unusual phrase
isn't it um a power of facing as if it
it's an active force it gives you some
advantage which is true um he was able
to look at things
at times
almost exaggerated
the
ugliness or the bad smells or seemed to
seek them out with a kind of relish but
nonetheless
things in himself in england
in democracy um
in
uh literature in the working class and
in the working class which the famous
line from his great book about coal
mining and coal miners the road to wigan
pier uh the working classes smell yeah
which orwell said
isn't necessarily true but it's what
middle and upper class people think and
it's the reason why
um
the the the class divide is such a hard
thing to overcome in britain because
it's almost physical it's not just
uh kind of mental snobbery and i think
that line am i right that that line um
really bothered victor gallant who was
the publisher of the communists went on
for the rest of his life saying that
this is what orwell thinks about the
working class yeah exactly
they smeared him with it um but he
doesn't romanticize when he's among the
workers
though he's on their side um he doesn't
remind us doesn't matter
nor does he romanticize the colonial
subjects on whose side he also is that's
right because he often finds them
repulsive absolutely the opening lines
of uh
shooting an elephant which to me is
almost it's the perfect orwell essay
where you just see his mastery of the
form
at its best
and i use it to teach the essay a lot
because students just see how he does it
so clearly but in the at the beginning
he says with one part of my mind i hated
british imperialism with another party i
thought the greatest pleasure would be
to stab my bayonet into a buddhist
priest's guts and
that's a kind of confession about
himself and about the burmese
that um may be painful personally but as
from a literary point of view is very
powerful because it invites the reader
and it says i have all sorts of
conflicting feelings and i'm going to
own up to them and even make them the
subject of this essay another thing you
mentioned his reticence
by which he never says anything he never
tells us why
he resigned from the burmese police
that's right
um but my guess is that he was afraid if
he carried on with that he would become
a sadist
he had a streak of that in him yeah um
he wrote once that to understand fascism
you have to have a streak of fascism he
was talking about jack london um whose
book the iron heel was a kind of
prophecy of fascism but he might as well
have been talking about himself too and
that too i think is is an answer to that
question we were talking about earlier
how could orwell have understood what
was happening
behind the you know the veil of terror
of stalinist russia nazi germany um
without direct personal experience of it
except as you pointed out in in
barcelona and um i think it's partly
because he he had the
sterner stuff in him some of his british
um will you very correct
in your introduction that most of his
arguments were with himself
i thought that was very well
encapsulated because
a lot of people are if you like
naturally liberals or naturally
progressives they think it's just you
know a nice way to be and he absolutely
didn't think like that at all had scorn
for those who
who did and i think he what's
fascinating is he he's someone educating
himself out of an upbringing where he'd
been taught to look down on and rather
fear the lower orders
to look on
colored people in the empire as raw
material
to be very suspicious of jews which
clearly took him a long time to get over
the time there's to reason his way out
of that that's right your book makes
that clear
sorry to excuse me get carried away with
my own
um verbosity um
and then one
very very enduring prejudice which he
doesn't cure himself of his absolute
hatred and disgust for homosexuality
that's right he he used that phrase the
pansy left to talk about auden and
spender and yeah it was not the nicest
side of him and there are women who
think that he was a terrible misogynist
and
even that his misogyny his um
inability to create convincing female
characters for example julian 1984 is
not um the the most persuasive part of
that novel but that
that was part of why he ended with such
a dark vision of the world this is the
subject of a book
by um i think her name is daphne patai
the orwell
i don't think it's right i think that's
giving totalitarianism not enough credit
for being
um
the
the darkness that was surrounding europe
at the end of orwell's life
but it's true that um
he has a strange attitude you might
almost say toward individuals
unlike a journalist today he doesn't
spend a lot of time on characters in his
nonfiction you you never get to know any
coal miner that's true by name you don't
get to know
anyone in his outfit in the militia in
in barcelona particularly well you learn
a few of their names sometimes he just
recites them almost like an honor roll
but you don't get to
to the inside of their being no but
there's the perv about the soldier he
meets yeah
and sort of feels a comradeship with the
first handshake with the italian militia
man in barcelona yeah and that's a
beautiful moment at the beginning of
homage to catalonia um and then at the
end of the poem that can that concludes
that essay uh looking back on the
spanish war
and that but he also says i i didn't
want to meet him again because if i did
it would ruin my
first impression which is that this is
sort of the flower of the european
working class
and that i think is the way his mind
always goes away from the individual and
toward
the social type
um toward uh
the the political and social
significance of
digging coal underground so i think to
preserve his own distance you see i mean
one point he replies to someone who
asks him if he'd like to come to dinner
and meet steven spender then famous poet
of the period and um
and he says no because i think i may
want to write about him and i find it
much harder and i i think what i'm going
to say is going to be pretty disobliging
i find it much harder to do that once
i've met someone that's right it's sort
of both very human and also very inhuman
it's saying
i don't sort of trust myself to be
intermediate because he knows that as he
wrote in the essay on gandhi
being human means attaching yourself to
other human beings and being willing to
be
broken down and even
destroyed by your love for this
individual he was
that essay
is
quite harsh about gandhi's impersonal
love for all of humanity and his cruelty
or neglect of his own family for orwell
this was a perverse
uh inversion of the proper order of
things which is you love the individual
not mankind he was not a saint he was
not a lover of mankind in that sort of
gandhian way although he's been
sanctified by some people um
posthumously
so it it's absolutely true that that's
where his feelings drive him but there's
also a counter force
that that cuts him off from those
attachments and i think it may partly be
simply because
they get in the way of writing and
writing honestly and so the individuals
are missing strangely
is a good illustration of another point
you make which is
orwell's ability to start with a very
arresting opening sentence and one on
gandhi
as i know you know begins by saying well
all saints should be considered guilty
until proven innocent we could just swap
orwell openers here
no
autobiography should be trusted unless
it reveals something disgraceful which
is the beginning of his essay on dali
in mulman and lower burma i was hated by
large numbers of people the only time in
my life i've been important enough for
this to happen to me yes shooting in
ellsworth yes but i think with the
gandhi intro as well it shows something
else which is his general distaste for
the spiritual
he always thought there was something
shady or creepy about that and his
general
um contempt for religion though he had a
respect for it too i mean he obviously
knows the bible very well he quotes from
it a lot clearly from memory almost
always word perfect or as as good as
that's how i know it's from memory
yeah there's
at key moments uh his marriage to eileen
o'shaughnessy he
insisted on having it done in the church
of england ceremony he was buried in the
church of england
graveyard
he likes the liturgy very much you feel
it's a kind of cultural attachment to
the the words um the cadences and the
traditions of the church of england
which has absolutely nothing to do
with heaven which he described somewhere
as
in the vulgar version seeming like a
choir practice in a jeweler's shop
so yeah he he um he was not a religious
man there's no sign anywhere of a belief
in um in the afterlife well i think he
had a strong feeling for the protestant
revolution however i mean it shows in um
his attachment to milton who's the great
bard of that in fact his favorite line
um was a line of milton's which was by
the known rules of ancient liberty in
other words there is a human instinct
for freedom
and he writes about the protestant
centuries as he puts it in a positive
way contributing to the european
enlightenment and i think
in um back to 1984 again the struggle
against an alien language has been
imposed upon people that of newspeak
and the struggle to find out what is in
the secret book that only the party has
right is a very good analogy to the
struggle of wycliffe
and with
coverdale and tyndale to have the bible
translated into english for which they
were all martyred and i think the
english revolution was important to him
i think there's an essay called the
prevention of literature which is about
the effect of of not just totalitarian
countries but um
the internal censorship that came with
the
the totalitarianization
of british intellectuals and that essay
begins the effect on literature the
effect on books he says um so you know
books like some wild animals can't breed
in captivity um it kills the imagination
and that essay begins with a sort of a
scene from a gathering of penn the
writers organization that orwell
attended it's an unusual case in which
he actually places himself at a some
sort of public meeting as an ex jumping
off point for the essay and at this penn
meeting no one is able to stand up and
defend free expression everyone is
defending the right of the soviet union
to do this or
it it reminds me kind of the worst um of
sort of identity politics when it
invaded um
writers organizations in this country in
the 80s and 90s so suddenly the last
thing anyone wants to speak up for is
free expression i think a good example
which is very near to your heart is when
salman rushdie came under the fatwa from
the iranian government and there was
hardly any writer who was able to say
this is an absolute atrocity except you
did
that's too kind to me i mean there were
a lot of people who did very well i
remember susan sanchez actually convened
a very good meeting actually i think you
were among the very first but well but
back to orwell that essay then continues
to imagine what if milton were to come
back today and attend this pen meeting
um
he'd be astonished and no one at the
meeting in 1945 or six was able to
defend free expression with the
unqualified
force of milton uh 300 years earlier so
i think you're absolutely right that
that period was a kind of a a touchstone
for him uh in the in the struggle for
to the title of your mind other
volume when you say all artists
propaganda i have a question to ask you
i know that he wrote that in wartime as
he wrote in 1941 in wartime all writing
is now propaganda yeah it's in an attack
i think on alex comfort and his pacifism
that's right that's right
where does this come from yes
he says it in several places he says it
for example in his essay on dickens and
does he he does he does but what he
means by it
and he says it also i also begins very
brilliantly dickens is one of those
authors who's well worth stealing there
you go i knew we could have a little uh
ping-pong game of showing off opening
liners no it's fun
um
he i think he might say it in another
essay called the meaning of a poem
for him it means and the reason i gave
the book this title
not that all art it could have been
written by um
you know the minister of propaganda
joseph goebbels or even the ministry of
information in wartime england but that
all art
implicitly has a point of view it has
something to say about the world and as
he says it's trying to push
uh
one's view in a certain direction it has
a persuasive function it has a
uh
if it's worth anything it has a kind of
a world view that it is advocating and
i think it it's not um a resignation to
the crudeness of wartime propaganda it's
more
his sort of smoking out
the art for art sake crowd who would
like to have art be a separate from the
world of ideas and politics and
events and he's saying especially in a
time like
his the 40s yes it was impossible to be
a serious artist and not have something
to say about events even if um you're
writing very internally he makes that
confession
for himself and says every line i've
ever written in the last 20 years
on a serious topic or any serious line
is written with hope of
forwarding the cause of democratic
society democratic socialism is the
phrase he uses and against
totalitarianism i mean not every writer
is going to be as explicitly political
as orwell nor nor do we want them to be
but i think it's his technique as a
literary critic and as a critic of a
field he practically invented which is
popular cultural criticism
to find the
implied or hidden
world view in what seems to be a kind of
um benign or not
particularly pointed um realm of of art
or culture like the postcards of
sort
uh
the donald mcgill postcards um that that
are um sort of
semi-pornographic or at least mildly
risque that were sold in england at that
time monotonously indecent
that's a great phrase for it or the uh
the boys weeklies um or
um the detective novels in his essay
raffles and miss blandish he's always
that essay is a good example
what are you gonna do with an essay that
basically compares
two different eras and british detective
fiction raffles from the turn of the
century and a novel called no orchids
for miss blandish which apparently was
rather popular around 1943
and the point he comes to is there's a
shift in moral
point of view between these two raffles
has a code
which is
not a particularly
lovable code it's the code of a
hypocritical english gentleman but
nonetheless it's a code and so there's
certain things that can't be done
whereas no orchids for miss blandish
the only code is power and the pursuit
of it and that's what should be admired
and there's a great passage in that
essay where he says people
appreciate
power at the level at which they can
understand it and he has a boy in a
glasgow slum worships jack dempsey
a student at a business college worships
lord somebody or other
a reader of the new statesman worships
stalin
it's a difference in intellectual level
but not in moral outlook and that's how
he finds
sort of the
i'd say the moral implications of
something that seems as
trivial as as detective fiction i'm so
glad you bring this up because it
brings me quicker than i wanted to but
let's do it now it was something i
wanted to raise
a lot of his
um writing about
ethical codes and reticence and
discretion so versus ruthlessness and
the cult of violence
reflect hostility to the united states
yeah say that look at the comics the
british boys read now look at the
american ones that are coming in that
are full of sadism and gangsterism
exactly
um
so we we began by saying well you began
by saying of my book that i said you've
got three great questions for the 20th
century right yeah but i add that he got
one of them i think not totally wrong
but
the importance of america
was something that he didn't write
enough about and when he did it was
rather sketchy and often rather
condescending you have a chapter on
orwell in america which he never visited
um he loved some american writers mark
twain
jack london
um henry miller oddly enough um but i
think for orwell america thomas payne
thomas paine absolutely british-born
but i think for orwell america was um
[Music]
it didn't have the things that he was
attached to and that are the things
winston smith in 1984
is clinging to for sanity the um
the odd traditions
the things passed on from one generation
to another like the lyrics of uh of a
nursery rhyme or a song um
old books
that and book stores that trade in old
books of course some of these things are
available here he wouldn't have brittle
country churches with brass rubbings you
got it uh the the you tree in the
country church yard for orwell those
things were
sort of the bulwark against the
monolithic paving over of everything
by
not just totalitarianism but by modern
life i mean he hated concrete he hated
central heating
he hated
most mechanical entertainment he hated
advertising and all these things seem to
be coming not just from the east in the
soviet union but from the west in the in
the united states and and his
in this sense there was something
parochial about he did dislike
anti-americanism very much yes that's
right which was then beginning to become
a disease on the left because i think he
understood it to be a kind of
anti-liberalism
and a refuge of
of a particular kind of snobbery that
you find on the left which sees america
as
um you know the
the vulgarization of all good things
it's connected i think to the that plus
servative version
yeah but you're i think the point you
made in your book and you're making now
is absolutely right he didn't see
america as a guarantor
of the things that he
cared most about culturally especially
it was an alien and distasteful place to
him it's a pity that he died when he did
because his friends at partisan review
knowing he was unwell
the tb um trying to get him to come to
us firstly for treatment
really yeah because streptomycin is easy
to get and yeah very hard to get but he
died of poverty in fact he died almost
dickensian death yeah
and they said come over and you'll like
it and it would he would have been a
great addition to the partisan review
crap and he at one point he contemplated
making a voyage down the mississippi
which makes what he would have done
nice to have oh well going down after
1984 his next book would have been about
the mississippi now
yeah i've got something for you on the
american this is a very suggestive
slight but i think you might like it
you will have no difficulty in telling
me what the opening sentence of 1984 is
the clocks were striking 13. it was a
bright it was a bright cold day in april
and the clock was focused on 13 yeah
that's right
i was reading john adams the other day
and he he was writing about how to get
the colonies together
and how to coordinate a revolution
against british power he says it'll be
very difficult to get all 13 clocks to
strike at the same time there you go and
then at the end of the book in the
dictionary of newspeak at the end of
1984 they have he
shows how the attempt is made to
obliterate all the possibility even
thinking about freedom from the language
and just to make it impossible even to
formulate the thought and he gives an
example of a sentence that couldn't be
translated into newsbeat and it is
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that's great and the following you're
saying you know
there is
there's possible one certainly
a possible two and certainly one implied
compliments to america
but just imagine orwell traveling
through um early 50s america the america
of of lolita the america of um
the eisenhower years when
the suburbanization
of the country was happening the highway
system was in play was being put in
place intellectuals were beginning to
leave partisan review leave
greenwich village and
take
some comfort and and security in
universities it i it's it's almost
unimaginable it's like a whole different
era
had begun by that time and orwell to me
belongs so completely
to a previous era that was harder
more exacting more
more australian yeah and and all the the
abundance and comfort of of post-war
america would have i think would have
left him pretty cold although you're
right he would have found places to love
i think the mississippi is one maybe the
west with its uh
i would have thought new york too
i i probably not san francisco he didn't
love london i mean he lived in london
and he
uh worked in london he even made a point
of staying in london during the blitz
when other people were leaving but once
london was no longer at risk it's uh its
charms for him wore off which tells you
something about the way in which he
actually pursued hard experience
actively rather than simply not avoiding
it and so instead he moved to one of the
hardest places in the british isles the
isle of jura off the coast of scotland
where he lived his last years probably
hastened his death in 1984.
but this i don't know if you saw this
his son richard orwell his adopted son
had kind of maintained his silence for
60 years
and we only knew he existed we didn't
know anything about him and he gave an
interview about a year ago
he's i think an agricultural engineer
somewhere in england which is kind of
what you'd expect
and he describes being orwell's son in
those years in jura
and
far from being this gloomy apocalyptic
you know jeremiah of totalitarianism
orwell was just a lot of fun he took him
fishing he took him boating they went on
all these adventures they nearly got
killed a bunch of times it wasn't
physically easy but orwell was
completely attuned to the natural world
and to his son and shared his love of
um of
physical things and of nature with
richard and it's for me
um
gives me a lot of pleasure to know that
orwell was a good father i didn't find
that surprising at all because um first
he had had a very bleak childhood
himself obviously didn't like his father
yeah in fact when he mentions the
analogy of a family
for british society it has every every
figure in it except a daddy which is a
kind of strange admission right a family
with the wrong people in charge but he
mentions maiden aunts and distant
cousins right second though it's very
rare to find a joke in georgia well
when they do occur they're quite funny
um they're very dry
i'm trying to think of one well in
animal farm when when the animals take
over one of the things they do is
go into the smokehouse and take out the
hams and give them a decent burial i
thought that was quite funny yeah um
and his essay on confessions of a book
reviewer is extremely funny yes yeah the
picture of
it's pretty pretty bleak um how do you
come out on the question
um of lionel trilling who says of all
that the great thing about him is he's
not a genius
that he he's i think the extraordinary
thing is how someone so relatively
ordinary
could just by refusing to lie and
working very hard
and not caring whether he lost a job or
or
got his book published
was able to
change the 20th century in other words
qualities of character alone are
sufficient to become a great writer and
to become one of the most important
writers of the century
yes and no um
part of what drew me to orwell back in
my 20s was this sense that
this is available this is not the mad
brilliance of
saul bello this is not faulkner's you
know
arabesques this is not um this isn't
even hemingway's you know highly
self-conscious stylized prose this is it
felt like
um
natural prose i mean that is a conceit
because it doesn't matter it doesn't
make you feel as you do when you're
reading a vocal for example why do i
bother why do i it's impossible i can
admire but i also you know can feel sort
of discouraged by it no with orwell you
feel encouraged by it you want to go do
it yourself that's the feeling that that
he gives me you want to try to write an
essay like that you because the prose is
simple it has that the plain style and
it um
and it seems like the leading
characteristic of it is honesty which um
one ought to be capable of
on the other hand
i think trilling might go a little too
far just in the sense that decency alone
uh that's that i think the word he uses
about very well is not
it's a key orwell word common decency uh
and it's important one but orwell
was an eccentric orwell was
a difficult man he had his incred full
of contradictions he was not so simple
and
good
i think as trilling what have you think
and you alluded earlier to some of his
um antipathies
and
um
his
he was a man of violent dislikes and in
some of his earlier work before
i think he
calmed down
with a certain amount of self-assurance
uh denunciation was his characteristic
mode yeah
so he's not so
he's certainly not a saint and he's just
he's not simply a good man
uh whose qualities of character allowed
him to write
great books um but those
but there's enough truth to that that he
is sort of a model available to everyone
who's writing it's very difficult to
imagine him being afraid
yeah exactly or if he was afraid
whether physically or morally he then
would have noted it and
forced himself to overcome it power
facing yeah exactly well we've only got
about 10 more minutes and what i thought
i would do is take up the idea of
dickens being a writer worth stealing
the world caught him
and talk about attempts to appropriate
orwell yeah the other meaning of
orwellian it's not usually used to
describe a totalitarian state is in some
sense someone who stands for certain set
of
principles that's the use i like it's
the positive use of it
and he's often invoked i mean he was
very he was invoked
against his will somewhat
in the early days of the cold war the
only ones he saw
uh by people who
thought that animal farm in 1984 was
specifically attacks on socialism which
he he didn't want that's right and he
had to actually write a statement saying
i'm a supporter of the labour party uh
and ingsoc is not an indictment of
english socialism it's a warning about
the tendency of
all modern political thought to move
toward
totalitarianism by the way he added um
and he was
very affirmative of the english it was
to show that the english were no better
than anybody that's right that's right
um
well the best way we could take this on
the chin you know i since different
times we both
viewed with favor the removal of
saddam hussein from power yeah
um and i think oil was in in our minds
um at different times and certainly i
know of other people who
tried is is it worth asking do you think
what would our world
but just to
finish the little history you started
he was also claimed by
norman pedoritz uh of commentary
in an essay called um if orwell had
lived basically forward would live
um orwell would have taken the american
side in indochina and i'm i think i
could be certain that that's not so
because of his anti-imperialism because
he was very strongly anti-colonial
especially in that part of asia which he
knew certainly
and he actually mentions when he's in
paris at the end of the war
the revival of a sort of left opposition
type anti-stalinist paper and one of the
great essays that it's printed which is
about the attempt to restore french
colonialism in india china yeah which is
the ancestor of the american
intervention exactly i think he would
have regarded it he would have seen it
as a colonial war
and for that reason he would have been i
think you're absolutely
irrational iraq is different yeah
it's not a colonial war
you know there's in a way there
it's very hard to say and it's a little
dangerous um
to claim but we can speculate because um
because we have to
there's two different arguments to be
made about that one is
that orwell would have seen in saddam's
rule
other than perhaps north korea the
nearest thing to
the world he imagined in 1984 i mean you
say that totalitarianism is a cliche
iraq is a great example saddam was big
brother he had big brother's mustache
his face was on
posters all over baghdad it was on
television all the time you could not
escape
the eye of saddam's many um secret
police iraqis used to say they thought
he knew what they were dreaming exactly
and and that he was inside them and that
even after he was overthrown they felt
they they continued to suffer from the
um the effects of death well we both saw
it in action and it was
the the pornographic element of power
probably never been more horrible i mean
saddam's son was sort of the
human incarnation of the pornography of
totalitarianism uh with rape and and all
kinds of crimes
so that
that one is easy to say that orwell
would have seen that regime as it was
there would have been no defenses
of uh sovereignty or
state sovereignty or
of uh
you know
that this somehow is an anti-islamic war
that this is an anti-arab war he would
have seen that regime as a modern
secular totalitarian regime which is
what it was
on the other hand i would say not so
secular
in saddam hussein
who are on the iraqi flag yeah toward
the end
he used sunni islam for his purposes
that's right
the other side of it is the language
used by the bush administration both
before the war and after the invasion
which in many ways was mendacious
was euphemistic
was
misleading
was bad language it was the kind of bad
language that allows bad political
thought
which is the subject of politics and the
english language maybe the best known of
orwell's essays and i think orwell would
have been
merciless in
stripping away
the rhetoric of george bush dick cheney
don rumsfeld um and karl rove for that
matter and so which orwell would have
had his fi the vote the
anti-totalitarian orwell who would have
seen iraq exactly as it was and known
that
[Applause]
to stand up against saddam
was to stand up for the kurds to stand
up for
masses of iraqis who did not want to
continue this way and he would have
understood
something that one learned upon going to
iraq which many most iraqis were
relieved
to have that regime uh conceded let's
not forget yeah
exactly that's been forgotten
on the other side
the orwell who hated um
political
um
lying and and and and political
propaganda and propaganda exactly so
hard to say
yes
it's it's also hard because he never
really wrote anything much about the
middle east and hadn't been there he was
very skeptical about the um
foundation of the state of israel which
was the big argument going on in the
closing
years of his life he he wasn't very
drawn by the promise of zionism and he's
sympathetic to the arabs of palestine do
you think he believed that democracy and
and the freedoms that you know that
milton uh stood for
could take root in non-western countries
is there evidence that he believed in
the universality of i'm not quite sure
of it i mean there's actually one thing
we really have in a couple of minutes
i'm sorry um
but by way of illustration
he writes to his friend his indian
friend
raj anand only died a couple of years
ago you know um
budding novelist then and essayist who
gets attacked in india for writing in
english and using the conquerors
language and gets mocked in england for
being a sort of white indian
or two nationalists into and also don't
worry about this you're bound to get
both those things but i'll tell you what
i think one day there will be there will
be
a department of english literature
there's a special
subset of it written by indians in
english and of course now you can't go
into a decent bookstore without seeing
five or six brilliant
indian or pakistani writers writing in
english
very often better than english people
too yeah i mean so naipaul would have
been kind of the following in the lineup
from trinidad i believe he's indian but
i mean i was thinking people literally
from the subconscious obviously honey
um arundhati roy um
certainly
there's um
he was he was not a little englander in
his view of culture and his view of um
expression
but one
pernicious idea that's resulted from the
disaster in iraq george i'm not a great
master of ceremonies
this was a real conversation i wouldn't
be saying you'll have to condense this
into less than a minute i'll do that
i'll give you the last word is that
people
who don't look like us can't do this
and that's a
a terrible mistake and i don't think
orwell would have fallen into that trap
of imagining that uh freedom is only for
um for white people which is well he
wrote an essay to that effect which the
title which i think i'm not going to
risk quoting on the earth i know the one
you mean okay yeah um well can i say
it's been real it's been fun good luck
with the books and with your collection
and all the best to you too christopher
thanks for coming in
cia inspector general frederick hits
find the entire weekend schedule at
booktv.org
next author christopher hitchens
delivers a lecture titled crucibles past
and present
he and author salman rushdie chair of
the pen world voices festival have a
conversation following the lecture
cooper union in new york city hosts the
hour and 20 minute event
all right hello everybody um thanks for
coming i'm salman rushdie
uh
thanks
thank you
um
[Applause]
and uh we're here for the
closing event of what i think's been a
pretty good festival the
sixth one and the arthur miller lecture
is always something we care a lot about
and
as as you'll know we have a bit of bad
news and a bit of good news
the sad news is that sherman alexie
couldn't make it and you know we're very
sad i mean there are personal reasons
and we don't want to go into it but
basically there's a good reason why he's
not here
and fortunately for us the good news is
that we were able at very very short
notice to get christopher richards to
come and do the lecture instead
and
and he is over there
and uh christopher is going to talk um
his title is obviously quite relevant to
arthur miller crucibles past and present
um and the way we're going to do it is
that he's going to talk for about 25 30
minutes
then i'm going to come up here and
we're going to talk for about another
25-30 minutes and then
uh you know we'd love to throw it open
to you and have you join in as well and
ask questions of christopher
and like that so without any further ado
christopher hitchens author of god is
not great and a thousand other books
here he is
well
thank you salman and
thank you ladies and gentlemen for
coming and thank you to penn for
honoring me
twice once by giving me the abraham
lincoln
podium which if anything
would encourage one to
abuse i can't think of a more
solid temptation than that and the other
is to be asked to speak in the name of
um
of arthur miller and on the
the tropes with which
visitors in the writing business
will always identify him
um i don't consider myself supremely
qualified to talk certainly not in his
name but i can say that i knew him a
little that my wife and i were married
by the same rabbi the late robert
goldberg who married arthur
miller to marilyn monroe
the same rabbi and fatih also was his
character witness
at the same time
at the house on american activities
committee because
it wasn't enough that arthur was trying
to get married to the woman considered
the most beautiful in the world
he was at the time having to ask
questions about whether or not
he counted as an american at all
and i i can't not tell you just a couple
of things about him and um
and marilyn
um i just can't so i will um
i can't not so i will um
when she was first introduced to the
miller family
robert goldberg by the way to the end of
his life resisted all efforts to
buy from him her conversion certificate
to judaism
a subject to which she was fairly new
when she met the miller family
and mr and mrs miller senior used to
feed her thinking she needed a bit of
you know fattening up
and um
it often would begin with matzo ball
soup in fact it would invariably begin
that way
until the evening when she asked if they
ever ate any other part of the matzo
contrary to the slightly hoidinish
reputation that ms monroe has had ever
since has clung to her ever since she
was actually rather demure and rather
modest chi girl
and the bathroom in the miller house was
a bit too near the living room so out of
shyness i suppose you could say
as the french would put it
she used to um when she retired there
turn on all the taps very loudly
um
just out of discretion you know
you want to not depress the in-laws and
um
after she'd gone and
arthur turned to his mother and said
well what did you think his mother's
opinion was very important to him
because mrs milicenia said well she's a
very nice girl but she sure pisses like
a racehorse
well okay i
i had to do that but it's not strictly
to the purpose um
somebody told me this evening that it
was possible that
attendance was down
at today's events because of
an attempted atrocity in um times square
last night and if that was true
i would both be depressed and
i would take it as an opportunity to
underline what i wanted to talk about
in the case of mr miller and in the
topic i picked which was
crucible's present and past
um which is to say the contagion of fear
um as the united states found out in the
1950s it's it's it's incredibly easy
it's depressingly easy shall one say
to get people who are the children of a
revolution who are born
into a country that is governed by
constitution
with all the all the rights and
privileges of a free society it's very
very easy to get people to give that up
or to devalue it or to panic and abandon
the values of that constitution in
particular
of its amendments it's wonderful
amendments that constitute
the bill of rights and the reason why
arthur miller was so important to us
and remains important i think to people
who don't remember any of it
is that he was one of the very few
americans who would say no i'm i'm not
going to go along with this and made out
of it a famous
play recalling an earlier time before
the founding of the republic before the
proclamation and promulgation of the
constitution
when there was an era of witch-hunting
which is another way of saying
clerical or religious
panic
persecution
uh tyranny
and hysteria and to see under what
conditions we who look down on
the poor old primitive uneducated
settlers of the bay colony
and what conditions we're entitled to do
that
what gives us the right to condescend to
people if we aren't
sure in our own minds
that we would be able in the same
conditions to resist
i think it's a fair bet that anyone who
takes the trouble to buy a ticket to a
pen event
has played this game in their head at
some point in their life
how would i shape up
what would i do
when the neighbors were being shipped
onto the trains or maybe when because
that so often comes when it's too late
you think maybe i should have done
something before
they started putting them on the trains
when should i have started would it have
been with the censorship
would it have been with the racism would
it have been with the off the record
imprisonments and executions at what
point i feel sure i would have taken a
stand at some point i i would have been
brave we all
we all have had to do this and we've all
had to look at societies
contemporary to ours and in the past and
asked well
okay
what
when the fugitive slave act is still on
the books and has been extended to the
states of the north as well what about
it where the slave catchers cross over
into pennsylvania and come as far as new
york uh and there's a bounty out and
there's a lot of pressure
to build of course i'm going to shelter
this wanted guy in my house aren't i
everyone thinks that they would
and everyone has a it's a pleasurable
imagination
until you begin to doubt yourself until
you begin to think i wonder if i would
be that good there's a wonderful poem by
edna vincent malay it's called
conscientious objector i can't quote it
all but it begins it's just come back to
me but it begins um
i shall die
but that is all that i shall do for
death
uh i owe him nothing he's mounting up in
the yard today his horse his hooves are
clattering he has business in cuba but i
will not give him a leg up
i will not tell him where the black boy
lies in the swamp i shall die but that
is all that i shall do for death this is
a hard test for people to pass
and by the time i got to know arthur
miller um he was of course quite old but
he'd he'd continued to witness
throughout his life for many decades
i remember when i was at the nation
magazine publishing an extraordinary
article helping to publish
a very humorous account he gave of going
to a dinner
at the american embassy in turkey
at the head of a pen delegation which
included himself and harold pinter
and how harold pinter had given the
american ambassador to turkey an
absolutely ruinous time
throughout the dinner
all night because of turkey's treatment
of the of this kurdish
minority and i had my differences with
harold pinter and in fact i'd had my
differences with that same american
ambassador and i could almost feel sorry
for ambassador stratsupe and having to
face
miller and pinter for an evening knowing
that american policy was complicit
in a near genocidal policy in
southeastern
anatolia and you know you could have let
that go you could have said we're here
on a delegation of writers it's nice of
the ambassador to have a dinner we can
sit this one out no you can't no this is
your chance
you'll always be sorry later if you kept
quiet there's never a good occasion for
keeping your mouth shut
so
so far nothing but praise for arthur
from me
but there came a time when a good friend
of mine and a
great friend of the cause of writing
and of free expression and of writers
and people who willing to sacrifice free
expression salman rushdie
was hit as you
all remember by the clerical dictator
of the theocratic dictator of foreign
state with a
fatwa that's the way the word entered
our language
that condemned him salman to both a life
sentence and a death sentence
it condemned him to death and it
enjoined all muslims in the world to
bring it about which meant that someone
had to alter his
social life and other arrangements quite
radically for for a bit
and well i remember thinking on that day
which was the 14th of february 1989 well
for me for my lot for us
this is the case this is the test we
often wondered what would it be in our
generation
most free speech cases you'll find if
you look into them
from the from the trial of socrates
onwards have been to do with blasphemy
socrates galileo spinoza you can fill in
blanks field so almost always that
someone is accused to have gone too far
this time
and to have outraged the sensibilities
of the community as well as the laws and
codes of the state and the city
and profaned the gods
which you really can't have because then
where would we be
how would we know how to behave if it
wasn't for a celestial dictatorship we
wouldn't know right from wrong without
that so it's a really subversive thing
to be doing i thought well that's pretty
easy
um but we should do better perhaps than
just get the usual suspects to sign the
usual free speech petition
maybe we should all say since the fatwa
applies
explicitly applies to all those
responsible publication of the book
a missing codicil is often not mentioned
we should all sign a petition saying we
consider ourselves co-responsible on the
model of spartacus
or the the danish
volunteers in the nazi occupation who
said if the jews are made where a yellow
star will wear one too and they can't
get us all so
i thought it was a good idea um just to
up the ante a bit
and then susan sontag who to whom i also
would like to dedicate any value to you
that these remarks may possess
and to her memory who was that years
president of penn fortunately
um
it came
the horrible news that a lot of people
were strangely reluctant to sign
that the fear factor
the feeling that the ayatollah
khamenei's arm could reach that far
that death squads were on the prowl that
anyone who got too closely identified
with this might themselves become the
object over here was actually keeping
away some people from the meeting we
plan to have to read from someone's book
and keeping their names off the list
they said no i don't want to sign and i
tell this story in my upcoming memoir i
don't i don't want to say anything at
all to undermine the memory of arthur
but there was a crisis with him and he
he said you know what you probably don't
need me
um after all i'm jewish it would only
attract attention it would change the
subject
it's amazing how persuasive fear can be
you can always think of a good reason
i'll behave better next time
um
maybe this isn't such a crux after all
and i remember thinking this really is
for me a moral
and intellectual
uh
and personal uh crisis because if the
author of the crucible
has decided that he this is an
appointment he's reluctant to keep
uh then we're all in very grave trouble
but of course the story has a happy
ending and arthur came through
very well as did a number of other
people who'd hesitated but i'll never
forget that week and how and what i
learned about how fragile
how tenuous
uh the commitment of the society to its
basic values
often is and how easy it is to panic
people into portraying them
and i'll stay with this trope if you
don't mind because i think it's back
and i think the rot is spreading
and i think it began this present phase
about exactly five years ago
when a small newspaper in the jutland
area of denmark called eulands poston
published some you'll know about this
some cartoons
better to say caricatures actually
of the figure of the prophet muhammad
who it's wrongly thought cannot ever be
represented in art there are several
islamic representations of him
particularly in persian culture oddly
enough
um it's not a it's not a prohibition
that is of any great value or of any
great force though it's it's believed to
be by people who like to find cultural
reasons as they often do
for political cowardice and moral
cowardice at any rate you know the
sequel there was an organized attempt to
destroy the danish economy by boycott
coordinated by some very extreme millers
in denmark with some partners of theirs
in other countries
there was an open season on uh danish
people
many of whom were attacked in other
countries
by the end of it we think at least 300
people were killed and not all of them
danish in different countries there are
riots between muslims and christians in
nigeria
in countries which when demonstrations
are never normally allowed at all and
where the police control everything such
as syria large crowds were allowed to
burn down the danish embassy
um without any apparent police
intervention
and the thing had the every appearance
of a horrible orchestration
i thought well here again what could be
a clearer case here is a small
scandinavian democracy
which had a fairly heroic record of
resistance to nazism
its citizens are peaceful
um its government is not allowed by law
to censor the press the demand was that
the government closed that paper and
and apologize for its publication the
danish prime minister said i can't do
that i have no right in law to affect
the publication of cartoons or articles
in denmark
um
but at least the friends of denmark will
show their faces now and we'll have a
proper discussion about this
full frontal challenge to the values of
the first amendment
can't wait to see for example what the
state department will say
the bush state department is here's a
chance for it to really stick out his
chest and
testify for real values well the bush
state department made a statement saying
we're very sorry about any offence
caused by the danish cartoons now we
don't keep a state department going to
comment on the internal affairs of
danish journalism
the state department could reasonably
have said that wasn't its job its job is
to say we stand by our democratic allies
and we particularly feel uh appalled at
a violation of its diplomatic immunity
and the sovereign protection of its
diplomat couldn't even go that far the
first thing was to apologize
well that's bad but i i'm not a diplomat
i live in washington but i'm not a
politician i'm a journalist that will
the
my profession my great profession will
stick up
on this point we'll have a proper
discussion and the first thing is to
show the cartoons because people must
see what the fuss is about
i mean if we don't live now in the age
of the image where do we live
everything is image driven newspapers
magazines and of course the television
everything is to do with the the
pictures themsema
not one
outlet in the united states would
publish
or show
those cartoons not one network not one
national newspaper not one news magazine
i couldn't even get the monster in my
column in slate which is online though
you could in the end go by link to find
them but the magazine itself wouldn't
take responsibility to do it
a small magazine i work for skeptical um
it's called the skeptical inquirer
um
secular magazine um it's actually
actually it's not called skeptical it
was called free inquiry pardon me that
there are two my wife free inquiry pub
did publish them
i don't know our circulation is even in
five figures but the bookstore chains
immediately pulled all copies of our
magazine
from the shelves and this was in
response to no threat
it was in response to no pressure it was
in response to no danger at all it's
when i was a kid we would say was crying
before
you were hurt but i thought then i think
now it was a terrible capitulation there
wasn't anyone in the united states who
would say look first order of business
let's see what the fuss is about what do
these pictures really look like
no one would take that responsibility
and nobody said it was for any other
reason than fear i know these people i
know these editors i work for some of
them why didn't you do it
what were you afraid of we were afraid
of reprisal
well of what value is your first
amendment what of what value is the
enormous money that you make out of free
expression
the the giant revenues that are be to be
made in a country that enjoys the right
of free publication if it won't be
defended at the very first challenge
you think it can't get worse yes it can
uh yale university press
which is run by someone who used to be a
publisher of mine but won't ever be
again called john donachich decides to
commission a book by a danish scholar on
the danish cartoons learned its subject
um sorry a learned treatment of the
subject including the vexed question of
is there permissible representation of
the prophet muhammad
in islamic art nicely produced book
comes out yale university press the
university of nathan hale the man who
said give me liberty or give me death
and then at the last minute they decide
to cut out all the illustrations in the
book all of them not just the cartoons
no illustration of any kind yale
university press without a shot being
fired
says no we're not going to do it we
don't have the guts for it they even
issued a statement saying that they felt
if they did do so
they would be instigating violence now
another thing that depressed me at that
point separate separate question is it's
a pity that at the university press of a
great university the proofreaders don't
know the meaning of the word instigate
to instigate something is to try and
make it happen is to me
it's it's equivalent to saying
incitement it's saying you are you're
trying to stir something up it is your
aim that the be violence if you
instigate it
um in the in in the passive use of the
word they made themselves responsible
for any action taken of a criminal
nature criminally violent nature by the
publication of the book which was which
has two bad effects one
it runs away and it deprives the readers
as well as the author of the book
of the right to discuss the matter
freely and second in advance it excuses
the criminal activity because after all
it can't be their fault it's ours for
showing the pictures
it's ours for printing the book
it's ours for having salman as an author
in our midst it's our fault and so
there's an indemnity given in advance
to the men of violence
uh that's therefore a double insult if
you like
to the principles of civilization and it
goes on
um
you'll probably remember on new year's
eve we were preoccupied at that point by
the so-called christmas bomber who
nearly brought down
a full civilian aircraft from amsterdam
over the city of detroit but a few
nights later on new year's eve
one of the authors of one of those
cartoons a man called westergard a 79
year old man
who is having a sleepover with his
granddaughter in copenhagen one of the
quietest calmest sweetest towns you can
ever hope to see
has his door broken in with an axe
by a wanted somali gangster
who's come to kill him and his
granddaughter with an axe on new year's
eve and if he hadn't managed to lock
himself in the bathroom and press
a panic button they'd both be dead and
mr westergard you'll be interested to
hear has since been let go by his
magazine as someone who it's too much
trouble
to keep on the staff it's it's just uh
just happened a couple of weeks ago he's
it's um
it's all very well to stick up for free
speech but you know there are limits
and you can't have someone embarrassing
you by having his granddaughter and
himself attacked on new year's eve you
know it gets around you look that
you think it couldn't happen here well
i've already told you it could
and has with the cartoon case and then
i hope you would have escaped your
attention that last week
the the channel on american television
that above all prides itself on saying
that the answer to the question is
nothing sacred is always no
where there's no there is no cow that
cannot be smacked around and and abused
comedy central decided that uh
discretion was by far the better part of
value of valor
and
of all things to get to cave in on and
of all the examples we could set to
the smart and wised up american youth
who like to watch it
south park is told you can't make a
teddy bear joke
involving the prophet muhammed
and so irreverence central
no holds barred central gives in without
a fight or [ __ ] let's say not without a
fight let's give them some credit there
is one
nut case who has one website in new york
who posted a picture on his website of
what happened to theo van gogh
the dutch filmmaker who made a film
about the oppression of muslim women in
the city of amsterdam
and who was ritually murdered in the
street having been shot off his bicycle
he was gutted
like a sheep
in the roadway
and a
knife plunged into his heart which held
attached to it a letter an open letter
to another good friend of mine miss ayan
hershey ali whose wonderful new book
nomad is about to be
published telling her as an elected
member of the dutch parliament and a
refugee from somalia and from gentile
mutilation and from forced marriage and
from sectarian warfare and religious
theocratic oppression that she was next
and she now lives in this country and i
can't even tell you where anymore
because she too like so many of my
friends now
in europe and the united states has to
go around with a permanent
bodyguard
whereas the people who put theo van
gogh's picture
on their website and say to the makers
of comedy central this is going to
happen
to you
sign
revolutionmuslim.com don't appear to
feel any kind of fear at all
they seem to feel as perhaps they are
that the first amendment protects them
too well if it does
and if this great architecture of free
speech if this this constitutional roof
under which we've all been thriving so
proudly for so long is to mean anything
then we're going to have to say
revolution.com cannot close down an
american cable channel at whim
by making a little bit of a threat
so the question comes right back to
where i suppose i initiated it
which is
it's no longer a hypothetical one you're
not being asked what would you do
when the climate of fear began to spread
and when even people you thought to be
reliable and brave will remember urgent
appointments elsewhere
and say well perhaps this particular
meeting i could skip
or maybe that petition
isn't so vitally important after all
i've signed so many petitions in my time
i can miss one and
anyway captain alfred dreyfus always
looked a bit of a cd character uh to me
um rather suspicious looking type you
know maybe we should pick our fights
with more care you can feel the air the
atmosphere thickening with excuses and
with euphemisms no question is what are
you going to do about this
what are you going to do about it now if
if what i was just told is true the
ranks of this very hall this evening
were thinned not by the prospect of
having myself instead of sherman alexie
forbidding enough as it is
but by a fizzle by a fizzled nothing of
a bomb in um
in times square look look you are the
children of a revolution
the united states did have to go through
a great deal to erect this architecture
of constitutional freedom and protection
people in living memory died to register
to vote
to be able to
hold a public meeting
to be able to assert their most basic
and elementary rights and we celebrate
them every year and we all wish we could
have been there and we weren't but we
can be because
uh there'll always be a time a
rendezvous
with this question and everyone's going
to measure themselves as arthur miller
did by how they
shape
up to it so i can now if i haven't made
my point by now i'm not going to have
made it am i
and i think i've probably about
trespassed on the point where simon and
i we're going to talk
and then we'll you can be our prisoners
for a bit longer and then we'll be your
hostage
and so this would be the moment perhaps
to
invite back on the stage someone who has
for this
um
thanks christopher that
i wanted to just i'm just going to want
to in some random way respond to a few
of the things you said and then we can
um
let's talk about the cartoons a bit more
because it seems to me
that there's two
separate issues about things like the
danish cartoons which get
conflated
one is the question about
should the cartoons have been published
in the first place
now seems to me
any newspaper editor anybody on a
picture desk of a newspaper or a
magazine
every day is presented with material
where they have to make the decision
is this worth putting in the magazine or
not
and i think we can also agree that maybe
no two picture editors would make the
same decisions
some of them would print all those
things some of them would print one or
two some of them written one of them
so on the one hand you've got
the argument about quality
and so should the things be in the paper
yeah i mean myself i think
that most of them were rather tedious
and the ones that weren't were actually
the most offensive ones
i mean the best cartoon
was the one which shows
suicide bombers arriving at the pearly
gates
to be greeted by the prophet muhammad
saying would you please stop doing it
because we're running out of virgins
yes now that that has the
that has the great merit of being funny
has a bit of bite to it yeah yeah and
actually the one with the turban the
bomb in the turbine was similarly
you know a perfectly legitimate strong
satirical point and well drawn and
well-drawn so those two the ones that
people got most exercised about
would actually be the ones that i would
if i was a picture editor that i would
have published and many of the others
were just beyond bland
so that's one issue would you do it
would you not do it but it seems to me
that there's
the second issue is what which is what
you were talking about i think is what
happens when the subject of violence
arises
and at that point it seems to be the
subject changes the subject is no longer
about whether you should publish or not
publish these things
but about how do you respond to violence
yes do you respond to it with cowardice
or courage
and at that point it seems to me that
every newspaper in the world should
publish the danish cartoons
not because they like them and not
actually because they particularly want
to insult islam
but just to make the point that you
don't give in
to threats yes
and so i think sometimes you know when
people start talking about the cartoons
as objects they
you know were they good or bad were they
offensive or inoffensive it's
that's one half of the point but the
second half of the point is the question
of the response to violence you know and
i think that's
that's one of the things that has got
very blurred recently well shall i
should i copy that um well first you
know what happens to mohamed atta when
he blows himself up and arrives at the
pearly gates
you don't know but he was told okay
welcome um
let's see who don't you know uh here's
mr thomas jefferson
here's mr james madison who takes his
hand
have you met mr george mason shakes his
hand
mr patrick henry says okay patrick what
is this
he said well he did ask for 72
virginians
there's actually there's even a better
thing
i was afraid this might happen
see this is i'm now not kidding
serious islamic scholarship has recently
suggested
that the 72 virgins was a mistranslation
of the original and then what was
actually
supposed to greet
people on their arrival as martyrs were
72 raisins
raisins or white grapes you know it's
there's a very good there's a serious
aramaic mistranslation of the quran that
is
done a lot of damage i think one of the
few good reasons for believing in the
afterlife yes is wanting to see the
faces
of
you know mohammed company arriving in
heaven to be handed a bowl of raisins
it also adds to the strong case for
saying that
holy books are in fact man made and not
dictated by god which is
i think a good part of this discussion
look remember the origin of the danish
question was this it was proposed in
denmark which was doing its level best
as many societies have
to make muslims feel welcome in danish
society it was thought the world school
children
should learn about islam we should have
a book for kids cartoon book you know
all you need to know islam for beginners
kind of thing but they couldn't get any
cartoonists children's cartoonists to do
it because they were afraid of making a
mistake yes of upsetting someone so it
was to satirize this reticence and this
fear
that fleming rose my friend the editor
of julian's post and said all right
let's have a cartoonist competition
and we'll see if we can represent the
prophet
so it begins with this reticence the
second thing is you're right of course
that people should do it out of
solidarity and you'll write of course
that it's a judgment call in point of
taste
in the first instance but once it's
become a matter of violence and
controversy there's a second stage you
have to report it yes you did
which everybody did on the front page
and so they reported it without the
content yeah let's do it without the
picture i can't really think of a
parallel of what
i mean they would say well
picasso's gone too far with guernica
um you know he's taken a obviously
propagandistic attitude towards the
spanish civil war
um there's a huge rouba this painting
um
you'd be very interested to know more
about it but unfortunately we can't show
you what it looks like because that
would be
inviting reprisal from franco or
something i can't think of a i can't
think of a
bit
even worse now was everything is image
everything is imaginary and one of the
most
i think mealy-mouthed
pieces of language that is developed to
justify this kind of behavior
is a kind of reinvention of the meaning
of the word respect
it
it seemed to me when i was growing up
that respect meant that you took people
seriously
it didn't mean that you never disagreed
with them
um you know to respect someone is to say
okay we'll take on what you have to say
and if i don't agree with it i will
offer
argument
the idea that it would be disrespectful
to someone to in any way disagree from
their system of belief
is a new idea the new meaning of the
term respect and it seems to me to have
nothing to do with respect
and what it actually means is i'm too
afraid to do it
so what you have is cowardice
masquerading as this as respect and
that's become more and more and more
common very clear in the case of the of
the of the cartoons
because i think the point you made which
needs to be said a great deal is that
is that blasphemy the the refusal to
accept
the church as the limiting point on
thought
is something which throughout human
history has been the thing that has
moved the human race forward
i mean you mentioned galileo
um
and uh socrates and one should also
remind people that the trial of jesus
christ was a vastly trial sure works
um
so and and from those three you could
say you have
you know western
religious belief
western scientific understanding
and western philosophy
they all emerge from blasphemy cases
yeah he was asking for trouble by saying
he was the son of god yes yes
he knew what he was doing as they used
to say meaningfully about you i remember
i remember that i always was abused or
not amused it wasn't funny at the time
um when people said that about me that i
knew what i was doing it would be really
strange i thought to spend five years
writing a novel and not know what you
were doing
what would that be that act but then
another thought though which i meant to
intrude earlier you were raised a muslim
yeah well you can be accused of apostasy
i know except my parents were about as
muslim as a chewed off fingernail
you know i've always thought that the
great gift my parents gave me was to not
be religious
they sort of excused me religion no
that's true but in the eyes of the uh
yes
you you belong like just as that's why
people say lapsed catholic you can't
leave the church unless you're
excommunicated no no if i'd been called
harvey weinstein there would have been
no [ __ ] well there wouldn't have been
maybe there should have been
that's another question yes actually
that's a very tempting no never mind
that's not good um
but with with you with you and ayan
hoshi ali
and many others
there's the question of apostasy which
muslims can if they like claim as their
internal affair what's interesting now
with denmark is a new line and comedy
central and a couple of other events in
london is the lines being crossed now
you don't have to be a muslim to be
brought within the range of uh reprisal
i remember quite soon after the attack
on the standing versus being sent by a
fan
a t-shirt
on which was the legend blasphemy is a
victimless crime
which you have to think about it
and then you realize that it's
completely in line with with your
uh with god is not great because of
course it's god who is the victim who
doesn't exist um
yes someone rather woundingly said of my
title that it was
annoyingly one word too long
just circumcise one word and you've got
the truth um i wanted to
ask you a couple of things now i mean i
think yes this is we should come back to
this a bit but it seems to me one of the
things that
to people of our generation
it's very strange i think
is the recrudescence of religion as a
political force
um because when we were kids in the 60s
there were many things that were
up there that we needed to fight against
it i don't think it ever occurred to us
that the power of religion whatever
religion
would once again be the thing we had to
battle and we actually thought that that
battle was won
and it turns out that we were wrong and
i wanted to ask you why you think that
is what is it
you know one of the things that andre
melrose supposed to have said and
apparently did not say is that the 21st
century will be the century of religion
apparently he didn't say that
but it seems so far on the basis of 10
years
to be the case and i wonder why you
think it is that this battle that we all
thought was over
has returned to become the central
battle of our time well lenin apparently
really did say that he thought the last
battle would be between communism and
islam
partly because islam was a competitor in
the third world against imperialism
which in some ways it can still
represent itself as being so i think
that a approximate cause not an exact
one but a proximal cause would be the
contributing cause probably is the
collapse of communism
um not least in the soviet union itself
or rather informal soviet territory
itself were now for example
the russian orthodox church the old
patron of serfdom and czarism and
anti-semitism is now fully back in a
very dangerous nationalist form it's the
clerical bodyguard to putin's regime it
has special privileges within the state
uh the army and elsewhere and over all
other faiths in russia that's a by the
way i think it'll be a very dangerous
thing as russian chauvinism and
revolutionism
gets more increased we have a tremendous
revival of the forces of reaction in the
roman catholic church exemplified by
this very squalid bavarian bureaucrat
who's the current
pope who whose first act uh as pope was
to readmit to the church those who'd
been excommunicated for denying the
holocaust and so on to to rebuild the
the hard right-wing element of
catholicism that basically thought
vatican ii was a mistake so
re-fundamentalizing what they still
think of as the one true church then you
have the crazy settlers in in occupied
uh territories in palestine who think
that they can bring on the messiah by
stealing
arab land and then you have the
christians who say wouldn't that be a
great idea
uh we support the jews as the rope
supports the hanging man they bring on
the apocalypse we get jesus back
a lot of whom are in this country and
trying still
to maintain
this goes on too i wouldn't have
believed it that american children
should be taught garbage with equal time
yeah um now girls and boys after the
chemistry practice we'll have alchemy
break
i remember that's enough to make a cat
laugh isn't it but they they never stop
in in texas and also big book school
book producing areas that this nonsense
is is unstoppable i remember at the time
that
that the state of kansas
uh decided that um intelligent design
had to be taught
at the same level as as that straight
vaguely unproved theory called darwinism
um it actually i wrote a piece of which
it's which i suggested that this
decision
by the state of kansas showed that
darwin was wrong
because it showed that natural selection
did not always choose the fittest to
survive
sometimes the unfitted survived and that
it was actually possible for the human
race to regress as well as progress so
there was a wonderful in alabama i
remember there was a public servant who
said that we couldn't be sure about the
truth of the theory about the big bang
because nobody was there at the time yes
yes and they but the equal time demand i
i think is is a an excellent one because
there are now a very large number of
churches
who take this view who are in support um
sorry in receipt of
grants from the so-called faith-based
initiative which i'm sorry to say
president obama hasn't canceled or
otherwise in receipt of a tax break and
so it seems to me very clear we should
take them up on equal times they will
teach
your stuff in the schools at least once
a week in the not in the science class
but in the social studies bit
and you have to sell
and teach uh darwin material uh fifty
percent of the time in your church well
you know just to press that'll be the
law and see how they like a little of
that seems to me even if you just look
at the united states if you look at
the politics of the post-war period if
you look at the the eisenhower election
even even the kennedy election so that
it wasn't so necessary
for religion to be a subject in the
election
nowadays it seems to me you can't be
elected dog catcher in america unless
you talk about your deep belief in
such-and-such church
why do you think it is that there's so
much greater power
of religious discourse in this country
i actually think that that's only true
if you and everyone else keeps saying so
i mean the
the number of people who check none of
the above
for religion
in the country has doubled in the last
year
or two last year the last five years
to something like 16 17 i think it's
probably higher
um the number of people who check the
box and say i am a baptist or i am a
catholic
i know because i go and debate in their
churches full of crisis and uncertainty
that it doesn't reflect
a monolithic religiosity at all
um barack obama got elected while having
to disown the only church he'd ever been
near he'd taken so little care to pick
one
uh that it nearly got him unelected the
church he went to since hasn't been to a
church at all and ended his inauguration
speech which i attended with a very good
quotation from thomas payne
so i'm not sure at all i think if a
person of reasonable integrity
and honesty and and
presentability let's say was able to
face the election and say i personally
don't attend a church and don't have a
belief i think there's every reason to
think they could win
well i hope you're right the political
right in this country clearly
thinks that the religious card is well
worth playing yes but the christian
right have had a very thin time lately
um and the catholic right as well
um i mean
who
who really now thinks that the catholic
church has any moral right to tell a
politician that they'll be denied the
sacraments if they don't conform i mean
i'd like to see them try it again i
really do
would like to see that
well that would once have been a very
dreadful threat
to move it outside this country one of
the let me just ask you
given
the
you know the huntington thesis all these
ideas about clash of civilizations
um
what do you think do you think these are
wars of religion or are they
wars as many wars of religion have done
wars which use religion as a cloak for
other discontents well i'm sure it's
both but a lot of the latter i mean
remember that the crusades which the
muslim world goes on about a lot and
quite understandably
began with a huge pogrom against
european jewry
then when they more or less finished
that nearly finished it they moved
across the bosphorus or not across but
to the bosphorus and destroyed byzantine
orthodox eastern orthodox christianity
which they thought of was a as a heresy
and an anathema so before they even got
to jerusalem and started butchering the
muslims they'd they settled accounts
with the jews and with
the only other papacy the only other
christian rival
excuse me in the picture
so i think sir stephen runserman is
probably quite right to say that that at
that point the crusades were the most
retarding experience that human
civilization had ever undergone and
we're still we're still suffering from
the consequences
it was an intra-christian war that led
to the crusade likewise as you can see
in iraq and elsewhere
there's at least one civil war within
islam
between the sunni and the shia
against our mighty muslims for example
who are considered heretical especially
in pakistan
against the sufism
it's becoming a warlord religion almost
islam because there are dueling fatwas
issued by separate authorities unluckily
for them in some ways and for us they
don't have a pope who can put a unified
line everyone has to follow the various
centers of power
and uh often they want to settle these
disputes on non-muslim soil
yeah i mean after all no sunni
government ever supported the fatwa
against you i think that's true yeah
that's true well i mean it was no no
government at all actually other than
other than that of
iran
and that was partly for political
reasons because
actually when the protests against the
satanic verses began they were largely
financed by saudi arabia
and the iranian father actually hijacked
yes a saudi
campaign thus enormously pissing off
saudi arabia
and it's one of the reasons no one
outbids the ayatollah yeah
no well i mean i just would like to
point out in regard to me and the
ayatollah that you know one of us is
dead
yes
do not mess with novelis yes
literally our script
the written word will remain
um
and it's true that if you look at the
the muslim world
the political
apart from the sunni shia split
the political dissensions
are so profound that it's very difficult
to speak over jihad
yes you know
i mean
the afghans hate the iranians who hate
the saudis who hate the syrians
and so on so that it's it's clearly not
unified but on the other hand
there clearly has grown up something
which is of appeal to it may be a small
group but as but a dangerous group
uh where the idea of the the pan global
jihad has become very attractive yes and
what do you think that's about i mean
it's very noticeable for example of the
i shouldn't prejudge their case but i i
don't like the look of it the four
pakistani boys who left the suburb of my
hometown the other day and turned up in
the wrong camp in pakistan
are only the latest in a large number of
young men from
england from france
elsewhere who've
volunteered to go die in remote parts of
the muslim world now it's interesting
isn't it it always has to be they want
to go work with al qaeda or the taliban
why wouldn't a young muslim in in london
before 2001 who wanted to go and fight
with the northern alliance
in afghanistan
which as a as muslim and organization as
could be had fought against the soviet
union was opposed to the taliban
um had probably had more support than it
did no one goes to volunteer for that
um no one went to volunteer for the
kurdish people who were fighting against
saddam hussein just as muslim
um all the all the muslim activists took
the side of saddam hussein when it came
to the crunch
in the war
who was who himself enjoyed the support
of al qaeda
if not in a military operational sense
he had the sympathy of their
proclamations in some horrible way
it's thought that you're an uncle tom if
you're any other kind of muslim yes
the authentic stuff
has to be the most horrible
the most extreme
and the most completely consecrated
violence that that consecration being
sealed by
self-destruction suicide
so that it really is a battle for what
you could call the soul of
islam i sometimes think i wonder what
you think about this
that
in the way that
soviet communism soviet-style communism
kind of burned through a large part of
the world and then burned out
there's an argument which says that in
those countries where radical islam has
become most powerful
it is also most disliked
that's to say you know that the people
of afghanistan a very large majority of
them do not like the taliban a very
large majority of the population of iran
does not like the rule of the ayatollahs
the people of algeria who flirted with
the feasts of the gia very rapidly moved
away from them
so it's iraq
iraq has totally isolated the al-qaeda
so so here's an argument which is that
here is a here's a rhetoric
which appears to be very attractive
kind of sexy glamorous
particularly to young men
particularly young men without much hope
of a future
and it can burn into a society with
great speed
but then
very rapidly people come to decide to
discover that they hate it
yeah so what do you think of that idea
that this may be a short-lived
phenomenon by the way i think you're
obviously right i mean there's every
sign of a turn of that kind among the
people of somalia now
as well against the so-called shabab
many of whom are foreign volunteers
quite a lot of them americans
and yes no one who's ever tried it once
wants to try it again
that's absolutely true
but it's a lot to go through um
and it can very i mean this afghanistan
will take a long long time to recover
yes just from a fairly brief period of
time rule it's not very difficult to
diagnose either not sure if you forbid
yourself the talents of 50 of the
population to start with just before you
do anything else then you ban music then
you ban all books that aren't the quran
um
the the the floor is going to keep on
dropping well it takes a long time to
bring it back up to where it was so
if you mean might we just let them burn
themselves out i know i don't think you
were saying anything no i'm not callous
as that but no if you think well could
we sit it out i mean i i sometimes think
perhaps not because
the damage done is so great and the
problem with it as with all theocracies
is it doesn't have a self-critical
capacity if they look around they notice
okay all the children's teeth are
falling out
um nothing works here except the secret
police in the fields nothing really
grows except footprints
um
what have we been doing wrong what
they'll say is we haven't been doing
anything wrong we just maybe haven't
been praying hard enough
and in the meantime the crusader zionist
conspiracy has been at work to subvert
our country
so of the huge number of failed and
unemployed and unemployable young men
they've got they try to export them
they export the violence back to the
worst
so that we have every interest in
not just stopping the jihadist element
but it's stopping the terrible
underdevelopment
that islamism brings i mean just to say
this way
very often you read people quite smart
people saying well these people are the
product of poverty and unemployment so
you've heard it
no they're not they're the cause of
poverty and unemployment
no society they've ever had any control
over has not been immediately more poor
and with much less employment the
national income of indonesia was reduced
by a whole point by the attacks of
al-qaeda on bali for example they drove
many people into poverty united that's
their plan
don't fool yourself that it's a protest
against
uh
bad conditions it's a wish for them
at the height of the soviet union
a lot of
uh
non-soviet
socialist
voices
uh in europe and america around the
world
made a distinction
between what they saw as the distortions
of the soviet system
and what they called actually existing
with what they call actually existing
communism
um which was clearly cruel and despotic
and you know so on and so on and if you
like true socialism yes the true church
of karl marx which was
virtuous it see it it seems to me now
that there's often a similar argument
being made
people who wish to distinct distinguish
themselves from you know actually
existing islam
which is cruel and despotic in many of
its national manifestations
and the separate idea of the true faith
which is you know religion of peace and
love
and and i wondered what you thought
about that
well i was one of those on the left who
spent a lot of time with the with the
left opposition in
eastern europe people who did take a
form of that critique who
who
who were who were not in favor of nato
or capitalism people like
i suppose in poland adam miknick would
have been one not harmful but some of
the czech opposition were democratic
socialists one kind or another yeah and
in yugoslavia and in bosnia particularly
so and i still have some sympathy for
that that critique the thing about that
is it's a bit more testable objectively
i mean if you come to the conclusion
actually there is something wrong with
the pricing policy the socialist economy
it has of all things real difficulty
working out what the value of things
ought to be
and this probably isn't um a result of
it being hijacked it may be a false
[Music]
abenicio
there's
you don't think you're going to go to
hell for saying that
say or you don't know
bring upon yourself quite the same
condemnation the thing about
theocracy is that it tends to say
that um if anything goes wrong if the
system breaks down it is only because we
haven't tried it hard enough
thus for example i i go on about this
all the time we should be thinking about
our iranian brothers and sisters every
day
not just the struggle they're having to
bring about a democracy and the fact
that the revolutionary guards who've
taken over their country are also the
people who control the nuclear weapons
but that on top of that iran is booked
to have a terrible seismic catastrophe
it's coming like a heart attack to
tehran
and no one's doing anything to
earthquake earthquake proof the country
at all nothing nothing like what the
chileans have done even it's more like
haiti
and friday prayers i knew this would
happen friday prayers couple i've been
writing about it for weeks friday
prayers the week before last
the guy did discuss the possibilities
of the
earthquake coming being quite bad news
which by the way will be if there are
underground nuclear facilities that no
one knows about
and he said well of course there'll be
an earthquake because women insist on
uncovering their faces
yes the
this was the official sermon on friday
the sexuality of women is the cause of
the earthquakes now both of us both of
us have suffered from the size
both of us have suffered from the
seismic effects of the female sex
speak for yourself and we know it can't
be
we know it can't be underestimated it's
a it can move mountains all right
this is ridiculous
but they know they have to have an
expedition and um
well
i do i don't think even stalinoid
marxism ever quite no no crapped out
it's a new degree that's a new look
that's right look before i want to open
it up to the audience but just before we
do i want to ask you one question on a
different subject
which is something like the subject that
that sherman alexie might have been
addressing which is to do with the
future
of of journalism
uh in this in the new age we find
ourselves and clearly you've spent most
of your life
as a working journalist and we live in a
moment when
the
environment is being transformed yeah i
i had dinner about a year ago
in washington i seated next to the
publisher of the washington post
catherine weymouth
and i
asked her because there were many
stories about the washington post being
in in difficulties
and and i asked her
how bad was it and she said you know
it's very bad
and she said to me that she had recently
been in silicon valley and had gone to
visit various of the leading figures
yahoo google et cetera
and and she had said to them uh she said
she asked them if you were me what would
you do
and they had all of us responded shut
down the newspaper and concentrate on
the website
which was something which shocked her
and which clearly she didn't want to do
but it was an indication of a revolution
coming
now the worry of course for many of us
is that the internet has not yet shown
itself to be capable
of supporting a news gathering
investigative
uh project of the kind that great
newspapers have supported yes
so if
the print media die
and the internet
fails immediately to replace them
what are the prospects
if you like for the truth
yes well one reason why i nearly
couldn't make your kind invitation this
evening was with last night we had to
give
the
party at the white house correspondents
during the annual
thing where the press forms too much on
the president and the president forms
slightly too much on the press and there
we all were in the
washington hilton ballroom and i thought
you know it looks thinner every year
somehow
um
and i could add to what and catherine
was there she came to our only after
that i i was thinking
the washington times which is the only
rival to the washington post in
washington now
and which is a paper owned by the
reverend sung miyan moon of the
unification church at that
is very nearly dead and we'll be at one
newspaper town pretty soon
i think last year
um
seattle became one newspaper town i was
astounded by that i have to say saint
louis i think three or four los angeles
has been one for a bit and the la times
has gone down faster and further than
anyone would have believed
um well everyone knows a bit of this
story i suppose but it's the speed of it
that impresses me
and that's at the production end if you
like it the demand end
i teach writing and i sometimes teach
journalism
and of my
students i would say that none now
regularly take a newspaper
and that's that's more or less it the
demographic as we say that's
that's a death sentence if if the habit
of picking up a paper and carrying it
around with you or taking it into the
house in the morning
is gone among the young then you've more
or less set the clock but what are the
consequences well
so i used to think well the positive
thing is that now
if i have a bright young
student whose work is promising i don't
i can't just i don't have to limit
myself to saying to them look i can
probably introduce you to someone in the
newsroom in chicago or new york or it
might be
i probably get your your clips read you
might be able to bypass having to join
the newspaper guild or a union or
anything like this that you might get a
break
i can say to them look you could you
could put up your own site you could
publish if you doomed to write you're
doomed to write and you could say
okay i'll put it up there and see if
anyone wants to come
expose yourself directly to the thing
and that's been quite encouraging and i
know some people who've done rather well
out of it but here's what i think is the
danger it's partly the one you identify
it opens us to an era of terrible
relativism
where everyone's opinion is as good as
anyone else is
you don't have to
earn
earn any credibility in a way
um and pretty soon you'd have not just
your own opinions but your own choice of
facts and there wouldn't be
a common stock of reference
which is by the way also a problem in
teaching literature these days very
difficult to find a book that everyone
has read
but do you think um do you think that
the things like the ipad and the kindle
are ways for newspapers to survive
yes i mean i think they're the only way
they can survive
but it won't postpone it when postponed
i don't think people
who weren't buying the new york times
weren't buying it because they couldn't
get it on kindle
we'll
now read it because they can get it that
way and there's actually an easy proof
of that i think i was in them
i hate taxi tv don't you
yes um but one particularly abject thing
that happened to me the other day in new
york was it was a new york times ad
clearly pitched to the youth market in
that fawning way that older marketers
talked to young people all the people
they imagine to be young and say just
get the weekend edition you don't have
to sweat through all the news and uh
using just it's all about
sports and games and music and theater
the movies you love it yeah and the
washington times excuse me the
washington catherine's advertising in on
the radio in washington is exactly the
same
just take it for a couple of days a week
and read the fun stuff yeah don't think
of us as a fuddy-duddy
news gathering we're not going to bore
you with lots of stories about you know
afghanistan or crap like that downers
everything is entertainment so the
defeat has already been experienced if
you like it's a shame i was telling
someone before about has anyone seen the
paper with michael keaton
phil great and some reason to me great
great a great movie i think
about a day in the life of a hacked
tabloid journalist in new york he's
obviously working for the post but the
three papers are on his table in the
morning and his paper headline says you
know headless body and topless bar and
the
daily news says
something like you know ford to new york
drop dead and
the new york times says
uh signs of swing to moderation in
nepalese elections
and he throws the paper to the floor and
says these pastors do anything to sell
newspapers
that's over believe me well at that
point let's we have about 15 minutes or
so so if people have questions they'd
like to ask christopher there's two
microphones there and there and if you
could or you sir and well or me but
really him
if you could go to the microphones and
and take it in turn yeah that's good
i love free speech but i'm worried about
fox news their influence they have so
many viewers and they lie so much is jon
stewart enough you know and colbert how
do we deal with them it's it's they just
make all the noise in the world
yeah i sometimes feel that i'm not as
judgmental about fox as i might be
because i was brought up in for a lot
large part of the early part of my life
in in london
where there's no percentage of
objectivity in journalism
where you you know you know what you're
getting you you look at the newsstands
and they're ablaze with different papers
that are party oriented that are run by
the interests of certain proprietors
not least among them keith rupert
murdoch um
who i last saw three o'clock this
morning by the french embassy swimming
pool
with
um
looking by the way looking by the way
says he's got a lot of good years left
in it
um so i don't get shot so easily what i
don't like is is a is a paper or not
that pretends to be objective and is not
i think that's much more of a danger
yes yes um i'd like to ask both of you
what you think about there's a
there's been a relatively recent court
case about the pledge of allegiance in
which
uh the plaintiff was was arguing that
it's a semi-prayer you know especially
the part where it says under god
and trying to discourage and trying to
make it you know illegal to uh to force
kids or encourage kids to to say that
during school i wondered what you
thought about that
well i know that i know the case very
well and i think mr new dao who brought
it
is actually a slight pain in the ass
because instead of saying what he should
have said which is that the pledge of
allegiance was written and promulgated
and became popular and well loved right
across america in the 1880s
written by a socialist
who was trying to bring america
society back together after the civil
war
and was trying to think of a pledge that
anyone in the country could recite
whatever their background
it went on like that
i pledge allegiance to the flag the
united states of america to the republic
for which it stands one nation
indivisible with justice liberty and
justice for all is beautiful
in the mccarthy years the time of the
toad as uh arthur miller and
lydia hellman used to call it
it was objected by some big mouth at a
flag day ceremony at cleric
where eisenhower was president and was
also present said this pledge could be
recited by a child in moscow
word for word
so
how could you make it so it couldn't be
new problem
how could we have a pledge that couldn't
be researched moscow shove in two words
where they don't belong
destroy the rhythm of the thing
and and make it um
religious put it under god
so what you want to say is no i'm for
original intent i'm a strict
constructionist
i want the pledge back the way it was
most people under the impression that it
always had those words in
and the atheists are coming to take it
out this is stupid
but of course it's flat out
unconstitutional to ask a child to say
under god you may not do that
first amendment is beautifully written
there's no wiggle room in it
congress may make no law respecting an
establishment
thank you
great britain is having an election this
week and one of the candidates who seems
to be doing very well nick clegg of the
liberal democrats is a professed atheist
if he does very well in that election
does that mean
something
changing in britain something new that
we don't have in this country no england
is very different to the united states
in this regard when tony blair who was
who is deeply religious
uh was running for office
he
his his main kind of flat catcher
alistair campbell
uh
said
openly afterwards that they deliberately
played down his religious beliefs
because it would lose them votes
now in england to be religious is to be
a flake
and and who would vote for you if that's
what you you know like i remember when
george w bush was asked early in his
presidency
if he ever consulted his father
now that he was president and he said
pointing upwards no because he had
another father
to whom he would refer now if he were to
say that in a british general election
he would be run out of town on a rail
yes
i've always thought that actually what
george junior was saying is i'd rather
talk to any father than that one but
but mr mr young mr clegg as i think of
him um used to be my intern
at the nation magazine and um of course
i would have hired him if he was a
muslim but um
i'm glad to know that he still isn't a
believer in any
holy book and what someone says is true
in fact i could have answered the last
gentleman's question by saying this
maybe we should
just force all americans to have
a prayer in the schools because i don't
know a quicker way of bringing about the
mass production of atheism among the
young
then that certainly the reason for the
secularization
of british society is that religion is
compulsory in english and scottish and
world schools it has to be a certain
christian protestant kind
and the queen
is the head of the church as well as the
state
and the armed forces which means on the
moment her
heart ceases to beat it should never
happen
but the moment that does happen prince
charles becomes
the head of the church of england a
bat-eared muslim fancier with no taste
in women
and that's what you get
for founding a church on the family
values of henry the age
but i think the truth is i think that in
england it's just not an issue that nick
clegg is not religious would no one
would dream of bringing it up against
him no and they would rebound on them if
they did
we'll see how well he actually does on
the day i mean i have
i don't know what you think christopher
i think you could you could argue that
in the end people will swing back
towards the traditional two parties or
that the the anti-labor
sort of landslide has now gone so far
that they're actually going to do even
worse than the opinion paul suggested
that and that actually we will have a
two-party state but the labour party
will be the third party
i think it's a three-party society
encased uncomfortably within the
two-party duopoly and every now and then
it it it comes out again it did with
jeremy thorpe if you remember at one
point in the 70s and
i think a large part of the vote
for mr clegg is is a call for
proportional representation which now
has to be discussed seriously
well we'll find out on thursday yes
yes um i was really sad to hear you say
that when the danes were trying to get a
muslim book for children they didn't go
to
muslims and ask how do we do it
and that may have prevented the cartoons
from happening the cartoon um
contest
and the other thing is all the talk
about religion
it's really the the extremists the
fanatics it's not the mainstream anyone
i believe that's causing any
difficulties anywhere and i'd like your
opinion well the question i mean you
what you say sounds persuasive and i
don't know by the way that they didn't
go to consult they must they would have
done
uh muslim authorities but the question
would be well which ones would those be
because there are quite a number of
imams in denmark but the ones who
started
the cartoons are very extreme and
they're
i'll come to your other use of that word
in a second um and weren't going to i
think allow any
discussion of the subject that they did
not themselves control
so if you went to one muslim authority
you'd be all you'd be doing was inviting
yourself into a schismatic row
between different factions of muslims
which would be in a very depressing way
to introduce school children to the
subject that's the first thing the
second is the word fundamentalist or
extreme has the following difficulty for
me
either
there is a word of god or there is not
in my opinion there is not
but if someone says no
you know what i think god did speak at
sinai
or did speak at the baptism
of the jordan
or did intervene to dictate
texts of the prophet muhammad
why does that make you a fundamentalist
i mean i think it's an extraordinary
thing to believe but if you say no i
don't really believe that what you are
is not not a fundamentalist you're not
religious
fundamentalism says there is god's word
there is revelation there has been
revelation
atheism is to say that hasn't
belief is what to split that difference
it can't be split
yeah i think we might even be able to
discover a slight difference between
christopher and me here
um
here's bring it on here's a
i mean maybe it's more apparent than
real but i think
my view is
that if people are religious
and gain from it
satisfaction
nourishment solace whatever it is
my view is that's none of my business
when
that comes into the public arena
and they and people of religious belief
try and force the values of that belief
onto me or onto the society in which i
live
then it's my business
and i have very strong views about
whether or not religion should be
allowed into that arena but in the
privacy of one's own home or one's own
mind
if one gains comfort from a certain set
of ideas however cockeyed they might be
that my view is just not your business
or mine i couldn't agree more but it's
it's not in the nature of especially
monotheism to let that happen because
uh they they're looking at you going to
hell they're not allowed to do that they
they're
they're supposed to redeem you
they're supposed to save you yes i'm not
gonna they can't leave you alone
it's my i will keep saying to them if i
thought there was a personal god who
took all the trouble to care about me
and supervise my movements and
and
have a tender attitude towards me in
general
um and even promised me that i would not
croak
i guess i have no idea what it would be
like to feel anything so fatuous but i
suppose it would make
it would make me happy
you know why doesn't it make it doesn't
mean i'm happy at all
the people who say they believe this
they can't be happy until i believe it
too
and that's the cause of the constant uh
cultural battle
so no i don't want it why do i even know
what they believe so a church which was
not militant you think is not not really
and it wouldn't be it wouldn't be the
church
judaism doesn't proselytize
except among jews
much
it doesn't anymore
um
yeah well it also also doesn't say the
messiah has already come it says it has
its advantages that too all right yes
hi yeah my question is about engagement
and maybe the role for engagement um
there's been a lot of discussion about
free speech and advocating and standing
up for it but um i live and work in
china and often when artists or
musicians writers abroad
protest china it does make it harder for
people working in the system so i just
want to see your thoughts on the balance
between engagement and protest i guess
well you keep hearing i suppose it must
sometimes be true
that if everyone kept quiet about a
certain country or a certain state
and didn't get
give its government the impression that
foreigners were intervening and so on
that
that it might make life easier for the
local
the tamer sort of dissident i mean one
is often told that
we're always told for example that
iranians don't welcome support
for their efforts from outsiders because
they they can then be identified or even
criminalized with
but that's all right again as long as
the regime itself stays out of my life
but the iranians won't do that they
won't let me think oh well i don't care
what happens in iran
on the country they say they want to
export
people to kill salman
uh people to overthrow the democracy of
lebanon
uh people to blow up the jewish
community centre and buenos aires we
know the names of the people who've been
doing this in tehran and to have an off
the record nuclear program
well i'm sorry i'm this is not their
internal affair
and i don't have a single human rights
question since you mentioned your
domicile
burma
the uh zimbabwe
um iran
um
[Music]
well just those three for now
you're trying to get anything done about
those poor at north korea these
appalling really appalling regimes and
you find that they're protected by a
chinese guarantee at the united nations
and in
sudan
china wants to buy all their oil it's
gonna it mean time gives them all their
weapons
you cannot address major human rights
drama in the world now without coming
against coming up against chinese power
on the on the wrong side i'm sorry this
is not their internal affair
i'd also add to that you know uh if you
look at the experience of of pen for pen
american center
um
i'd say two things every time that pen
has supported a writer
uh in
difficulties or arrested whatever in
whatever country
um
we have heard back
from those writers
that it was enormously valuable to them
to know that their case was being seen
by the rest of the world and that they
gained great strength
and nourishment from the fact that their
case was being highlighted so certainly
in the cases of those writers who have
been on the front line
to them it has mattered a great deal
that their case was uh
was was given prominence you know but
there's another thing which is if you
look at the
these so-called awards that penn gives
every year to writers which is actually
obviously those are writers in jail so
the award is a way of highlighting their
plight
there is an enormously high percentage
which i think is somewhere around 90
percent
of those writers being released from
jail within a six-month period
and and it is because it's very
encouraging tyranny does not like
publicity you know it is one of the
curious weaknesses of tyrants that they
want to be liked
[Music]
and if you could show them that they are
not liked and actually that the world
thinks they're [ __ ]
because what they're doing to that
writer or those writers it's sometimes
easier for them to release those writers
and stop getting that kind of bad
publicity and this has been our
experience in country after country for
many many years you know so so i would
say about the publicity that on the one
hand it gives strength to the good guys
and on the other hand it very often
discomfits the bad guys so much that
they actually change their behavior
yes uh yes i was wondering if you could
give specific examples of great literary
novels that are now being censored
muslim um societies i'm very sympathetic
about satanic verses children of
jabalawi god dies by the nile and so
forth but is there anything right now
and if so would it be al-azhar that's
doing it is it saudi arabia is it iran
and could you give the name of the book
and the author well the most famous book
that is buddlerized in every single
muslim country is not published
unexpected in a single muslim country at
this point is the 1001 knights the
arabian night
the the arabian nights the most famous
book in the history of arab literature
cannot be published
uncensored in any arab country why
because it's full of naughty bits
you know there's a lot of sex in the
arabian nights and oddly there's very
little religion
you know god doesn't make many
appearances in the arabian nights but
men and women having a great deal of sex
make a lot of appearances
and and so there it is only the most
famous work in the history of the
literature
is the one being censored
iran has to authorize the publication of
novels by board of censors every year
there have been years i don't know if
this is one of them but there have been
years recently when not a single novel
has been approved for publication
so no novels have been published that
were though no knowledge were deemed
worthy of publication so the censorship
is at a very extreme level it's also
probably an aspect of under development
that's
you should look up the arab development
report which was
produced under the auspices of my friend
uh clovis maxwell who used to be the
head of the arab league
and a panel of other regional
intellectuals and writers
on the sheer dearth of
literary material not as a result merely
of censorship but of the failure to
publish or translate
greece translates more books into
out of other languages and into greek
every year than the whole arab world
does in its its entire language so it's
just it's a matter of the unavailability
of things that it's cultural starvation
rather than a
singling out of a book for censorship
the only book i know about that comes
straight to my mind because i've just
written the introduction to its
anniversary edition is animal farm which
is banned in all muslim countries not
just because of the pigs so after all if
you remember don't come that well out of
the book
but because certainly certainly in iran
where i've been involved in an attempt
to get it to get a pirate edition going
but possibly smuggle back into persia
uh it's because it's about a revolution
betrayed
it's it's much more political
okay we're out of time so if you could
please ask a quick question and
christopher give a really quick answer
that we can do i'm sorry
okay um you mentioned vaclav havel
earlier who um as you know was a
playwright before he became the
president and i've often wondered what a
government composed of writers would
look like and if art in politics
necessarily has to be independent in a
free society so i was just wondering um
if you think that would necessarily be
detrimental and what that would look
like
salman for president um
mr president i can just i have called
him that when he was president of japan
uh plato thought it would be the worst
possible idea in the republic he says
that that really would be terrible
that'd be the worst kind of tyranny you
could picture
i think poetry should probably be banned
um
[Music]
when
what examples do we have that could be
in the least bit encouraging here
some countries have done very well by
making their writers into ambassadors
yeah uh george sir ferris was a
brilliant ambassador carlos fuentes
carlos fuentes um
uh jorge edwards uh was a great diplomat
um
diego well
we had a near mess with mario vargas
yes
love harvell
um
i'm not applying for the job harvard was
the best
and um
georgie conrad
was offered the presidency of hungary
after the collapse of communism
but
the author of anti-politics and various
other wonderful books but he said no i
think he's partly because he thought the
first
independent president of hungary i mean
president of independent hungary should
not be a jew
um rather
a rather arcane reservation but perhaps
a
a good one
um
in the circumstances
okay well no i think i think um
i think people should be elected
i think uh
i think on behalf of penn we have to
offer a big vote of thanks to
christopher hitchens
christopher hitchens is a contributing
editor at vanity fair magazine and a
professor of liberal studies at the new
school in new york city his books
include why or well matters god is not
great and the forthcoming memoir
hitch-22 for more information visit
penn.org
tell us what you're reading and what you
think of our programs
christopher hitchens talks with book tv
from the 2010 book expo america in new
york city he discusses his memoir hitch
22 for half an hour
christopher hitchens who talked you into
doing
an autobiography
i think it may well have been the person
who wrote my obituary by accident
in the um
catalogue of the national portrait
gallery in london a couple of years ago
there was a
an exhibit about a group of people
friends of mine and of martin amuses a
sort of set if you like
and in the catalog copy it referred to
the late christopher hitchens and um
they were terribly upset and said don't
worry we'll recall them all we'll pulp
the whole thing and i said no no i want
several copies of that because
nothing focuses the mind like reading
about yourself in the past tense
and it immediately dissolved any
objection i had
when i was asked to do
a memoir which is well isn't it too
early
i think well i certainly can't leave it
till it's too late
so there was that and then
i told myself
excuse me
i talked myself into it a bit
because i didn't much mind being 40
or 50 i barely noticed it but 60 hit me
harder than i thought it would
and i found i was looking backwards
quite a lot brooding on things
so i thought this is probably the right
moment to do it
why hitch 22
well
i end up having described a lot of
commitments i've had in my life and a
lot of ideological battles i've taken
part in
with the general polemic against
certainty
and against um purity
against consistency if you like i'm i'm
no longer a member of any party or any
ideological grouping but i am associated
with a group of skeptics
who are sure of one thing which is that
nothing's for sure
and you're absolutely certain about the
uncertainty principle
and so my my hitch 22 is that my
commitment is entirely to the
to doubt
so that's the idea and then
there was a game i have a lot of word
games in the book some of them very pure
art indeed
schoolboy humor but
getting better as time goes on and um
one of them is a
game invented by salman rushdie
where you have to think of a book title
that didn't quite make it um
for whom the bell rings for example or
um
mr zhivago
or um
good expectations was another one um
a farewell to weapons uh portrait of a
woman
and one that he contributed actually was
hitch 22 and i thought yes i think i
might borrow that
death is a theme in your book yes why
well because because i begin with my own
obituary
accidental obituary
then because it's not an autobiography
exactly but it
i thought that everyone if they're doing
a memoir they have to do one chapter
about their parents
and death i'm afraid it's a big subject
there because
my mother took her own life in very
tragic
circumstances very dramatic tragic
certain sense that i described
and my father was in the war business he
was a lifelong
naval officers had a very tough war and
i was brought up entirely on
stories of chiefly british
valor at sea
um and on land and india i mean it was
i can't remember how old i was until i
realized that all television all books
and all films were not about the second
world war i thought they were
the
chapter about your mother yvonne
yes i could evolve well because it was
her name and because that's what i used
to call her
she liked it
and because it's a nice name
um
and it's the way when i think about it i
don't i don't think mummy i think or
mama or i think yvonne
we were very close and
[Music]
and i also used to think because we came
from a slightly drab
part of english society the lower middle
class
with aspirations
naval and military and
my mother was a sort of failed
millionaire she kept trying to open
dress shops that never quite made it
and so
the sort of the wives of my father's
brother offices were called things like
ethel or
margery or nancy or names like that and
i always thought when i was little that
yvonne had a touch of class to it was a
little bit more cosmopolitan perhaps a
bit more stylish a bit more
swanier
and she was that in my life she i
described her as the gin in the campari
and the cream in the coffee she was uh
cheerful and
humorous and um
once said to me that the really the only
the really only unforgivable sin was to
be boring
which has haunted me all my life
fear of bores
fear of becoming a bore or being boring
terror stark terror but
i think it's probably the most
devastating word that one can use
against somebody or
or risk having used against yourself yes
don't be boring mustn't be boring
this book is full of names bold-faced
names as i say i'm just going to throw
some out and have you sure respond
martin amos yes who is he what's his
relationship well martian is um
as i'm sure a lot of your audience will
know is he
brilliant novelist
both of humor and of gravity i mean he's
written
uh novels about the holocaust
and about the gulag archipelago
but he's also written i think with his
best humorous one best known one it's
called money
which is a study of anglo-american
degeneracy and the the cusp of the
1980s um in which i appear once or twice
fairly heavily disguised
and he's my best friend and has been
since we were in our 20s
and the chapter of the book is basically
a sort of love letter to martin and
i i'd say in the
in that chapter that
the question i'm trying to answer is
phrase it like this can you have a
heterosexual relationship with another
guy
i don't know whether you can or not but
i decided to give it the sort of old
college try
and
i described the influence you had on my
writing
the way in which we used to have very
long language very tender
very intense discussions about women
um
the the inexhaustible subject
and i show how you can make lead into
gold
as i describe a visit we both made
to a terrible massage parlor brothel
outfit in new york
which he had to go to because his
character and money john self had to go
and expose himself to this
it was field work and it was the most
intensely sordid
and horrible and
depressing uh shameful really
morning of my life i think um
and for him too absolutely ghastly you
can read it in money i'd even give the
page reference
um and i thought when i read that
section
john self's fiasco in the massage party
i thought well
that whole morning of squalor and misery
it's now been sort of totally redeemed
it's become literature
it's an almost pristine moment you
actually you can get wasted lost time
back
and feel it wasn't squandered after all
so i know if i'm giving you a hint i
mean i
he's been a great source of enthusiasm
and um
risk and so on in my life
james fenton you dedicate the book to
him
james um
changed my life when i met him at oxford
um
in the late 60s where we were exact
contemporaries
um
he is i think easily the finest poet
writing in english at least of his
generation now
and
probably best known to your audience for
the poems he wrote from indochina it's a
surprising thing when you think about it
there's almost no poetry generated by
the vietnam war or if there is there
isn't a poem everybody knows
um as there have been poems in other
wars
the best is written by james i quote
some of it
um
and he
as well as martin and a few others
taught me that there was more to writing
and more to journalism than
polemic you know i used to think that
the test of a good article was how well
i'd argued the case how well i'd
sort of laid out the arguments for the
left how how bad i could make the right
wing look
how i marshaled the arguments it was all
very didactic
and though james like me was very much
to the left
to him it mattered much more how the
article was written
making every word count using irony and
understatement and humor
and we actually even wrote a couple of
articles together the only time i've
done a joint byline with anybody
and he was he was immensely influential
on on me in that way i think prevented
be perhaps some becoming boring
to revert to the
the death trap subject
peter sedgwick
yes
peter said you would be less well known
to audience but
he was um
he was a marxist intellectual of a very
rarefied kind in other words he
he was one of those people who was of of
the left of the left the left against
the left very very anti-stalinist
very much against some of the cult
figures of the 60s like um
herbert marcuse and rd lang who were
being
much badded about they were conjuring
names when
when i was beginning to cut my
teeth he thought the 60s would probably
a bit of a false promise the
counterculture didn't interest him very
much he was a scientist as a
psychiatrist
believed in objectivity um
wasn't easily swayed
introduced me to the sort of dissident
marxist tradition of writing
rosa luxembourg particularly
some of leon trotsky
george orwell
um
the great clr james the great west
indian historian
who wrote the best really the only book
on the haitian
revolution it's called black jacobins
fantastic book about the
slave rebellion in haiti and also
incidentally was the best writer on
cricket that's ever been produced by the
british empire
um an odd thing for a revolutionary to
be doing but that was the thing about
peter he introduced you to idiosyncratic
types the sort of tradition of the
revolutionary left that
got buried by the hitler style impact by
the cold war
and which was
had something of a revival in the 60s
and 70s
salman rushdie
will salman
i have devoted a whole chapter to him
and to his cause because i was just
getting to know him i'd become a friend
of his when
he suddenly became even more famous than
he thought he was going to become and
even more well known for his writing all
in all at one go rather unfortunately
didn't of getting an incredibly bad
review from the ayatollah khomeini who
as well as not content with a bad review
offered money in his own name to suborn
salman's murder
an unbelievable sort of frontal attack
on civilization so
for many years he had to go into hiding
and be off the map
and there were
a number of us who were very proud to be
his friend at that time
sort of arranged to
keep in touch with him to keep up his
spirits
he was afraid at one point
not so much that they would find him and
kill him but
the effort of staying alive would mean
he couldn't write turns out he was wrong
to fear that he's written a lot of great
stuff since then
um he's a very emblematic figure
of this of the 20th century the the idea
of the intellectual migrant the person
who's at home in two continents
it's incredible to me that english is is
only his second language his first
language is audio he writes it and
i would certainly say speaks it
really better than any native speaker
does
and as i say he hugely improved the
level of our rather childish
boy boyish schoolboyish word games
um
i'll give you an example uh he was once
asked without any preparation
um
[Music]
what would a shakespeare play
be titled if robert london was tight i
won't tell you how that all came up
takes too long but
just picture if you will look robert
lord i'm naming a shakespeare face
someone said okay try me and we said
okay hamlet and he said um
the elsinore vacillation just like that
unbelievably clever um
i said okay i bet you can't do that
twice with macbeth says it
the dancing deforestation um
for othello the kerchief implication um
for the merchant of venice the rialto
sanction or like that
there are some more in the book um
he has a real hold on english literature
he he he loves it and really knows it
and in addition as if that wasn't enough
he's become
one of the great symbolic figures in the
in the battle of over free expression
which never ends
we never thought perhaps we would have
to defend
the first amendment against such an
incredibly fantastically violent
fundamental literally fundamentalist
assault
but i think it was right to notice when
the hour had struck when it did
proud to have had anything to do with
that
go on at length about it
taking the citizenship test
oh yes
yeah shortly after 9 11
i realized i've been living in the
states for a long time more than two
decades nearly three
i had a green card that was so old that
it didn't have an expiration date on it
it was one of those old ones they used
to give out a platinum green card you
might say
i had three american children an
american wife
it's unlikely i'd get deported um
and i had a european union passport in a
green car i could have gone on like that
happily being sort of anglo-american
for the rest of my days but i thought i
began to feel i was sort of cheating on
my deers
that i should i really felt a strong
solidarity with american society after
that
appalling attack on it just down the
road from here
and um
began to feel much more like an american
even strangely to feel more like a
washingtonian i mean like washington was
more like my base i used to think
strong identification so
i applied
and um
well it's got very hard to do the
paperwork these days
and they kept on making appointments and
then breaking them and
putting them off
but then they sent me an exam
which i think even had the answers in it
about questions you might be asked at an
interview
and um
some of them were rather trivial like
what are the advantages of becoming an
american citizen you
you wanted to think there would be some
something noble could be said there
you looked at the answers given by the
official government that said
you can apply for a job in the federal
government and you can bring your
relatives in from that's overseas
one would hope one the united states
could say a bit more for itself than
that
um
then there are questions where you
mustn't try and be funny like against
whom did we fight in the american
revolution well i think the answer is
the usurping hanoverian royal family
that had us
but the correct answer is the british so
you have to get all that right
it's a bit disappointing but i set up
the night before
not in any fear of failing the exam but
i just sat up and read through the
constitution
and the bill of rights
and i have a section in there about how
you can read off the whole history of
america
by looking at the dates of those
amendments
the the ways in which they came about
it's it's very nice because
it's nice in itself because actually
does demonstrate progress which
sometimes you wonder about
second we'll have doubts about it
second it shows why this is such a great
country for a writer because it's based
on written documents
which are deliberately there in order to
expose themselves to rewrite their work
in progress they can be revised
so that the the words and the music of
the words and the meaning of them and
the legality of them are all very
important and that's a unique privilege
i think
so
then i was able by good luck
to get
um the department of homeland security
to allow me to have my ceremony
take the oath
at the jefferson memorial in washington
dc
on his birthday the 13th april which is
also mine and i'd buy then written a
short biography of him
and i held a copy of the virginia
statute on religious freedom
which was one of the four things he
wanted to be remembered for
and um
that was that was a wonderful day really
was
sylvia plath
so the path keeps on coming up in my
story because she wrote about two things
well she didn't write about suicide she
committed suicide but
she's the occasion of an enormous number
of books about female self-destruction
and
i have to i don't just write a chapter
about my mother's
self-slaughter of suicide
but i also write a coder short chapter
of
reflections on suicide and
the plath story keeps coming up in that
and then
in one of her
um most famous lines it's in the bell
jar um
she describes her family coming from
some manic depressive hamlet
in um
on the german polish borderlands
and it so happens that that's where my
mother's family comes from it was a
secret kept in my family for a long time
i didn't find it out till i was
about 30
but my mother's
family was of jewish descent
from what is now poland but was then
germany it's always very horrible when
that border moves at any time in
european history terrible things happen
when that border changes
and i have a chapter on why i think it
is that she
kept it a secret from my father and from
her two sons and from everyone she knew
almost
she died before we could have the
conversation and i make a roots trip i
go to poland
find the old shettle
and
see if i can find any traces of any
remaining relatives no it's a clean
sweep they're all they're all dead they
will be murdered
by fascism
um
and so the the silvioplast concept of
the manic depressive hamlet comes very
alive to me on that trip
peter hitchens
peter hitches is my younger brother he
was born two years after me slightly too
close
perhaps
i used not to notice about things like
birth order and all these articles you
read about it actually now i think it's
quite important
and
things for potential parents to think
about if you have a brother who's
actually more like 18 months younger
than me
he's too close to be a baby brother
um but close enough to be a rival
for of all things my mother's attention
my god imagine how i must have felt
i don't remember it but i'm told that i
became very jealous and i can believe it
and as siblings we've never been very
close we haven't lived in the same town
since we were quite small
he lives in oxford now and he he's a
very well known
newspaper and broadcast newspaper
columnist and
broadcaster in england
of the extreme right
he's also very well known as a christian
believer
in fact he's even written a book you i
hope he'll do something about it it's
come out it's coming out this month or
so it's called the rage against god
the subtitle is how atheism led me to
faith and it's a
it's in part an extended dialogue with
me for my unbelief
and for me anyway the biggest difference
i could have with anyone is no matter
all political differences absolutely
dwarfed by
the difference between those who live
believe there's a supernatural dimension
like him and there's like me you do not
and it's the basis really of all other
arguments that's where philosophy begins
it's where
arguments about biology actually begin
too
so he is i have to say a very good
writer
he's a hitchens after all
um
he's a very serious person i think a bit
more solemn than me perhaps
um
and when i say right wing i mean
genuinely right wing in other words he's
people
people who regard things like the
argument over iraq for instance
as a left right one i always think have
it wrong because
in my experience anyway the iraqi and
kurdish left who are friends of mine
raw in favor of removing tsunami saying
large numbers of the american right
people like pat buchanan as you know
the so-called kissinger realists and so
forth generally against it and the same
is true of a kind of isolationist
conservative
force in britain of which my
brother is a pardon and he he actually
at one point says
the war in afghanistan is the sort of
stupid left-wing war
only someone like my brother could
possibly support
and there's more truth in that i find
than in the
rather cheap allegation made that if you
are in favor of the liberation of iraq
you somehow become right-wing
which i also try to deal with in the
book i have a chapter about
my experiences in iraq going back to the
70s
on the back of your book are the typical
blurbs that a book would have and
christopher buckley for instance says
that you're the greatest living essayist
in the english language very sweet of
him uh gore vidals uh
if he wished to nominate a successor he
writes an inheritor a doffer
i have decided to name christopher
hitchens that's on here but it's marked
out yes
well gold brother took that back
the other day we had a very big falling
out over
9 11 where he made the i think
disgraceful suggestion that it was an
inside job
in which the administration had taken
part
i can't that's more than a difference
over politics it's not a difference of
emphasis i i find that untakeable that
sort of talk
and so
he made a couple rather sour remarks
about me and at one point he even seemed
to suggest that i i'd made that
statement up at any rate it seemed to me
he was taking it back so i thought well
i won't i won't wait for him to take it
back
i'll take it back myself but i did it in
as waspish away as i could
he is said to like a feud well i mean i
think he should have one
chris hitchens
yes the bane of my life
my ugly my ugly younger brother um
i've tried to obliterate him
ever since i was small my mother hated
people calling me chris if your next
name is hitchens
chris hitchens means the h is always
bound to go it's pretty vulgar
uh christopher's a nice name chris isn't
i say that
even though christopher buckley calls
himself chris um i wish he wouldn't
um kristoff actually is what i call him
we compromise on that
um
people at school would try and call me
that
and it's actually it can be very
difficult in america because
people here are fantastically friendly
and they like to get to first name terms
very fast and then shorten them to be
even more friendly almost before you've
got to know them so
unless you quickly say i'd rather you
said christopher
you're going to sound like a snob or
someone who's you know
repudiating
friendly advances so it's it's a
constant battle for me
and
um i think now
i've won it because people don't call me
chris anymore no one who knows me at all
does and anyway a lot of my friends call
me hitch at last which is the other
reason for the title and
was i discovered when i went to my
father's
naval reunion he took me to a reunion of
his old shipmates years ago before he
died
rather touchingly it was i think it was
the last reunion they were going to have
these old sea dogs
and i noticed that they'll call him
hitch i'd never known that before
that was what my friends were going to
call me
so that's another reason
another another fold or wrinkle in the
title
what was the process of writing
a memoir like for you
well
it was a good bit harder than i had
expected it would be
and i tried to work out why it was
giving me such a hard time and there are
two or three reasons i think one
usually when i write i'm trying to make
a case or
push an argument
not always but most of the time
or at least i know exactly what i'm
doing i'm trying to describe a foreign
country say
as best i can i've done a fair bit of
that
with this i'm not making a case
i'm not making an argument it's not an
apology
so
[Music]
the sort of style of writing
gets a little softer perhaps if you're
not careful
and then
again i would normally be trying to see
how much i could pack into a given
number of words
five thousand for an article say or a
long essay might be more or a short book
would be ninety thousand
how much you can
press into this when you're trying to
remember things
if you're like me who has a very good
memory you may well find you're
remembering more than you thought you
would and then you think i must get this
down while it's still in my
cortex
so things start to balloon rather
alarmingly or not being terse at all
you're being very discursive
that was another difficulty it i turned
in almost twice as much as the publisher
originally asked for
i'd never done that before
and then
of course um innate in it you don't know
how it's gonna end
or to be exact how to end it i had a
very hard time
wrapping it up i didn't know really when
i was done in fact i'm not done
i wake up every day thinking damn
i should have put that in or
i should have put that differently but
more often than not something i
remembered that it's too late to put in
now people say it's a good sign
it gives me the blues but it's probably
dull if you're still writing it in your
head
it may have some vitality to it hope so
anyway
christopher hitchens his memoir hitch22
this weekend on book tv's in depth
up next an author panel with christopher
hitchens author of hitch 22 a memoir
william gibson author of zero history
and novel and sarah gruen author of ape
house a novel author and actor patton
oswalt is the master of ceremonies the
program was taped last week at the book
expo america an annual trade show for
the publishing industry this program is
an hour
oh hi uh folks uh thanks for coming out
to the bea luncheon uh my name is paton
oswalt you may have seen me on basic
cable
i'm not used to being in front of a
literate audience this is uh
kind of new for me i'll be at uh
cranberries in west virginia next week
featuring come on out uh
six rolling rocks for six bucks um
i
i have a uh
a book coming out next year that uh my
publisher told me that i should talk
about oh although it's it's a little
awkward to
actually um oh look at look at hitch
getting all the photogs look at that
soaking up the fame
such a rock star um
i uh i have a book coming out next year
i i feel a little weird talking about it
it's still an ephemeral thing in my head
uh but it's uh basically
a collection of uh wow one lady is
taking my picture oh that's that's so
sweet thank you
nice
with it oh with a disposable camera okay
so um
look at the big 35 millimeter lenses
yeah give me a little
oh don't get me under the chin though i
look all bloated and creepy oh
like wow why did admiral ackbar speak at
the luncheon that was weird
good three nerds in the crowd um
basically uh
i don't really know where to start i've
been such a bookworm my whole life and
this is sort of my first
book that's coming out and i'm sure you
guys have been through this process and
are kind of old hands at it but uh
it is sort of a big deal for me and i
and i don't really know
sort of what's going to
happen with it i guess i think the
weirdest part about writing uh the book
is as a comedian if i come up with an
idea i usually just go on stage and just
kind of blurt it out and i get immediate
response and
in writing a book as i write each
sentence i almost want to send it out to
300 random people to see if each
sentence works which i know is a is a
terrible way to kind of write so i'm
sort of
getting used to that process which again
i'm sure that these guys have been
through and know all about
um
and also i've become a dad
uh which is uh very strange because i
want my daughter to
uh grow up very intelligent but now i
don't know how intelligent i wanted to
be
um and i'll just what i'm saying is my
brother-in-law babysits for two kids in
chicago and they're they're basically
the prodigies that the parents are
geniuses the dad is a physicist and the
mom is some other kind of scientist and
the kids are two years old and they
speak languages and they do advanced
math and they play instruments and
they're just prodigies and at one point
uh my brother-in-law one of the but
they're still in diapers that's what's
so weird they wear diapers but they're
reading french so
uh one of the kids
at one point had an accident
in their
diapers basically and my brother-in-law
went oh do i do i gotta change your
diapers and this two-year-old said
diaper
singular
which
again that's
that's the confidence of a serial killer
like if you
if you're defecating in your pants and
then correcting people on their grammar
that's just eerie on on a level that i'm
just not used to at this point
so
uh and now of course i'm on i'm on
twitter uh which uh i just i just love
how we've basically gone from myspace
uh which which was this great thing for
kids and then all the adults piled onto
myspace and all the kids went ooh
there's these creepy old people here and
they ran over to facebook and then all
of us jumped onto facebook and they went
uh and then they kind of went over to
twitter which is just facebook boiled
down to 140 letters that's all it is is
how how how boiled down can you possibly
make it um
and then uh and then i also have a
youtube channel which i've realized now
youtube is is basically the beginning of
american society being rome burning to
the ground because all youtube makes us
is a bunch of bored roman emperors every
day and we basically wake up and say
what do i feel like amusing myself with
this morning would i like to see a panda
poop or perhaps a redneck be hitting the
scrotum i wonder
bring me a panda pooping please that's
all
youtube basically is
is just people being hurt for our
pleasure while we sit in our pajamas
and sip lattes
any questions no we're good
nothing to kind of ask me about
um
huh
oh what's the book going to be about
it's basically a
well thank you
um
it's uh it's sex in the city but for
just sort of fat shut-ins no um no that
would be
that would be wow that was please tell
me that was mocking applause
all right
it's basically it's called zombie
spaceship wasteland and it's a kind of
uh autobiography about my life done
through kind of humorous essays and the
whole basic central idea is and i'm if
there's any writers in the room uh
out there in the audience you know that
especially for the i guess the the nerd
portion of the population
uh part of growing up and becoming a
writer is you either write a book about
zombies a book about spaceships or a
book about wastelands because when
you're 13 14 years old you don't know
how the world works so in order to write
about it you have to somehow either
destroy it or leave it so you either go
oh there'll be a zombie apocalypse or
it's a weird futuristic wasteland or
i've just left the planet and i'm
killing mutants with a ray gun because
i'm frightened of girls i don't quite
know how
uh
the social networks work so i'm going to
destroy them before i write about them
so that's
folks the book's a lot better than the
way i just described it by the way
there's all kinds of there's really
awesome stuff in it i'm telling you
is this the way you sell a book just
kind of go up in front of people and
really
i wrote this book and it's awesome you
should totally check it out
all right here's stephen king
um
all right i will uh
i'm going to end on i'm going to end on
a bit that uh uh made its way into the
uh
colombian valedictorians speech this
past weekend
um yes thank you columbia graduates uh
when i was in college i went to a very
liberal arts college and it was the kind
of a college that they were very proud
about the fact that you know we create
well-rounded students our science majors
take english classes and our english
majors take science classes and i was an
english major and i had to take a
science class and
uh and basically and to this day my
knowledge of science goes no further
than salt is salty there there you go
so um but they had a class in my college
and i'm not making this up i went to the
college of william and mary and in my
junior year they had a class called
physics for poets
so basically was like hey there english
major weenie are you
do you want to learn about the music of
the spheres without any scary numbers
we'll put on some pantaloons and a scarf
and skip on down through a field of
ghillie flowers to the physics
department
where we'll teach you about the about
science without using any of those
frightening equations that make you
scurry under your bed and shiver under
the coverlet and you can ask questions
like is the red planet mercury like the
crimson eye of cerberus
yes whatever just sit down puffy shirt
we'll just get you through this
so
the guy that taught the class was the
head of the physics department and was
clearly doing it as a favor
to
the college they just go please just get
these get these english majors through
one science class so they can graduate
and he taught the class just just soaked
in resentment like his hatred for us you
could have drizzled it over waffles it
was so thick and rich he just hated us
but for the final exam i guess he just
figured i've been so mean this whole
semester i'm gonna try to reach out to
these wood nymphs and be a nice guy so
he gave us the final exam were five word
problems and he really sprinkled some
english prose over them and and tried to
make them user friendly and one of the
questions was
captain kirk is sitting on the bridge of
the uss enterprise
if the if a klingon ship is approaching
at this speed and the enterprise is
going this fast that it's basically it
was a distance and velocity problem in
space
um
and the question ended with um if if
captain kirk uh tells chekov to fire the
phasers and the phasers go this fast so
that's the whole problem so i'm sitting
in the back of the auditorium and this
is how my friend tells it because he was
sitting next to me and he's like you
suddenly stood up
walked all the way down to the front of
the auditorium and you're now at the
professor's desk and you're saying
something very specific and very angry
and very pointed and then you walked
away and the professor
put his hands
on his desk and just kind of heaved
himself to his feet and sweat
everybody please need your attention
uh word problem number five
i've just been informed
that
sulu fires the phasers on the uss
enterprise
not chekhov
if this made the question
impossible to solve
i will
change the name of the crew member
please hand your blue books to my ta
i'm gonna go home
sit in a hot bath and open a couple of
veins screw all of you
all of you die
please buy my book next year
all right thank you guys
very much
um
all right i'm gonna uh introduce uh each
of our uh panelists i almost said
panelists like this is a game show um uh
this first uh uh writer is a huge
uh in in in my world this guy is the
white stripes and bowie and a rocket
that's made of cheetos that is how
awesome he is to me
his new book hitch 22
which they sent me an advanced copy of
and i've read it and it's crack it's so
good um
uh folks you know him you love him
ladies and gentlemen mr christopher
hitchens
[Applause]
[Music]
just a hint of tongue there
ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much for coming um i was
thinking when you were talking about the
title problem
of flash back to me the late english
comedian alan koren wanted to write some
memoirs and he was told
by his publishers they don't sell don't
bother
very discouraging wherever he went and
they finally said well what does sell
and they said books about golf
books about cats
and books about the nazis
so he wrote a book called golfing for
cats
which i had on its cover a huge cat
waving a golf club with a huge swastika
tattoo noise
on its tummy and it was a bestseller
so take courage um
i was asked to be brief but i didn't
realize that i'd have such an enormous
captive
audience so
just relax everyone i hope has a drink
and something to read perhaps in fact
like steve all got pitch 22.
make yourself comfortable i have no
intention of being terse
i was also asked to write talk a bit
about what it's like writing about life
writing
and one of the things is
you have to bid a due to economy
normally i'm trying to condense trying
to lay out an argument make a case
see how much you can pack into a few
thousand
with the fountain of memory unsealed
however
you throw a caution to the winds you
keep remembering more and more things
you try to get them down while you can
and you look for mnemonic devices and of
course one of the best of these and i
have a lot of them in the book
is the limerick
i know that a lot of you think the
limerick is just a
delivery system for filth don't you
yeah filth that's what they want uh
filth and plenty of it um
the humble limerick i mean can be used
as a delivery system for filth i mean
there's the young engine driver named
hunt
who was given an engine to shunt saw a
runaway truck by yelling out duck
saved the life of the fellow in front
that's not what you wanted is it that's
not at all
what you wanted was something filthy and
preferably anti-clerical i would guess
strange how contemporary that stuff is
um
let's see it's a family values gathering
i'll keep it soft
though
they say of the bishop of birmingham
that he screws little boys while
confirming him
they kneel on the cassock he lifts up
his hassak and
pumps his episcopal sperm in him
rough
you'll agree but
hardly needs any bad words
but the real point about the limerick is
not that i could go on in that vein but
i won't unless there's a huge demand for
it
it's how much you can condense for
example uh the great robert conquest who
is one of the many wonderful figures
whose friendship i honor in the book
he's now
94 great historian of the russian
revolution and great poet
and great limericist and he condensed
the history of the russian revolution
into a limerick which
goes like this russian revolution had a
big influence on my life at one point
too so that's my excuse
there once was a fellow named lennon
who did two or three million men in
that's a lot to have done in
but where he did one in that old bastard
stalin did 10 in
you see it doesn't leave much out five
lines
um you'll remember the speech that
jacques gives in the second act of as
you like it the seven ages of man you
remember all the worlds of stage and all
the men and women merely players they
have their exits and their entrances
each man in his time plays many paths
the form being seven ages remember that
this is robert conquest condensing those
24 lines
into the following
um seven ages
first puking and mulling
then very pissed off with your
schooling then [ __ ] and then fights
then judging chaps rights then sitting
in slippers then drooling
shakespeare in one go you can also do
john calvin's doctrine of predestination
in um in the limerick uh there once was
a man who said damn
it's been born in upon me i am the
creature that moves
in predestinate grooves i'm not even a
bus i'm a tram
there you have it
and well
and then there's the wasteland um
quite easy to do if you're wendy coke
who i've listed my memoir is one of my
favorite poets certainly my favorite
woman poet
and she has the wasteland like this um
in april one seldom feels cheerful
hot sun and cold dusk
make me fearful
clairvoyance
depress me
commuters distress me met stetson and
gave him an earful now the wasteland
ladies and gentlemen
so
uh these i try and include as mnemonic
uh devices but the task of telling about
one's life doesn't get any easier in
fact it gets harder once you've
once you've finished
because
you keep on remembering more things or
things you wish you'd said since we're
talking in french
it's um
it's uh
what did hero calls the um the esprit de
scalia the line you think of on the
staircase on the way down that you wish
you'd
after the time it comes to you too late
sometimes called
aria paul say
i was asked yesterday
why i decided to slightly out myself
and describe a gay episode in my
bride said regurgitated days at oxford
university
where one of two of my conquests
included
delightful young men who later became
members of mrs thatcher's cabinet
and i was asked why didn't uh why chosen
to put that in
and i said
well i've been in favor of screwing the
tories all my life
why didn't i put that in the book i
tortured myself about it um
jonathan carp my brilliant editor and
publisher
and one of the founders of this feast
said to me at one point this there's
quite a lot of sex but not very much
love in the book and i thought i was
thinking in blurbs by then i thought
immediately
lots of sex but no love jonathan carp
12. perfect verb
almost written
for me
if they say anyway they say it's a good
sign if you keep on thinking about it
and that it's boring if you put in if
you've put in
everything the other thing that i found
is that there's nothing quite like
reading about your own death
someone referred to me as the late
christopher hitchens in the catalogue of
the
national portrait gallery in london
recently and i thought i'm not late mate
but then i thought but there's a
sentence that will one day be absolutely
literally true
and as um leopold bloom says in ulysses
it's a good thing to read
your death notice it gives you a new
outlook on life concentrates the mind uh
very wonderfully i recommend it
constant reflection on demise
is a good thing
now um
i'm trespassing on the time of my
fellow guests here i'll just i'll try
and end with another thought
because i'd like you all to read the
book and i'd like you to give it to your
friends and tell them not to take it out
of the library but to buy their own copy
because there's much much more value
added if you
if you do that and it also hit me
yesterday and i wish i'd thought of this
before that
hitch 22 is also a telephone number
it's got exactly the right number of
digits as it were um and if you just put
one 900 in front of it will you promise
write this down
just
dial one 900 hitch 22 and we can stay
in in constant touch and you can send my
my children to college and i and i look
forward to it and it's been very nice of
you to be my prisoner thanks so much
ladies and gentlemen thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
now um unfortunately uh mr hitchins has
to fly to london which i so hope someday
someone says that about me like he wants
to stay he's got to fly to london
because you're a spy for god's sakes you
you are literally
james bond he's going to he's going to
leave now to fly to london how awesome
is that now let's all watch him do it
here he goes there christopher hitchens
ladies and gentlemen
thank you
[Music]
if if you haven't had a chance to read
the book the chapter where he goes over
some of the word games that he and his
circle of equally brilliant friends play
is so filthy and so kind of reassuring
to a comedian like me that oh yeah even
really smart people try to find ways to
slip filthy words into classic sentences
i won't go into it but it is it is
it's actually kind of life affirming in
it it's literally pages they're just
sheets of filth and when you're done
reading them you'll go oh hey life's
really great all right
i like it
um
now our next writer i i got sent your
book last week and i've been moving and
i haven't had a chance to read all of it
but i i started reading it on the plane
yesterday and i read it the entire
flight i could not stop reading it i've
read the first i think
10 chapters at this point
and uh and that's really saying a lot
because the in-flight movie was the
tooth fairy starring the rock and i did
not watch it
i i instead i read her book instead of
watching tooth fairy a fifth time so
that really
um uh the book is called uh ape house
i'm gonna let you describe it but we
were talking about it backstage it's it
the beginning is terrific maybe it
stinks later on i don't know but the
beginning is awesome
it is really amazing uh ladies and
gentlemen the also the author of water
elephants sarah gruen ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
hi
can everybody hear me
okay
is the microphone right in front of my
face no okay
well um
it's been three years since i was last
at baea and uh it's hard for me to
believe because the time has just flown
and i actually as many of you know
intended to be here last year
but sometimes books take a little longer
to write than you intend
um
before i get into details on the new
book i want to
thank everyone in this room again for
everything that you did for water for
elephants
um it meant the world to me it it made
the book and as a direct result of that
the film started
they started filming the movie a week
ago today
and so thank you
[Music]
and it's got a dream cast of christoph
waltz and reese witherspoon and robert
pattinson
and
additionally a lovely elephant named ty
and speaking of lovely animals
it was just before my water for
elephants tour that my mother sent me an
email about the grade 8 trust in des
moines iowa and the work they were doing
there with language cognition and
acquisition among apes
and
there were two reasons that i was fast
immediately fascinated by this and the
first is that although i've loved
animals my whole life and and
particularly great apes i've never heard
of bonobos
and the second is that they're doing
really really amazing work with language
acquisition and i had been following the
story of coco the gorilla since um 1980
which i well i've just dated myself but
it's it was it's been a long time that
i've been interested in this
um
but the bonobos i spent a day looking at
the the website of the grade 8 trust and
researching bonobos of it and they're
the
um most recently discovered species of
grade eight um only 1929 did they get
named as an as their own species they
were considered a type of chimpanzee
before but they have a completely
different culture and it's a really
kind of crazy culture they're um
they're matriarch matriarchal
they're egalitarian they're peaceful and
they're extremely amorous
the average bonobo initiates sexual
contact of some sort every hour and a
half
they it's like a handshake they reaffirm
friendship they when they get excited
about food arriving they have an orgy
before eating it's you know it's
they really do so i really just i
decided right then and there that i had
to do the next book on these on these
creatures and i really wanted to go and
meet them as part of that
so apparently a lot of people want to go
meet the apes of the great eight trust
and the trust weeds them out by giving
you tons of homework to do and
making you prove that you've done it and
what part of my there was a stack of
books and
linguistic textbooks and things and i
also went to york university for a crash
course on linguistics
and
it wasn't ever anything that interested
me before but when i came out of
york and walked to the bus stop what i
really wanted to do was walk to the
enrollment office because i was just
already so caught up in the work that
was being done and listening to
the vocalizations of the bonobos and
them actually picking
you know words but i digress a little
bit because that's the bonobo language
the the thing that's important for for
my book is that the bonobos have human
language
they uh understand spoken english
completely
and they respond using a
lexigram board uh which is it's a series
of symbols that represent words and on
their computers they press the buttons
and a synthesized human voice says the
word and they speak in complete
sentences and they use
tenses and you know they're
grammatically correct it's it's um it's
amazing so i i did my homework and i um
groveled until i got invited to the
trust and
um
but i knew that getting to the trust did
not mean that i was going to get to meet
the apes because the apes are in
complete control there and so
i really tried to stack my odds like the
guy in my book
i did research on each of the apes
favorite toys and foods and i bought
them each backpacks and stuffed them
with bouncy balls mr potato heads m m's
um
and had them and and sent an email to
the scientists saying oh please tell
them i'm bringing surprises and so after
my orientation and they were testing me
on the books and i'm like yeah yeah i
did the homework can i meet the apes
and um so they went back and asked the
apes and came back and said well yes not
only are they letting you in they're
insisting you come in
so m ms go a long way with apes and
children but
um so
kanzi is the most famous of the bonobos
of the great ape trust and he's he's a
show-off he's a rock star and he knows
it so he came out and he was talking on
his keyboard and and and playing music
you know he's recorded with
um very famous you know he's recorded
with peter gabriel and paul mccartney
and various other musicians
and um then i met pam benicia who's very
quiet and she's although she's more
linguistically competent than her
brother
she doesn't talk to just anybody
and i didn't know how to break the ice i
knew that pampanisha liked dogs but not
cats and i knew that she had two sons so
i brought a picture of my dogs in a rich
picture of my sons um
and so i showed her a picture of my dogs
and there was nothing when she wants to
say no she just there's no response and
then i held up a picture of my kids from
when they were much younger
and they were all in a bubble bath
together and she
immediately punched babies washing
bubbles
in her in her computer and it was that
was the first moment of two-way
conversation that i'd had with an ape it
was just really mind-boggling
um what i didn't know at the time is
that
being a mother is the gets you instant
status and bonobo culture because they
the highest
uh
the highest infants are the highest on
the social hierarchy
but
so i spent i spent the day there and
they sort of dragged me out when they
when the scientists wanted to go home
and apparently the next day uh pam
benicia said
where's sarah build her nest when's she
coming back
and
so i want obviously i wanted to so i
sent them a fruit of the month club
i wanted them to remember me
so this particular family of apes is uh
is what the apes in my book um
are uh
are based on
and
i'm trying to sum it up quickly because
authors are notoriously bad at summing
up their own work
but
i guess i could say it's a family of
language competent apes who are torn
from their home under mysterious
circumstances and then resurface several
months later
under equally mysterious circumstances
in a reality tv show situation
recently i had a chance to go back and
visit
and
it was a very different visit because of
the fruit of the month club they
actually remembered me
and so i had many many more
conversations with them and they were
you know not shy at all and in fact when
i got there they said well if you're
really lucky you can go for a walk in
the forest with pam benicia and i just
thought that wow and
but then by the next morning cambodia
had changed her mind and we were to have
a tea party in the forest
and so and so the other apes heard this
and they got jealous and they were they
said well if she's gonna have a teapot
party with sarah then later on she has
to have a tea party with us in the green
tunnel and there was all this you could
hear all these this this uh yipping and
squeaking and peeping going on through
the building as they were communicating
and communicating this to the to the
scientists and discussing amongst
themselves where this was all going to
happen
meanwhile pambinesha heard that i was
having my makeup done
and decided she had and they gave her
makeup and she realized that somebody
else was doing mine so she wanted
someone else to do hers and so at one
point she ended up with very
artistically self-applied uh purple
lipstick
and powdered cheeks and um her makeup
job on on dr sue was was not as
wonderful
she removed it right away because it was
in red and we thought that might give
the wrong idea in photographs
sort of a slasher film thing
but so we went out it took a long time
to get to the forest and i realized
later i found out what had happened is
that the people had set up the tea party
and pam benicia got upset and made them
take it down because she wanted to set
it up and she has her own kitchen and
she has a gas range and so she made the
tea
she chose earl grey for me and
blackberry for herself
and she spread out the blankets and she
knew i was coming so she'd been saving
cookies for a week
and
she put out the cookies on the plates
and
we were using fine bone china and she
poured she poured the tea and then she
asked me very politely if i wanted to
milk
and i said sure i'll have milk and i put
some milk in it and this is where it got
sort of very bi-cultural by species so
then she asked for the milk back and
went glug and just slammed it and it was
gone
and
this this was a tuesday and the bonobos
have been declared overweight so they
have diets on tuesdays and thursdays
so pam benicia then told me i should try
the candied ginger
and dip it in my tea and so i did and
then she told me the other cookie i
should eat and so i did and then she
asked me politely for my cookies and
just tipped the plate back and ate all
the cookies
and then
then she just she thought about that for
a while and i guess she thought that
that wasn't fair so she went off into
the forest
and she brought me a branch and gave it
to me sort of ceremoniously in the it's
i guess it's called brows um
i watched one of the scientists eat a
leaf hoped that she hadn't faked it
because to me i was
taking her word for it that it wasn't
poisonous and so i sat and politely ate
my
my brows
which would have been much improved with
some olive oil
um
but then another amazing
sort of
linguistically important thing was the
way that pam benicia segued this she
looked at me and she said
using her board
sarah did you eat eggs today
and her favorite food is hard-boiled
eggs and i said no i didn't but i did
yesterday
and she said
the bunny came last week and hit eggs in
the forest
and she looked sort of pensively up and
thought said
i wish the bunny would come back
and in the background i see guys on
walkie-talkies and
five minutes later the easter bunny
comes traipsing out of the trust with a
basket of hard-boiled eggs
and so the the bunny showed us what was
in the basket and and pambinesha was
visibly excited because hard-boiled eggs
are her favorite food and so
um
then sue the the head scientist asked
pam benicia pemisha kept trying to get
up and go and look for the eggs
and um and sue said no and then she said
would it be do you think do you think
sarah would be good if we sent her to
get an egg
and pampanicia thought about it
and i was thinking oh no i'm being set
up for failure here but she said yes and
then sue said so you think if she finds
an egg she'll give it to you and not eat
it herself
and pam benicia said yes
so sarah can go get an egg yes so off i
went into the forest to get an egg
um and i came back and
she ate it very happily and at one point
she noticed that i had a bruise on my
leg
and she got very concerned and she was
asking me how i got hurt and i just i
have a 107 pound lap dog which is how i
end up with bruised legs but um so i
explained to her that i was okay and
everything but she really really wanted
to groom me and she was very concerned
about this
and um
then i got
i spent some more time with the other
apes but we never got around to the tea
party
and the apes were upset about this
and so i was at an off-site interview
the day before i was supposed to leave
and
15 minutes to the well quarter to five
we got a phone call from the trust
saying that one of the apes was refusing
to eat until i came back
and she was holding to her word so they
said well what time is your flight
tomorrow
and so i got up early and i really don't
do mornings but for the bonobos i do
mornings
and i got up early and i went back to
the trust i stopped at starbucks i got
them all at starbucks and um
and i brought them each a coffee and an
apple
and i went through and talked to each
ape separately and explained to them
that i had to go home to my own nest and
my own family but i would come back and
visit soon and the very last thing i did
was have breakfast with pam benicia
and it was just the two of us and we
were lying on blankets
eating our apples completely silently
and it was
it was in this moment
of silence where there was was no need
for words that i'd
that i really realized just
how very similar we are
and um
and that's what i hope i hope will come
out of this book
that's it thank you bye my book
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it really is an amazing book and
especially i i wanted to mention you
when you showed up with a backpack full
of the stuff that you knew they would
like so they would let you in i just
remember when i was at the sundance film
festival a few years ago and i walked
into some gifting suite and they were
frantically
trying to get like the right kinds of
shoes and vodka and fragrances out on
the tables so that paris hilton would
show up like they had to make sure to
get her favorite things and i realized
oh it's just a backpack for a happy ape
that's all it really is they just get
her m ms and her bouncy ball and maybe
she'll show up and we'll get a picture
that nice
and she worked with a nice little keypad
too she was like you know vodka give me
it was it was really it was really
touching it was really touching
but then they tracked her and it was it
got really ugly so
um our last uh writer of the day uh
i really need some introduction this guy
uh
coined the term cyberspace
right out of the gate and then he kept
uh a lot of people wouldn't be able to
uh follow that and he just kept
expanding and deepening this amazing
dark
universe that he kind of uh lives in he
uh people also don't know he coined the
term bootylicious
and
wessonality and he does god not get
credit for those and i think that's
wrong i think that's very wrong um
ladies and gentlemen uh the reason your
kids are looking at a blackberry and
texting and not talking to you
mr william gibson william gibson ladies
and gentlemen
here we come
[Music]
okay well
say it's midway through the final year
of the first decade of the 21st century
and say that last week
two things happened
scientists in china announced successful
quantum teleportation
over a distance of about 10 miles
while other scientists in maryland
announced the creation
of an artificial
self-replicating
genome
now in in
this particular version of the 21st
century
which happens to be the one we're all
in today
neither of these things attracted as
much attention as the final episode of
lost
now you know
with quantum teleportation there's no
actual
matter transferred
but information is con conveyed across
distance without resorting to a signal
in any traditional sense
so it's not really teleportation but
still
it's the word
teleportation used seriously in a
headline
and so i you know i'm reading this and
saying no kidding teleportation
but you know i only really felt a slight
amazement
and that synthetic genome in maryland
which is arguably artificial life
that felt less amazing
it's the sort of thing
one feels might already have been
achieved somehow or
was that in the movie
but it's artificial life in maryland
but those artificial life sciences
scientists also inserted a line of james
joyce's prose into their genome
and that
triggers you know that the sense of the
surreal for me
even though they did it for a really
practical reason they did it to
incorporate a yardstick
a measure for the ongoing rate of random
mutation
so right this minute quite literally a
short length of james joyce's prose is
being very slowly pummeled into
incoherence by cosmic rays
but when i found myself confronted with
these two pieces of more or less
simultaneous
news
my imagination which grew up on
countless popular images of exactly this
sort of thing
could only produce a tabloid headline
synthetic bacteria in quantum free space
teleportation shocker
when i was when i was a boy alvin
toffler warned us about future shock
so is is this future fatigue
and for the past decade or so the only
critics of science fiction i pay any
attention to all three of them have been
slightly declaring that the future is
over
now i wouldn't blame anyone on first
hearing that for assuming that it's akin
to premature declarations that history
itself is over
but
really i think they're talking about the
capital f
future
which in my lifetime has been a cult
if not a religion
people my age are products of the
culture of the capital f future
the younger you are today the less
you're a product of that if you're 15 or
so
in 2010
you inhabit a sort of endless digital
now
a state of a-temporality
enabled by our increasingly efficient
communal prosthetic memory
but you probably don't know it because
as anthropologists tell us we have a
very hard time comprehending our own
culture
the future
the argument goes capital f be it
crystalline city on the hill or
radioactive post nuclear wasteland
is gone
up ahead of us
now there is merely more
stuff
events
some tending to the crystalline some to
the wastelandi stuff
the mixed bag of the ongoing quotidian
now please don't mistake this for one of
those after us the deluge moments
on my part i've always found those
appalling and most particularly when
uttered by aging futurists who of all
people should know better
this newfound state of no future is in
my opinion a very good thing
it indicates a new kind of cultural
maturity an understanding that every
future is someone else's past
every present someone else's future
upon arriving in the capitalized future
we discover it invariably to be the
lower case now
the best science fiction has always
known that but it was a sort of cultural
secret
when i began to write fiction at the
very end of the 70s i was fortunate to
have learned as an undergraduate that
imaginary futures are always
regardless of what their authors might
have believed about the day in which
they're written
orwell knew it writing 1984 and 1948
i knew it writing my own first novel
which was published in 1984.
neuromancer that novel though it's
careful never to admit it is set in the
2030s
when there's something like the internet
called cyberspace and a complete absence
of cell phones
which i'm sure young readers assume must
be a key plot point
more accurately there's something like
cyberspace but it's called cyberspace
though i know that's confusing
i followed neuromancer with two more
novels said in that particular future
but by then i was growing frustrated
with a capitalized future to me those
books were actually about using the tool
kit of science fiction to discover what
i could about the 1980s
so i wrote a novel called virtual light
which was set in 2006
which was then the very near future and
followed it up with two more novels each
set a few imaginary years later and what
was really my take on the 1990s
but it didn't seem to make any
difference in how i was generally read
lots of people assumed i was still
writing about the capitalized future i
began to tell interviewers somewhat
testily that i believed i could write a
novel set in the present our present
then which would have exactly the affect
of my supposed imaginary futures
hadn't j.g bellard declared earth to be
the alien planet
wasn't the future now
so i did in 2001 i wrote a book called
pattern recognition my seventh novel
given the events of 2001 i quickly found
the material of the actual 21st century
to be richer stranger more multiplex
than any imaginary future
but still imminently susceptible it
seemed to me to being unpacked with the
toolkit of science fiction complete with
a work a day level of cognitive
dissonance we now take utterly for
granted
zero history my ninth novel will be
published this september rounding out
that third set of three books
it said in london and paris last year in
the wake of our global financial crisis
i wish i wish i could tell you what it's
about but i haven't yet discovered my
best likely story about that
that will come with reviews audience and
bookseller feedback
and booksellers are especially helpful
in that way
along with however many interviews these
things will serve as a sort of oracle
suggesting to me
what it is i've been doing for the past
couple of years
if pattern recognition was about the
immediate psychic aftermath of 9 11 and
spook country about the deep end of the
bush administration and the invasion of
iraq
i could say that zero history is about
the global financial crisis as some sort
of nodal event
but that must be true of any 2010 novel
with ambitions on the 2010 zeitgeist
but all three of these novels are also
about that dawning recognition that the
future be it capital t tomorrow or just
tomorrow friday just means more stuff
however peculiar and unexpected a new
quotidian
somebody's future somebody else's past
but simply in terms of ingredients
it's about recent trends and the
evolution of the psychology of luxury
goods
crooked former special forces officers
corrupt military contractors the
wonderfully bizarre symbiotic
relationship between designers of
high-end snowboarding gear and
manufacturers of military clothing and
the increasingly virtual nature of the
global market
and i called it zero history because one
of the characters has had a decade go
missing 10 years in which he paid no
taxes and had no credit cards
he meets a u.s federal agent who tells
him that that combination indicates to
her that he hasn't been up to much good
the past 10 years
but that quotidian now finds him events
find him and he starts to acquire a
history and one assumes a credit rating
and the need to pay taxes
and it's also the first book i've
written in which anyone gets engaged to
be married
now a book
exists at the intersection of the
author's subconscious and the reader's
response
an author's career exists in the same
way a writer worries away at a jumble of
thoughts
building them into a device that
communicates but the writer doesn't know
what's been communicated until it's
finally possible to see it communicated
and after 30 years a writer looks back
and sees a career of a certain shape
utterly unanticipated
more stuff
and it's a mysterious business the
writing of fiction and i thank you all
for making it possible
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was william gibson ladies and
gentlemen
or was it
[Applause]
uh i have a copy of uh zero history i
have not read it yet i cannot wait to uh
read it i'm going to the sasquatch music
festival this weekend in gorge
washington i'm going to walk around with
an advanced copy of william gibson's
latest book that always brings out the
good mushrooms so i'm very
very excited um guys thank you so so
much for coming uh to this luncheon i'm
very excited to be as soon to be
published author i'm sorry that i'm so
giddy and uh
um just not glib about it it's a big big
deal for me but uh another round of
applause for all the uh tweets on book
tv's in depth live sunday at noon
eastern on c-span 2.
book tv is asking what are you reading
christopher hitchens what are you
reading right now
i'm reading
well partly to review it but now i'm
just reading it because it's such an
exciting book
a history of the dreyfus case
by an oxford woman professor of history
called um ruth lewis i think sorry yes
it is that's
new to me
really wonderful re-examination of the
greatest frame up in history
and the revolutionary consequences that
it had for france
and then because i'm usually reading
something in the fiction line at the
same time
i'm reading a book by
an author called sebastian barry
a brilliant young irishman
and it's called a long long way
and it's about
it's a novel about the vicissitudes of
an irish
regiment on the western front in the
first world war
while they're fighting the germans under
the british flag but in the meantime
irishmen are fighting under the irish
flag against the british government back
in dublin
and so the the our civil war is also
beginning at the same time and they're
all very torn it's brilliantly done
for schedule information and
descriptions of our programs log on to
booktv.org
you can click on the viewer input tab
and email us tell us what you're reading
and what you think of our programs
hoover institution press is based in
stanford california and we're talking
with julie ruggiero.com
coming up a debate on atheism with
christopher hitchens author of god is
not great and david berlinsky author of
the devil's delusion this event was
hosted by the fixed point foundation in
birmingham alabama
good evening
i'm larry taunton executive director of
fixed point foundation and we welcome
you to tonight's debate
the resolution being debated this
evening is atheism poisons
everything now again this is the
resolution
this is the question being discussed it
is of course a play on the title to
christopher hitchens bestselling book
god is not great how religion poisons
everything arguing the affirmative of
the resolution is dr
david berlinsky a scientist professor of
mathematics and author of many books
most notably the devil's delusion
atheism and its scientific pretensions
which is available
in the lobby and afterwards there will
be a book signing so you'll have the
opportunity to meet
dr berlinsky arguing the negative
of the resolution is christopher
hitchens
journalist cultural critic and
best-selling author and most recently he
is the author of the memoir
hitch 22 this is also a bestseller it's
also available in the lobby and you will
have the same opportunity to meet uh
christopher hitchens and to have your
book signed by him now just a bit
about the format for tonight's
debate first of all there will be
12-minute
opening statements by each of these men
dr bolinsky will be the first to speak
and then of course christopher hitchens
then we will have a rebuttal
of six minutes each and then a speaker
recap that is to say some some
final remarks for that portion of the
debate three minutes each now i will be
time keeping as we as we move along and
i'm asking these gentlemen not to
trample those
those time limits and then we will move
into a question and answer time i have
some questions here which have been
submitted and i will read them to the
two of them and then i will signal them
at the end
when they have received their last
question that they should then
give some sort of closing statement and
since
dr balinsky is going first he will have
the opportunity
to go last so
that being the case we we will now begin
our debate
and uh dr david balinsky please open for
us
thank you all very much for being here
i would like to thank larry taunton and
the fixed point foundation for their
outstanding hospitality
and
to christopher christopher hitchens
landsman
my pleasure being allowed to bask in the
radiance of his reputation
and lachaim
the proposition before us is atheism
poisons everything ladies and gentlemen
i'm perfectly aware and you should be
too
that that proposition is fully
compatible with the proposition that
religion poisons something
were christopher hitchens and richard
dawkins tomorrow to announce that they
were prepared to invade hell
in order to roust a variety of
pederastic priests
i would wish them well although for
reasons of personal inconvenience i
could not join them
in some respects as dr johnson once said
the proposition that atheism
poisons everything
hardly requires a defense the inquiry is
not needed he said
the last date at which atheism was a
possibility in social thought was also
the last date in which it was a
plausibility in social thought i ask you
to cast your mind back oh around 1790
1791 in france paris in front of the
cathedral of notre dame
and standing there somewhat elaborated
by my historical imagination is
robespierre reed thin narrow green eyed
fanatical rabbit as a bat
and danton large boisterous remarkably
eloquent and they're watching or they're
looking at notre dame and one guy says
to the other what should we do with this
pile of gothic junk
and the answer is let's rename it
good idea what should we call it each
man was hoping they would call it after
themselves but that was not to be
in robespierre robespia came up with a
wonderful idea we'll call it the temple
of reason
good thinking his companion said the
temple of reason that works splendidly
it means nothing but it works splendidly
we might as well have called it the
temple of evidence
temple of rationality what should we do
next was the question
and the inevitable answer the answer
known from historical circumstances well
let's go out and kill a whole lot of
people and that's exactly what they did
once they had renamed notre dame the
temple of reason
it was relatively easy to go out and
kill 50 000 innocent men women and
children
that i submit to you is the nature of
the proposition we are discussing
1851
60 or 70 years later
an age of remarkable progress
enlightenment
wonderful sense of dawning material
possibility matthew arnold in a poem
entitled dover beach
reflected on the decline of religious
faith in europe
the melancholy long withdrawing raw
he didn't see anything particularly
optimistic in that withdrawal
and he could think to say to himself and
to his readers only this
only this
ah my beloved let us be true to one
another
my beloved true to one another
for the world which lies about us like a
land of dreams so various so beautiful
so new
hath neither really joy
nor light nor love nor certitude nor
peace nor help for pain and we are
caught as on a darkling plain
swept by confused alarms of struggle and
flight
where ignorant armies clash by night
this is the prophetic declaration from
the heart of the progressive enlightened
19th century
in 1914 surveying the carnage that was
to come the foreign secretary of great
britain said again prophetically
the lights are going out all over europe
the lights what a strange word
we shall not see them lit again in our
time
ladies and gentlemen i submit to you
that the 20th century was a record
in germany in russia in china and
cambodia and elsewhere
not only of remarkable stupidity
brutality and violence but of
unparalleled
brutality stupidity and violent violence
and each of the regimes
each of the regimes behind
this
remarkable decay of civilization
had two features in common two
characteristics we should bear in mind
in the first place
the men guiding these regimes
and their entourage
did not believe for a moment there was
any power higher than their own
and they acted on that assumption
and in the second place
in the mass murders they conducted they
were aided and supported by any number
of crackpot scientific disciplines
that makes for a character
characteristic combination in the case
of the nazis the scientific disciplines
were derived from biology and especially
from darwinian biology
in 1937 having murdered 70 000
handicapped men women and children the
nazis released a film and on the
background of the film the narrator says
in terms of solomon comprehension
my goodness we have sinned against the
law of natural selection
the law of natural selection
what could that mean we have sinned
against the law of natural selection
the communists of course had an equally
crackpot theory that they derived from
marxian economics
the two cracked potteries joining in one
deeply repugnant stream
as all of you know
atheism today is not simply the private
doctrine of a handful of individuals
become a social movement and as a social
movement it has been advanced chiefly by
the scientific community certainly in
the united states but to a large extent
in europe too
some of this is adventitious a few
popular writers such as richard dawkins
discovered that by writing books
indicating that science has shown that
god does not exist
well they could make a fortune
i'm very sorry i wasn't there to join
them i didn't think of it at the time
i'm quite sure that someone now is
writing a book
how margarine science shows that god
does not exist
but the inevitable consequences
of this degree of atheism within the
scientific community
has involved a deformation of scientific
thought
quite striking in its character and its
extent
after all the sciences if we restrict
our attention to the serious sciences
and those may be found in mathematics or
in mathematical physics in no other
place
then we must recognize that the serious
sciences have nothing to say about the
existence of god either in their
premises or in their conclusion what a
remarkable fact people are writing books
how physics shows that god does not
exist but physics has nothing to say
about the existence of god
the aching questions that trouble the
human imagination
about which the science is one seriously
considered
are resolutely silent
these remain just where they were
and the religious tradition especially
the judeo-christian religious tradition
has offered a coherent body of belief
and doctrine by which they can be
explained do we understand why the
universe arose 14 million no we don't do
we understand why it's there at all no
we have no idea
do we understand how life emerged on
earth not a prayer right now
do we understand the complexity of life
we can't even begin to describe a living
creature in anything resembling precise
terms
recent article in science digest cell
division requires 4 000 coordinated
proteins acting together what a
remarkable statement what a wealth of
information we possess about biology
what an abundant lack of understanding
we have about living systems do we
understand why the laws of nature are
true no we have no idea do we understand
the miracle of analytic continuation in
physics when certain kinds of functions
can be pushed forward into the future
contrary to all experience
do we understand why the universe
remains stable from moment to moment the
medievals pondered this question ladies
and gentlemen and they came to the
conclusion
and i quote a medieval theology theo
theologian that god is everywhere
conserving the world what a remarkable
declaration can we do without it
can we do without it do we have an
explanation for the continuity and
stability of the universe there is one
paper that i know in the literature by
freeman dyson
that addresses the stability of matter
but beyond that everything is enigmatic
how can we propose seriously and
solemnly to rule out of court in advance
a hypothesis that not only answers to
the human heart in many respects
but that answers to genuine intellectual
needs in other respects
when one sees the american scientific
community like a herd of wildebeests
trotting across a fruited plain it's
very reasonable to ask are they going
someplace are they fleeing from some
place and i think the overwhelmingly
obvious answer is they are fleeing they
are fleeing from an idea that they
reject for a variety of reasons
not only is the inquiry about atheism
not necessary in terms of the history of
social thought it's not necessary in
terms
of the outlines of scientific thought
but there is a last question to be
addressed perhaps the most important for
you and me
the cosmologist joel primack asked an
interesting question he asked what
compels the electron to follow the laws
of nature good question i don't know
but heinrich himmler who had presided
over the destruction of churches and
synagogues throughout europe
and was the mastermind behind the
extermination of the jewish people
asked a very similar question in 1944
when confronted with the onerous treaty
obligations the german state had adopted
with respect to its own say traps
he asked insouciantly but pregnantly
after all what compels us to keep our
promises
moral relativism is very often
derided as a
unhappy consequence of atheism i don't
think moral relativism is a particularly
deep issue but i do think the issue
i do think the issue
of what compels us to keep our promises
is very relevant
i had in front of in front of me rather
a remarkable button
if you should press it
if you should press it
yours would be untold riches and
whatever else you desire
the only consequence to pressing it
beyond your happiness is the death of an
anonymous chinese peasant
who among us
would you trust with this button
sit still christopher
thank you
[Applause]
can you give me three minutes not 30
seconds
can you give me three minutes
thank you professor bolinsky um thank
you larry for the very generous
introduction thank you
ladies and gentlemen for coming
um
at short notice i can only hope to match
the parisian urbanity
of my rival in knowledge of
french ecclesiastical architecture and
its
cosmic implications and in modern
and in the
ready access to modern uh 20th century
poetry will
let's take instead of
notre dame and the famous story of its
deconsecration by guantanamo
the erection of the other most prominent
eglise of paris the one that you see on
your way in from the airport
the grand wedding cake style erection of
sacre cur the sacred heart
built on top of the commanding heights
of montmartre built y
built to celebrate the massacre of
parisian workers and intellectuals
after the paris commune of 1871 had
tried to save the honor of a humiliated
france
that had thrown itself officially
and was thrashing at the feet of
bismarck
and his prussian invaders many many more
people were killed
in that massacre in that terrible
reprisal that were killed in the whole
of the terror but it was and it wasn't
enough
but that was the case but a whole church
had to be consecrated by
the french
religious and clerical establishment and
their political allies to celebrate
the massacre of their fellow country and
does this prove that religion poisons
everything by no means does it do so
does it help to curtain raise and to
understand the terrible century
which professor bolinsky and i have both
studied
yes to a degree it does
this french right wing clerical right
wing goes on to the terrible arraignment
and frame up of captain
alfred dreyfus possibly the most serious
miscarriage of justice in the most
thorough most thorough goingly justified
and advanced
uh by political establishment in modern
european history this and the sides
taken in it
determine who will be who in the
terrible war of 1914
which dermond mccullough admired by
larry taunton among others as a
historian of christianity and very much
venerated by me
in his magnificent
history new history of the first two
thousand years
of christianity
describes as a theocratic war says the
christendom as we used to understand it
as our fathers and grandfathers used to
understand it ends in 1914 when every
country in europe goes to war in the
name of its own god or church
king george vi is the king emperor and
the head
of the church of england
the tsar of russia is the head of the
russian orthodox church is considered
not to be a god but a little more than a
human being you know the rest of it it's
the first time that got me uns is put on
the belt buckles but not the last time
of the german army and this is the end
of christendom and the curtain raiser
to fascism
without that terrible war of christendom
it's impossible that the totalitarian
movements that became such a threat to
civilization could have arisen in the
first place and just to stay with france
it is the vichy collaborationist regime
the rounder up of france's jews
the massacre
the massacre agent in the french
colonies the collaborator with the third
reich
that strikes from the french coinage the
noble words liberty
liberte galite fraternity and replaces
them with the catholic slogan family
patri
travail and under this france fell
to the lowest point of its history so i
would be aware sir
of uh deriving your argument about
atheism from the coincidences of french
ecclesiastical
uh design but
i'm with you on
the larger point that you made and i'll
also try and illustrate it from the work
actually of a great
anglo-catholic anglo-american poet
thomas stern's earlier to in his courses
from the rock asks the question
where is the knowledge we have lost
in information
this question has to preoccupy us all
when i am told
and i suppose in one way you could
accuse me of taking it on faith because
i couldn't prove it for myself
and having had it demonstrated to me i
probably couldn't repeat the
demonstration
but having been told by stephen hawking
and lawrence krauss and all the leaders
in the field of physics that we now
estimate
a total of 400 billion
galaxies
that's not universes or solar systems
like 400 million galaxies
and asked to decide the question
with one sun
every second since the big bang or one
star we only call our own star the sun
in an apro tropic propitiating way that
comes from
our terrorized ancestors a star that
size goes out
every second
so that's quite a lot while i'm talking
and has been blowing up and going out
ever since the first moment of the big
bang
this is more than we can handle we
cannot say we know
about this
it can be argued that all that was
indeed set in motion with the intention
of producing
on a very small planet
in a very small solar system
in a tiny neglected suburb of a
relatively
unimportant galaxy
a race of beings primate but capable of
language and reason
who believe that if they make the right
propitiations they will live forever
you could say
that all that gigantic explosion and
destruction was designed with that in
mind
but i wouldn't be able to take your word
for it
and it seems to me that the burden is
not
on me
i don't have to prove that kind of thing
i don't make the equivalent claim
that the religious person has to make
the religious person doesn't have to
just say of course god wanted it that
way and that's the way it is
because a design of that kind doesn't
just imply a designer
it implicates a designer
it means if there is such a designer
he's fantastically destructive and
wasteful
as he is in microcosm
99.8 percent of all species ever on this
earth have already become extinct this
is a pictureless wasteful capricious
design i can't prove that that isn't the
way he wanted it to be
but i can say that there's an
implication
for the designer but again it's not me
who's saying that if you believe in it
you have the means of grace
and the hope of glory and the
possibility of redemption and vicarious
salvation and forgiveness of sins
through human sacrifice and eternal life
we can't attempt and don't try anything
like that so the eighth the the excuse
me the agnostic or the deist is not
arbitrating between equal kinds of
certainty
those who are certain in the face of all
this uncertainty and unknowability the
strongest ground of agreement between me
and david
are bound to say if they're arbitrating
it properly the first people to leave
the island are the ones who say they
already know enough
that they know why this is happening
that they know the mind of god those who
claim the certainty are out of the
argument the argument then goes on
between dears agnostics and atheists how
can we make sense
of what we know
and how can we in doing so be true to
the great principle adam rated by
socrates which is this
you must educate yourself by striving
constantly
excuse me
as hard as you can to get to the point
of understanding your own ignorance only
then can you claim
to have any acquaintance with knowledge
at all
that's the appropriate and due modesty
that the founder of our school
of thought brought to the question and
there's no proof
that socrates ever existed i tend to
think from the eyewitness accounts and
second-hand ones that he did
it would be quite hard to confess such a
personality but it doesn't matter to me
whether he existed or not we have the
method he taught us how to think
if i was to tell larry after our drive
down through shenandoah yesterday and
our joint reading of the first passages
of the gospel of saint john
that the jesus who is surreal to him
is in fact or could be proved to be only
a fictitious person
a mythical individual it would have to
ruin
comrade taunton's day
not just his day his life
it would extinguish his hope
is there not something slightly
fanatical
in placing such large claims remember
the size of the claims i'm i'm talking
about three minutes on such a slender
and narrow basis
now we'll get to the the we'll get to
the nazis in my rebuttal if that's all
right that won't take frightfully long
under the totalitarians
and we'll have to do can we be moral
without believing fantastic things that
won't take too long either
and we can we can uh uh
do a number of other things too that i
have so far left unaddressed but believe
me not forgotten
but i just wanted to see if i could
introduce just for once a new
element into this uh argument
you must when you next go to washington
go to the newest museum in the united
states it's the newly opened hall
of human origins in the smithsonian
museum of natural history
it's by the way paid for by mr coke
the former libertarian candidate for
president and
founder and uh pay master of the tea
party movement so i invite you to
join me once again in saying in some way
this really is a great country
uh
here is the greatest gallery paying
giving the proper account of evolution
and our true origins that has ever been
erected in any country
the bit that has fascinated me and taken
me back to it again and again is this
until 17 000 years ago only in one case
and not many more
years
than that
in others there were at least three
other
hominid or human species
primates like us with
large brain pans language capacity in
the case of the neanderthals very
significantly decorated graves which
suggests if it doesn't insist upon the
idea of a ritual
and a religion
they have genes in common with us they
are of our species
and they've left important traces they
weren't very well understood or in some
cases known at all the case of the
flores islanders of the indonesian el
capita only until very recently but
there they always were
they were our brothers and our sisters
and our kin
and they had all these yearnings and
hopes and terrors and fears
and they're not in genesis
and
they've had no one to visit their graves
or do them honor until very recently and
as a result of scientific innovation
and curiosity
and whatever gods they had abandoned
them
and so i just think it's worth brooding
since we talk about ourselves as the
objects of a tremendous
cosmic and biological process that was
set in motion
supervised and if it's to be believed
designed
intended
i just think we should take a moment of
silence and think
of our fellow humans our fellow
creatures the fellow extinct already
extinct members of our species
to whom we might spare
a little thought before we go on
i'm in your debt and i'll be back thanks
we now move to rebuttals
six minutes dr balinski thank you very
much
there's a disturbing area of agreement
that i sense between mr hitchens and
myself
which i will do my best to minimize
please remember ladies and gentlemen
that when it comes to the wickedness of
religion i have ceded the point it's no
longer argumentative
i would remind you however
of remark dr johnson made he made it
about original sin
and i paraphrased him he said the
inquiry is not necessary
for all the laws of heaven
and earth
are unable to prevent men from their
crimes
now mr hitchens is very much in the
position of someone watching
a [ __ ] walking painfully with two
crutches
moving arduously
and saying to himself and saying to you
i've got a great idea kick one of the
crutches away everything will be so much
better
that seems to me a weak argument
a weak argument not an impossible
argument i would welcome
the defense of the argument but it is no
rebuttal to my position that atheism
poisons everything that religions poison
something there are plenty of poisons in
the world we don't lack an abundance
second point i would like to mention is
this strange
enchantment with the views of say
lawrence krauss or stephen hawking you
know stephen hawking just published a
book
and i don't know whether any of you have
yet seen it it is again a book
explaining how everything began why it's
there why we shouldn't worry about god
and a multitude of other subjects he
published it in collaboration with a
friend of mine leonard milano
and of course the lines are
very deep
in the bookstores
and to paraphrase the claim that he now
makes having given up
a through n he now champions something
called m theory
the claim that he now makes is the
universe just blasted itself into
existence following the laws of m theory
the universe just blasted itself into
existence following the laws of m theory
i don't deny what stephen hawking has
said i do not endorse it i haven't read
the book although i've read his other
books i respect hawking as a reputable
physicist who did his great work 30 or
40 years ago
but i can tell you this what is
lamentably lacking
in every one of these discussions is
that corresponding spirit of skepticism
which are christopher hitchens or
richard dawkins or
vic stengel will bring to religious
claims and that lapses absurdly when it
comes to scientific claims
surely we should have the sophistication
to wonder at any any as separation of
the form that the universe just blasted
itself into existence following the laws
of m theory a theory that no one can
understand whose mathematical formalism
hasn't been completed which has never
never once been tested in any laboratory
on the face of the earth
third and final point of rebuttal
the fact that the earth our home is a
small part of the physical universe does
not mean it does not mean it is not the
center of the universe that is a
non-sequitur
after all no one would argue least of
all mr hitchens that the doctrine at
home is where the heart lies
is rendered false by distance
we should be very careful about making
these claims i agree the universe is
very big lots of galaxies amazing things
and there is certainly some point of
continuity between human beings and the
animals that went before
but as for the central religious claim
that this particular place is blessed
and important that's quite different
no doctrine about physical size rebuts
it thanks very much
[Applause]
how much yeah i want them all yeah
i wouldn't
um
i
swore to answer
press belinski's two points about
totalitarianism and atheism
um
well here's one point and i've had one
to make perhaps i'll make it in preface
uh atheism by itself is of course not a
moral position or a political one of any
kind
it simply is the refusal to believe in a
supernatural dimension
or a supernatural supervisor or dictator
and it's it's the maintenance of the
view that though that cannot be
disproved
no good evidence has ever been induced
for it or any good argument put forward
for it
but that's where it ends
you can be an atheist and a nihilist you
can be an atheist and a sadist
you can be an atheist and say as is said
in dostoevsky's famous passage of
brothers karamazov without god
anything is possible anything is doable
is thinkable
of course that's open i would say
immediately to the objection that anyone
who says they have god on their side
also awards themselves and you can see
it happening by opening the newspaper
the right to commit any crime however
ghastly
that there's no escape from
the existence of certain psychopathic
human beings who either for want of
supervision or by invoking
the idea that they are the agents of a
divine supervisor will do anything at
all
that gets us no further forward you can
be an atheist and a fascist most
fascists were actually christian
you can be an atheist and a communist
most but not all communists were
unbelievers by definition you can be an
atheist and perfectly indifferent to the
to your fellow creatures but there is a
humanism within atheism
it starts i think with lucretius who put
the atomic theory of
democracy into a wonderful poem
that effectively suggested not that
people were using religion as a crutch
as you so
in such a domesticated and furry way put
it but that instead on on a very hot day
they were putting on a huge heavy
overcoat and dragging a ball and chain
oh dear my crops have failed i didn't
make enough sacrifices
oh god i've had a filthy thought now i'm
going to hell
um all my children are because i didn't
baptize them
man forged manacles of terror and
ignorance and stupidity the emancipation
of which
of our species has been
millimetrically slow but in which
materialist and atheist thinkers have
played a great part with our lucretius
you can you only have to read galileo's
work again he's inspired by the work of
lucretius he considers him considered
himself to be
very lucky to possess one of the very
few copies of lucretius's work that was
not destroyed
in the christian centuries
in the hope of putting an end to such
terrible
unwise speculations as that as so much
of galileo's work was either destroyed
or censored
on the slow the thread is passed on it's
picked up by the greatest jew
who ever breathed baroque spinoza
changing his name later after his
excommunication from the synagogue to
benedict
who said if there's a god he's
pantheistic he's in nature there's no
personal god
prayers are not answered divine
interventions do not occur the
consolations of philosophy must be
resorted to from him and
people like him we get the the
enlightenment in which not only downtown
and robespierre ladies and gentlemen
have their share
but thomas payne and thomas jefferson
and the founders of this
great republic and the philadelphia
enlightenment this is not a tradition of
which anyone on my side need be ashamed
and of course not all of it is atheist
some of it is deist
but it becomes more atheist as darwin
and einstein and others
approach us with their mind boggling
almost wants to say mind-altering
findings
and you perhaps will say it's a
coincidence
that einstein is expelled by the third
reich along with anyone else who
understood anything about biology or
physics as practitioners of jewish
science
i'm sorry the area of agreement has just
contracted sir
for you to save nazism that it was the
implementation of the work of charles
darwin as a filthy slander undeserving
of you and an insult to this audience
darwin's thought was not taught in
germany
darwinism was derided in germany along
with every other form
of unbelief the the
all the great modern atheist thinkers
darwin einstein
and freud were alike despised
by the national socialist regime
and there is it said i believe it to be
true a misprint in one german edition of
the origin of species from which the
false statement
that evolution requires the survival of
the fittest is taken or statement never
made by darwin who has
anyone knows
says that adaptability
is what is likeliest to give
survival or
luck or advantage we'd better say uh in
the struggle now
just to take the most notorious of the
20th century totalitarianism the most
finished example the most perfected one
the most ruthless and refined one that
of national socialism
the one that fortunately allowed the
escape of all these great atheist
thinkers and many others to the united
states country of separation of church
and state that gave them welcome
if it's a atheistic regime then how come
that in the first chapter of mine camp
hitler says he's doing god's work and
executing god's will
in destroying the jewish people
how come the fuhrer oath that every
officer of the party in the army had to
take
making hitler into a minor god begins i
swear in the name of almighty god my
loyalty to the fuhrer how come that on
the belt buckle of every nazi soldier it
says got me uns god on our side how come
that the first treaty made by the
national socialist dictatorship the very
first
is with the vatican
exchanging political control of germany
for catholic control of german education
how come that the churches celebrated
the birthday of the fuhrer every day
every year i mean on that day until
democracy put an end to this filthy
quasi-religious superstitious barbarous
reactionary system again this is not a
difference of emphasis between us to
suggest
that there's something fascistic about
me
and my beliefs is something i won't hear
said and you shouldn't believe thank you
dr balinsky your recap you have three
minutes
thank you
i've endeavoured to assert the following
proposition first the general
proposition that atheism poisons
everything
and second
the ancillary proposition that for sure
religion poisoned something
these propositions are not in conflict
and at the beginning of the discussion
i said they were conflict
so as separations to the contrary
introduced into this discussion neither
interesting evidence
nor a valid argument
in terms of the social history of
atheism
it seems to me when i began this debate
and still seems to me now
overwhelmingly clear that while
nazism in germany communism in russia
communism in china even
communism in cambodia certainly had
religious elements who would deny that
why is that an interesting claim
the governing apparatus of ideology no
matter what hitler had to say
about his devotion to a warrior like
christ
involved the proposition
among those who ruled these states and
their entourage
that no power
no power was greater than their own
they acted on that proposition they were
restrained by nothing and we saw the
consequences
now you may say and perhaps say truly
that in their heart of hearts some
catholics
adopted the rituals of the ss and took
communion after an especially arduous
day murdering innocent women in the
fields of poland could be true i don't
deny it
but we must ask ourselves if this is to
be an intellectually serious discussion
is not whether there were infiltrations
of religious thought in the worst
tyrannies of mankind of course there
were
that goes without saying
but whether something fundamental had
changed in the dire pacing of thought
that made these atrocities possible and
i say yes there was
i've argued as well
that atheism as a position has a
deforming influence on science and i've
given you my reasons
finally i have argued that atheism
insofar as it removes from the human
context
a brute sense of obligation based on
fear
a brute sense of obligation based on
fear
removes from the moral calculus
profound and powerful reason
not to do evil
i think there's no escaping this it's
unpleasant i don't particularly like it
and to be perfectly honest i haven't
lived my life that way but i recognize
it as a fact
and i think we all must
with that said i thank you for listening
well i think perhaps i can help close
the
the gap a little the gap that
professor linsky complains of
in my in my closing remarks i came
across a straight uh comment by george
orwell whom
great admirer
in a in a little known essay recently
which he said
at root all totalitarianism must be
theocratic
and i thought of my most admired author
that's that's rather
stretching it and this it's certainly
possible to admire totalitarianism
to identify totalitarianisms
that are not explicitly uh religious
uh he went on to clarify it a bit he
said
the reason i say it's theocratic is this
in all such dictatorships there must be
certain
unchallengeable assumptions some things
that are beyond discussion
that are not available that for debate
that must be taken as statements of
faith in other words in initially for
example under fascism you'll do che
haciendi the leader is always right
um the of course the cult of the fuhrer
uh the view that stalin could bring two
or three crops a year was the great
protector of the people the worship of
mao
the to take the other great element of
the of the uh axis powers japan the
emperor was actually a god couldn't have
anything more theocratic
than that though he had secular
appearance as well
now if you think of totalitarian
totalitarianism in that way
and if you think of that as the greatest
poison since i'm accused not of
mentioning poison enough or stressing
enough
then you'll see that
the charge that is essentially
theocratic is true because it depends
upon unchargeable statements dogma
and faith
i don't know if anyone wants to named me
or whether
david will take up the challenge a
statement of atheism that is a statement
purely of faith
independent of evidence requiring no
reasoning and above all punishable if
challenged
i don't believe you can come up with
anything of the sort to the contrary
the little faction with which i'm
honored to be identified as a junior
member is
adamant for doubt
is resolved to be skeptical is certain
only of the principle of uncertainty
and says that what we have yet to know
is enormously greater than anything we
have discovered or known so far and that
that and only that
is the test of education of intellectual
integrity of honesty and inquiry and yes
let's hope for it the emancipation of
humans from from man-made and i stressed
man-made
delusions
including of uh hopeful ones including
false consolation
and
thus it thus again and i'll close by
repeating myself um
i've done worse
it is only those who claim to know
things like the mind of god
and the origins and destination and
intention of the universe it is they and
only they who are the explanation and so
far this evening haven't
cared to furnish it thank you
[Applause]
we now move to the question and answer
form of uh time of of this evening and
we begin with uh with christopher
hitchens and uh christopher your first
question uh what are the weaknesses of
pascal's wager
well sometimes known by the way is
pascal's gambit
which is i think a suggestive a coinage
for those of you who don't know
or who might be watching and for whom
this is new i'll just state it i hope
not too crudely
blaze pascal who was one of the founders
of probability theory and a great
mathematician
and great catholic apologist of the 17th
century
phrased it like this he was addressing
the people he called uh those who are so
made that they cannot believe that's me
for example
and he said well if you can't believe
think of it like this
if you bet
that making the right adjustments to
your relationship with god
uh will save you
in the future in the future state
and you're right you win a lot
if you're wrong what have you lost
what have you got to lose
now the reason why i say wager and
gambit are appropriate for this is it's
obviously a very huxter-ish claim or
offer i mean to say it's pretty cheap
and pretty vulgar and i would say
especially so when offered to people who
are dying or ill or frightened or in
extremis i think it's distinctly nasty
and sharp practice
to try it on them but i think it's
pretty sharp and nasty at any time and
you'll notice that it postulates and
here are its other weaknesses
two things one a very cynical and
gullible god
who will who will if i say to him tell
you what i'll give up the convictions of
a lifetime
fling myself at your feet pretend i
believe
hope you're impressed
would say yeah that's good that's
progress
in other words you get no reward for
intellectual consistency courage honesty
anything of that so and of course as
with all these human-made ideas of
divine tribunals no lawyers who
represent you no appeal and no
opportunity to produce any evidence
um i pass over that lightly and say what
does it ask also of the wage asks for
someone to be
a credulous cringing
unprincipled serf who says sure what are
principles for if not to be sold
in the hope of a future
boon well
those are the
the largest i think uh shortcomings of
pascalian and by implication all other
religious reasoning about the death
judgment and the other last things
thank you
[Applause]
dr balinsky what are the strengths of
pascal's wager
very good
uh christopher hitchens would you agree
with the following statement made by sam
harris and i quote
some propositions are so dangerous that
it may even be ethical to kill people
for believing them
uh
you you'd
you would be idle in dismissing it at
the first reading and obviously sam has
put it at its most blunt
but let me i'll give you a very
practical example of a current
theocratic dictatorship
we've all wondered
at least everyone of my age has since
they were small
what will happen the day that a really
nasty guy gets hold of a really bad
weapon that's how i thought about it
when i was seven
i would now say what happens when
a messianic regime lays hold of an
apocalyptic weapon well we're about to
find out
and the people who have
plagiarized the ingredients of this
weapon stolen it from piracy on the high
seas broken every international law
every agreement every treaty they've
ever signed with the un
the atomic energy authority eu and and
so forth
are governed by the totalitarian theory
called the velayatifaki the guardianship
of the jurist the supreme leader
notice that again another supreme leader
another divinely inspired dictator
whose word can't be challenged and who
wants to bring on
the end of days it's not the least of my
dislikes of religion that it has openly
or covertly an expressed wish a clear
one for the end of the world doesn't
like this world wants it to finish
people who want are in the process of
acquiring
the the secular weaponry with which to
bring about genocide
deserve i think to have their ideology
treated as toxic
and its characters as dangerous vermin
and as like pirates and terrorists
people who it is lawful to destroy
yes so to that extent i'm with sam sure
dr
uh you're not a christian and indeed
you're uh you're not religious as uh as
i understand it
why do you argue for the influence of uh
of christianity or a judeo-christian
influence in society
i presume you're not asking that in the
hopes of a personal declaration i mean i
argue for a great many things and my
personal involvement and topics for
debate is variable
this particular question
strikes me as more important and more
demanding of a personal involvement than
most
i think the issue is tremendously
significant i think if we're honest
about the times in which we live
it's quite right what matthew arnold
suggested
the sea of faith has been receding under
the power of a variety of forces
and the results have
in a certain way been catastrophic for
the human race
i should not say
that
a secular jew has
remarkable degree of authority when it
comes to discussing these events after
all i have lived my own life
under the impress of the maxim to have a
good time all the time but on the other
hand
it doesn't hurt to hear these words from
someone such as myself because at least
you are hearing
these words for someone with no
conceivable bias in their favor i count
myself as an objective observer of the
circumstances
so perhaps that's the only reasonable
answer i can give these are important
questions they've had horrific
consequences in human history they
continue to have horrific consequences
especially in
intellectual history
and
in response to why should it be that a
secular jew opens his mouth on questions
pertaining to the christian religion
10 seconds
it's a big tent
i'm presuming i will be welcomed
thank you
[Applause]
christopher hitchens
what specific teachings of jesus do you
believe to be evil or poisonous
um
the concept of vicarious redemption is
the most repulsive i think
and the most central i mean i could pick
a lot of peripheral
uh utterances of the nazarene or alleged
utterances of the nazarene but the the
inescapable one the one that none of his
followers troubles to deny that he is
the idea that by
throwing your sins onto somebody else
onto a scapegoat you can you can have
them annealed polished
that is a disgusting and immoral
doctrine
if uh i care for you enough
i can pay your debt even if you incurred
it out of your own stupid
irresponsibility i could if i wished
and it's been done offered to take your
place in prison though not many people
will allow the exchange or if you were
hostage i could do that if i loved you
enough and there are examples of people
willing to put themselves forward as the
uh substitute for someone's execution i
suppose sydney carton in a tale of two
cities is the best known folkloric one
but you cannot relieve people of their
responsibility
and it's immoral to offer to do so and
it would be disgusting if it could be
done so
the moral rot of christianity is i think
exposed in its central doctrine of
vicarious forgiveness it's a it's a
it's an abdication of moral
responsibility
i think the idea of taking no thought
for the morrow
of of the instructions are abandon your
family
if you don't you are one who hates me
give up investment thrift
any thought of a future
children
uh
architecture anything of the sort forget
all that
and follow me is moral only on one
condition
and it's the condition i referred to
before that the world is about to come
to an end
and that only those who stick by me
a familiar trope from deluded prophets
throughout the ages are going to get out
of it
again i would say a multiple multiple
wicked thing to be saying and offer
to be making we would be so much better
off without this cult we would think so
much more clearly about the real moral
questions that confront us
given this choice and no other
would you prefer a secular or an islamic
europe
what my dear sir makes you think it's a
choice right now
large portions of europe are already
islamic
i mean how would i adjust the european
continent
i have no opinion
why should i judge
the european continent as far as i can
tell having conducted a relationship
with the arab community for more than 11
years i have no objections to muslims in
europe
oh david do you mind if i reached um
convention
to
one degree in
cigarettes see why i think you could
have answered that better
sure i mean because it implied in what
in your view
that atheism poisons everything
is is it not and i think this was the
intention of the question anyway
that i'd be better off as a wahhabi
than i would as an atheist
now the what larry i think was trying to
ask you is do you seriously maintain any
such thing
you mean with respect to europe
would europe be better religious but
islamic or without god is that i think
the question is it not and i i
miniaturized it for myself
i i invite you to take another run at it
yeah
in fact
in fact
i strongly advise it and you can have it
out of my time this is a forced choice
which would you prefer an islamic europe
would you like to live in an islamic
europe or would you you do live in
europe or would you prefer to live in a
secular the trouble the trouble is the
question has no provocative urgency for
me
it has none whatsoever i mean it's like
asking which i would prefer to be
dressed in gold or in silver it's not a
living issue
christopher
do you believe that all this is by the
way is your last question so at the end
uh take uh take a extra minute or so
to summarize uh your arguments and to
make a final statement uh
do you believe
that all religions are equally poisonous
my beloved
younger daughter
today became a senior
at sidwell friends school in washington
so at least i know that she's under
serious police guard during the
day as its name implies this is a quaker
foundation where
if she hasn't understood the story of
frederick douglass and elizabeth cady
stanton and many other people by now
it's not for dint
excuse me not for want of trying
and so would i not be fatuous or
uh demagogic if i said that quakerism to
me is exactly the same as wahhabism or
twelver
uh the twelver shiite theory of the
village of like the kameni theory of
course not
but religions different ones do take
their turn at bat
i think uh to be to show how dangerous
the religious proposition is
quakers for example
uh expelled from their ranks those who
supported the american revolution
because they thought
that they'd taken an oath of loyalty and
that it was
it's all other principles and there had
to be another quaker
meeting set up in philadelphia people
had been chucked out
um betsy and episcopalian and so on the
more you look at some of these
supposedly innocuous sects you realize
they're only innocuous
because they've become so by having
their fangs drawn by
civil society over the years
when jefferson says to the baptists of
danbury connecticut don't worry you live
in a country that has a wall of
separation between church and state and
it will ever be thus
who can tell me actually i've got a
better chance in birmingham of getting
someone
who were the baptist of danbury
connecticut afraid of
oh come on
oh come on the congregation list one in
alabama
um
the congregationalists of danbury
connecticut thought that baptists
shouldn't be citizens
so i've only got a minute so
uh
just as i would have said for 50 years
ago the catholic church is by far the
most dangerous because of its open
soggy disgusting rotten alliance with
fascism which it didn't get over till
well after the second world war
obviously now islam which
had been going through a long period of
latency is by far the most dangerous
religion but yes
they all make the same mistake
they all take the only real faculty we
have that distinguishes us from other
primates and from other animals the
faculty of reason
and the willingness to take any risk
that reason demands of us
and they replace that with the idea that
faith
is a virtue if i could change just one
thing it would be to dissociate the idea
of faith from virtue
now and for good
and to expose it for what it is a
servile weakness a refuge in cowardice
and a willingness to follow with
credulity
people who are in the highest degree
unscrupulous thank you
your final question and uh at the end
you may summarize your arguments
what is one to make of the claim or
rather what do you make of the claim
that science
and christianity are in opposition to
one another
what am i to make of the claim that
science and christianity are in
opposition to one another
i would need to hear the claim
reticulated properly
to claim a point of opposition in
general seems to me unhelpful
to claim points of opposition in
particular
seems to be rather more reasonable
in its largest aspect
western science is of course an
outgrowth of the judeo-christian
tradition especially to the extent
perhaps only to the extent
that it is committed to the principle
that the universe the manifest universe
contains a latent structure
that can be discovered by the intellect
of man
i think this is true i don't think this
is very far from drawed manly hopkins
declaration that the world is charged
with the grandeur of god they represent
rather the same
position in the world of thought the
world is charged with the grandeur of
god therefore it can be rationally
comprehended
please notice
this is very different from a muslim
claim it's very different from the
islamic tradition in which god is
assigned rather a capricious role there
is a reason that muslim science so
second and glorious in the 10th 11th and
12th century did come to an end
unceremoniously
and it can be traced back to
muslim theological writings so yes i
would say
the judeo-christian tradition the
tradition of a revealed religion that is
revealed in nature but pointing to a
supernatural order
has been a powerful influence on the
development of western science one by
the way recognized by virtually every
significant scientist every single one
of them
what do i have next one minute for
closing remarks
i certainly have no objection to
repeating myself but whether you're
equally willing to hear myself repeat it
i don't know i've offered you three
considerations
i've listened very respectfully to what
mr hitchens has said and i have found
myself as he expected immeasurably
improved
however i have heard nothing that
discourages me or dissuades me from
affirming the propositions that i have
affirmed
the influence of atheism even though
religions have done dreadful things has
been
poisonous for at least 300 years and
especially poisonous in the 20th century
second atheism is a position in thought
a dogmatic position and thought and as a
separation that there is no god
has had a deforming influences on the
sciences because it leaves open
unanswered questions that press on the
human heart
and third that atheism inevitably in the
moral sphere
leaves us unanswered the question what
obliges us what forces us not what
persuades us what forces us
to behave as we should
thank you
[Applause]
i want to thank both of these gentlemen
for participating in this debate and
uh it seems appropriate at this time now
the debate is over to say a word about a
fixed point foundation fixed point
foundation is a christian organization
and unashamedly so though we do seek to
engage in the realm of ideas now some
would wonder why we would sponsor a
debate like this i mean as a christian
organization we have represented on the
state stage here
uh
neither of these men are are christians
well we think that these are these are
questions these are ideas that are
relevant
to everyone whether you're a christian
whether you're an atheist
agnostic or of some other religion now
that said
i want to be very honest and state that
our
our position our sympathy certainly lie
in the direction
that a
robust christian influence in society is
a as a good thing now christopher said
and it seems appropriate uh to me to
respond
uh to him that uh that it would that it
would ruin my life um if
it were if i were to learn that that
jesus christ was just a figment of my
imagination and millions indeed billions
of other people as well
to that i must confess that he is
correct
it would ruin my life
it really would because it would suggest
uh from our perspective that this uh
this life is in fact meaningless that
it's a that it's a hoax that it's a sham
that is that is our perspective
now
if you are interested
if you are interested
if you are interested in uh
knowing more about fixed point
foundation and certainly you can find
that about us on the web this particular
debate will be aired on c-span and i'm
not sure of the the dates or times of
that but i think it'll be aired a number
of uh of occasions so you can find it
there and you can certainly find it on
our website as well and we also want to
welcome somewhat belatedly 60 minutes
who is here and they are doing a piece
on christopher hitchens so please join
me and uh in thanking these men for
their participation this evening
christopher hitchens is a contributing
editor at vanity fair magazine david
berlinski is a former fellow at the
institute for applied system analysis
and the current senior fellow at the
discovery institute
the fixed point foundation hosted this
event
for more information visit fixed hyphen
point dot org
a new book out by bloomsbury publishing
blur
how to know what's true in the
[Music]
this week on q a our guest is
christopher hitchens contributing editor
to the atlantic monthly and columnist
for vanity fair
mr hitchens is the author of over a
dozen books his most recent is his
memoir hitch 22
last summer mr hitchens was diagnosed
with cancer
he joins us from his home in northwest
washington dc
christopher hitchens i just checked and
i've interviewed you 20 times since 1983
and i must say this is one of the
hardest
well because you haven't been well not
very no
what's the current status of your cancer
i have a tumor in my esophagus which has
some metastasizers they spread to my
lymph nodes
and i'm afraid that i'm not completely
sure to part of my lung
and it's at stage four and
the um thing to note about stage four is
there is no stage five
um
so it concentrates the mind a bit but i
i have some wonderful
oncologists working with me and
there are we're on the verge of a whole
number of new treatments some of which
may apply to me the chemotherapy is
holding it at bay
i apologize that my voice is a bit husky
today
um
but
that's the situation
um
so i
i have to practice staying alive and
preparing to die at the same time
which as my memoir says is actually what
one has to do all the time
as a matter of fact i mean you're never
more than a breath away
but it's a bit more vivid to me now
sort of doctors in the morning and
lawyers in the afternoon
why did you decide to
take us through that journey in your
writing in vanity fair well i was
wondering whether i wanted to or not and
to make i didn't want to make a parade
of my
condition
but i was very intelligently pressed to
do it by my editor grade and carter
apparently fair
um and i tried to do it in such a way as
it wasn't the parade of my feelings or
uh
a sort of yellow ribbon type journalism
um
and i've been told that some people have
been
comforted by it a bit identified with it
to some degree
um
if you have a lemon make lemonade would
be the other explanation better than
staring at the wall it is a great
subject
everyone has to do this
at one point or another
either survive or die of
um
something like this
it's one thing one is certainly born to
do
so
as an extension of the memoir i
published when i was hit with it
um i thought well
i should keep up the narrative because
this is very much a part of my life
how's your life and i should add because
of these experimental treatments i've
had my genome sequenced for example i'm
very unique in this way i'm very lucky
i'm able to write about some really
quite exciting new
developments in the field of oncology
which i hope will
surely become more available to more
people
it's a rather tantalizing time to have
cancer
this time for me someone of my age
because
there are treatments that i can see that
are just out of my reach probably
which is both encouraging and annoying
if you like and there are others that
are probably just within it
my constitution is very good all my
other vital signs are excellent
everything from my limit my blood
pressure is excellent superb in fact
unjustly so what am i
the fans would say but um if i can hang
on there are quite a few expedients i
can and intend to try
but you just had your gallbladder out
and it had nothing to do with uh oh no i
had a very bad episode um a couple of
weeks ago i crashed as my doctor
normally very
aberrantly diffident guy said i mean i
had a meltdown in my bone marrow
that can happen with chemotherapy i had
a crisis with white and blood cells at
the same time as my gallbladder went
rancid and i was in terrible pain
thought i had a burst appendix
so i was really flat out but i've now
lost the gallbladder and i've gained
some blood transfusion so
i'm back
hanging on
broad question but what is this done to
the old head
well the the worst of the initial
treatments was what's called chemo brain
in the trade
where you feel fogged in the head and
you barely even want to read let alone
right and that terrified me very much
because i thought if i can't do that
well my raison d'etre would in a way
have gone in the literal sense i i
wouldn't have a very persuasive reason
to live and i i didn't want to give in
to despair
it turns out the chemo brain is
transitory i mean i still suffer from
terrible exhaustion i've got it now
physically but i'm i'm quite lucid
at least in my own opinion
i could write a column today if i was
lucky if i had some strong coffee
i can certainly read
um
[Music]
and converse but
if anything was to spread in that
direction i mean then i i probably would
feel that was the end what has been the
reaction from other people to your
condition because you know a ton of
people yeah
and
i'm also known to quite a large number
of people now
and because i had to cancel a book tour
just as it was beginning a rather lavish
book tour
back in the summer
i i couldn't just do a fade and go into
treatment i had to make a statement as
if i was some kind of public figure
about why i couldn't keep these
appointments and
people had gone to a lot of trouble i
had to say something so it became
overnight a sort of news item i guess it
must have been a slow week
and
i imagine partly because of my
opinions about
the supernatural and the religious
life i also got a lot of attention
because people thought well surely now
would be the time for me to make a
reconsideration
withdraw from the principles of a
lifetime make my peace with some church
or other and
there was a lot of public talk about
that there was a day of prayer for me
national day of prayer
which i i took kindly i thought it was
at least sort of gesture of solidarity
but that was by the way prayer in my
favor
there were other people who lobbied
the divine in the opposite direction
presuming to instruct him in either
case seems to be a bit presumptuous but
people can't seem to help that
and i've had an amazing number of
letters from people i still get them
handwritten once to the house
as well as emails to my office in new
york
saying really the nicest things most of
them not all um
and trying to assure me that in their
minds my life hasn't been a waste of
time even if it ends prematurely i'm 62
in april if i
make it that far
and believe me that's been encouraging
i've learned something from it which is
um which is of course like most of the
things one knows that are important
already known to me but i really know it
now
never put off writing a letter to
someone who's in distress
it's always very much appreciated and um
i'm not asking for more people to write
to me but if they have someone in mind
or someone known to them
they haven't quite got around to it yet
i urge them to do it it's been a
terrific help to me i must say and i'm
not particularly um
what's the word vulnerable person in
that way not that easily stirred but
this has been very very moving for me
very confirming
has any of your
at least professional enemies come to
you during this time
if they have what would what do they say
well professional enemies are i suppose
rivals or people who take the opposite
view
not all of them have been very nice and
i've had i mean they've been you know
newspaper columns written about me in
the new york times in them
by david brooks very generous column and
another one by timothy egan in the times
it was it was an editorial in the times
of london
i began to feel
as if i was reading my [ __ ] but
but because i was still alive only the
nice bits would be apprenticed as it
were
and i thought it's nice but of course it
gave me the slightly creepy feeling of
it being premature as well
um
i don't know how many personal enemies i
have
um
and people just don't like me in other
words
one whose nerves i get but the number of
people who've written to me
saying they hope i suffer
now and then forever after i've died um
is
i'd say hearteningly small
go back for them a moment because it was
quite a series of events i mean i'm i
have your
memoir in my hands and in which the
first so should everybody yes and the
first seven pages are all about death
did you have any premonition at all no
but it is weird isn't it um
no i had a free gift from the national
portrait gallery in london which
publishes a
a magazine for subscribers um about its
upcoming exhibitions and there was an
exhibition of the friends of martin amis
who was a friend of mine
photographs
which included me and because one of the
people featured had died while the
catalogue was going to press
they put hastily in the words the late
but they put it next to my name so for
the first time in my life i saw the
words the late christopher hitchens in
print and it does
sorry to overuse the expression
concentrate the mind
they wrote me groveling i think they
thought i was gonna sue and said they've
all been withdrawn we'll pulp them only
a few got out it's all right and i said
no no i want you to send me as many as
you've got
because it makes a wonderful
mini introduction to my
memoir which i nearly finished
so i wrote a it's called a prologue with
premonitions reminiscent reminiscence
sorry meditation on
death
but then i that stage i had no idea who
i was no none
but you went on the daily show with
jon stewart right around the time that
you found out
i went on that show the day i was
diagnosed you know did you know it at
the time yes i've been told in the
morning i'd woken up in new york feeling
very ill
and had to be taken to hospital
and they said i thought i was having a
heart attack
this is not your heart
you can discharge yourself if you want
though
we recommend you stay in for observation
um but whatever you do the next stop
must be with an oncologist there's
clearly a tumor we probably in your
esophagus but it's spread
so i decided to discharge myself because
i wanted to do the stuart show and also
that evening a big event at the new york
um
yhca the 92nd street y circle big public
event with salman rushdie and i managed
to do both of these without showing any
effects but i just had the sentence read
to me let's watch
just a little bit of the stewart uh show
so people can see and then when they see
this you know that you've got a real
problem let's just watch yes i've never
seen it miss hemingway used to read his
obituaries every day with a bloody mary
to start the day to ward off depression
he worked for 10 years before he put the
shotgun
and it
i'd say this it concentrated my mind i
thought here's a sentence that will one
day be unarguably true but for now screw
you i'm not late mate and so i took it
and that kind of unsealed the fountain
of memory a bit and also of course
it dealt with the usual argument you get
from people comment isn't it a bit soon
i say well maybe but there's no choice
of leaving it until too late now is
there no there really isn't and you know
i don't think people should be able to
decide uh for you when you said when you
turned 60 i'm very impressed that
someone who has uh clearly from from the
stories in your book lived you've lived
it you haven't
taken it easy on this model body you
have
yet you don't look like
like and you should
you you actually look i don't know
it's somewhat upsetting
there's um
crying inside a
and b there's an oil painting up in my
attic that's beginning to stick
distinctly
distinctly cd i think i'm not saying so
it's it's starting to get that
actually as i saw you on the john
stewart show you look like you
you had a sense of humor you're fairly
normal what was your head telling you
when you were walking out there well
i i just buried the thought for what it
took to do the show and then later this
on stage event with salman which also
went
very well it was only at the dinner
after that that i began to feel i
couldn't carry on anymore um
but i should get through it i didn't
think anyone noticed but i was
at every opportunity between these
events i was violently sick threw up
very
powerfully
and you had any indication at all that
something was going wrong no i'd had
nothing but
very very good annual check up reports
from my doctors on all fronts your
father died of esophageal cancer he did
at the age of 79.
had that penetrated i mean it was it
i mentioned it in the book i mean i
would have written that before i found
out myself
um but no
i suppose because i used to smoke very
heavily
um i was afraid i was getting it in the
lung
i seem to lead a charmed life but
the thing about esophageal cancer is you
can have it for quite a while it's very
hard to detect
unless you have an upper gi almost every
month and you're looking for it you're
very likely to miss it
and it doesn't usually present as they
say until it's metastasized by the time
i went to the
doctor for biopsy it was very easy to do
because you could feel it in the lymph
node on my neck
which is not a good sign
you began what kind of treatment
i began a cisplation that's called
treatment of chemotherapy
which made me then lose all my hair
it's growing back with the new
chemical i'm trying
slightly
and made me lose a lot of weight and
made me very tired but
knocked it back
perceptibly i mean you could
it was measurably reduced and where did
you have this done
in bethesda and that started what month
last year july
and it ended when
what's still going on still going on yes
i'm hoping now you see because
thanks to a wonderful american um
dr francis collins who's the head of the
national institute of health which
includes the national cancer institute
who did the human genome project brought
it in as you know ahead of time and
under budget marvelous scientific
achievement
um he and i have met because we're
opposite sides of the religion debate we
became friends that way he's a very
convinced christian
um and we become friendly debaters and
he's taking a very kindly interest in my
case and
has helped me have my genome sequenced
and try and look for
a more
perfect identifiable match for any
mutation they can find that's peculiar
to me that could be targeted by a
special drug
so today is friday the 14th uh i don't
know when this will be shown but
on monday i'm going in i hope to try
that if i'm strong enough if my bone
marrow is recovered enough
and that involved six million no excuse
me six billion
dna matches of my tumor
set against six billion dna matches of
my blood
to look for something
that was individually mutated that
wasn't in my genes
absolutely extraordinary what can be
done now i had to go to saint louis to
do it
why saint louis that seems to be where
the project is for finding out
how the genome can be applied to
individuals predicaments in medicine um
it'll be commonplace soon
there's a terrible lack of funding as
you perhaps know i might just say a word
about this now
because people can write their
congressman
in the most recent budget a terrible
collapse in funding to the nih and of
course there's this stupid attempt
to limit the extent which actually
existing embryonic cells can be used for
this kind of thing
and i've become well i was anyway before
this but i i
would like to become more than i am of
an advocate for
overcoming these pseudoscientific
obstacles to medical research
so where did you get your you get your
chemo treatment at nih no no i've had
various
um
tests there but i just go to my regular
oncologist it's a very brilliant man
called dr smith
in bethesda who's
who consults over the internet with a
panel of like-minded experts and
they work out sloan-kettering and
elsewhere they work out a protocol for
me
and adjust it every few weeks
in the in the vanity fair december issue
you wrote about a woman
who came up to you
at a uh
when you were signing books yeah she
starts off by saying shall i tell it if
you can tell i did it i've got it i've
got it here in case yeah tell what
happened well this is my campaign to
have a book of cancer etiquette
published which i might do
signing books in new york after debate
with tariq ramadan about islam
it's a long line
woman at the front comes towards me she
doesn't even have a book which hasn't
bought one
says i'm sorry you're ill
and i said well it's very nice for you
to say so
she said a cousin of mine had cancer and
i said i'm really excited about that he
said yes in the in the liver i said well
that's dreadful i'm really that's awful
and she said but he got better i said
i'm good
and then she said but he got much worse
again
and i said oh i'm sorry
and he said and of course he was a
homosexual and i thought i'm not going
to say of course how was i supposed to
say that and all his friends and family
abandoned him and he died alone and in
great pain
agony incontinence
piercing
pain humiliation indescribable horror
um and i said oh well i was beginning to
run out of things to say but i expressed
consideration with that
and then she said so i just wanted you
to know i know exactly what you're going
through
i thought and then left without
having been by a book
so i thought now would she have treated
me like that if i was well of course not
but people think they have almost a
right if not a duty to do it if you
aren't so and i think we need patients
also need to
suffer
to reciprocate by not sort of inflating
it on people i actually have a badge now
i'm not wearing it a button that says
don't ask and i won't tell
um
and some people do make a huge parade of
their
their condition
i've tried to write about it in other
contexts
exactly i wrote about the national day
of prayer and why i wasn't joining it um
i've written about imaginative new
gene-based treatments things like that i
don't just want to write my own
tumor diaries
that would be
a little
solidistic but
you wrote in uh your
prologue of your book uh
as i said a lot about death which is
called
hitch 22.
i personally want to do death in the
active and not the passive
and to be there to look at in the eye
and be doing something when it comes for
me
why what's that mean anyway well it's
part of life
so i'd like to be conscious for it but
this is what i thought then
um and i ideally
i'd like to be making a speech perhaps
or making love or
i don't know sitting with friends
um
or if i had more notice conceivably to
try a sort of socratic
terminus where
people gather around
and you try and make
a fist of a decent farewell
i've had cause to reconsider that now
because
if this cancer doesn't go into remission
um
it's a very unpleasant way to die
why
well
one
quite probable way of doing it is to
choke in your own puke for example not a
very good thing
and it can be preceded by all kinds of
humiliations um so it's not that you're
gonna die and you're resigned or
reconciled to that
as part of life it's that
the sentence includes that you'd be
tortured for a bit before you die
and
so it i now feel a slight bravado about
what i wrote there um i would still if
it were possible like to be awake
and looking at people and if i'm lucky
talking to them
but i'm not so sure i would insist on it
um it might be as well to sort of slip
away in a
in a narcotic
uh stupor
it might be but still there's something
about that
may sound very old-fashioned thing to
say strikes me as a bit ignoble
as i say it's part of life i want to i
want to get as much out of it as i can
how much of during this period have you
talked about this kind of thing with
carol blue your wife
well a lot because she's been a great
province day for me she's she does
things i don't like to do
going on the internet looking up every
conceivable ramification of treatment
and possibility
um
tirelessly
looking for new doctors and
new avenues and things of that so we
talk a lot about it
about losing about what would happen
when i've gone we've actually barely
have talked about that
my determination is that i'm i'm not
going to die of it i'm well i'm not
going to die of it now i might die with
it perhaps some years from now that is a
possibility
and i'm certainly going to do everything
i can to be an experimental subject for
other treatments even if they don't work
for me i feel that would be
i say in the book i quote the great
american scholar horace mann who said
till you've done something for humanity
you should be ashamed to die
so it's quite a high standard to reach
well that would be doing something for
humanity
at a fairly small cost to myself even if
it involved protracting
the treatment unnecessarily i'd be
willing to do it
in the middle of all this a couple of
weeks ago you debated
tony blair yes in toronto
i've carried on debating
on this and other questions
but we we covered it and i want to run
just a clip of you
making some points he's sitting on the
stage there with you let's watch that
and we'll come back and ask you
as long as you don't want your religion
taught to my children in school
given a government subsidy imposed on me
by violence
any of these things you are
fine by me i would prefer
i would prefer not even to know what it
is that you do
in that
church of yours well i do in fact if you
force it on my attention i will consider
it a breach of that pact have your own
bloody christmas and so on
do your do your slaughtering
if possible in an abattoir
and don't mutilate the genitals of your
children
because then i'm afraid it gets within
the ambush of law all right so that's
don't you think that's reasonably
pluralistic and communitarian of me i
think it is
why is it a vain hope on my part why is
that
has this packed ever been honored by the
other side of course not
and it's a mystery to me and i'll share
it with you
um if i believe that there was a savior
who'd been appointed or sent by or or a
prophet
uh senator sent by a god who bore me in
mind and loved me and what wanted the
best for me if i believed that
and that i
possessed the means of grace and the
hope of glory to phrase it like that i
think i don't know i think i might be
happy
they say it's the way to happiness why
doesn't it make them happy
well don't you think it's a perfectly
decent question why doesn't it because
they won't be happy till you believe it
too
and why is that because that's what
their holy books tell them
[Applause]
why did you do that debate when was it
actually it was at thanksgiving
and what condition were you in then
well i
i sort of timed my treatment so that it
would come because i had a lot of notice
of the event
so that it would come at the end of the
dream when i'm much usually much
stronger
because it would have been very
irresponsible it was a huge event a lot
of
trouble and money went into
fixing it up and getting blair and
getting security and all this stuff
so it wasn't well i never liked like to
cancel anyway but i couldn't do that so
i was feeling okay very tired but
physically
all right and mentally quite alert and
it was the first time blair had had a
public debate since he stopped being
prime minister on any subject and then
you wrote about it in vanity fair yes
and what was your take from all that i
mean you were you were taking the
position well you tell us that your
position in his position i mean i debate
with religious people all the time
mentioned terry ramadan um rabbi shmuley
all kinds of people i've debated since i
became sick
blair is of course a new convert to
roman catholicism
so i wanted to question a bit about that
and then one can only do one thing at a
time usually in these debates and
the point i wanted him to concede was
that
the evils that people like
myself speak about when we talk about
religion
he will always and his co-thinkers will
always acknowledge they'll say this was
done in the name of religion and i said
now you must drop that
there is scriptural warrant and
authority very clearly in the holy books
which is supposed to be the word of god
for these evils
so it's a cop-out to use a vulgarity to
say it's in the name of it's
you can't just say it's a parody of you
have to face the responsibility
well in fact when we were asked by one
questioner
to say what had been the strongest point
made by the other he said that he agreed
that i was right that
the problem is that there is scriptural
authority for a great deal of atrocity
and cruelty and stupidity in the holy
books
so that's my best memory of the evening
i suppose um
when i asked him i opened with a long
quotation from cardinal
newman
whose beatification he just recommended
to the pope
and support it
very wicked in my view quotation from
newman's apologia
and then i wanted to know whether he
thought the pope was the vicar of christ
on earth whether the catholic church was
the one true church
it was quite strange he didn't come up
to the scratch to fight me on that
you could not have told from anything he
said
that he was a roman catholic at all
he could have been a very weak sort of
christian socialist liberal
who basically says that if christianity
is okay because it makes people do good
works and give money to charity which
no one denies is true but has nothing to
do with the relevance or the truth of
the matter
so
um but he's a man with whom i sympathize
in other ways and i've known a little
bit for quite a long time
so it was it was an unusually
interesting debate
excuse me
sorry bro
just have a sip here
my medicine
you and i f
first interview i ever conducted with
you was on november the 7th 1983.
remember it was the windshield 83 colin
show yes and i want to just run
oh it's a minute
24 seconds and then we'll talk about
this all right
uh when when journalists
lose their credibility i think in this
country journalists have lost their
credibility based upon their past
performances
the american people are speaking out now
and i i just feel that
without no type of checks and balances
on the journalists they're doing exactly
what this gentleman's doing here they
bring a foreign news agent
over into the country
okay report all the faults
okay but don't take a deep enough look
at the positive uh aspects of what a
free press really is
i'm getting fed up with this kind of
questioning actually i mean 30 miles
from north of philadelphia as you are
how do you presume to know that the
american people are speaking out to the
extent that you do know or to the extent
that you can speak for them
you can only know it through reading the
reading of free press
and watching a free tv
the truth is that the papers are
reporting the fact
that they're unpopular with the
administration and the
column with which david began luke
cannon's column today says he he admits
it's true that public opinion is
probably on reagan's side
on this one but if you want your prayers
to be treated as the british treated
their press in the falklands you're
going to end up not knowing very much
about what's going on if that's what you
want don't read the papers but do not
prevent me or anyone else from reading
them
well you can see how times have changed
from that clip there you were on our set
smoking yes
i was doing that until quite late on i
forget when it stopped i can't remember
when we it's incredible now when i see
as one often does that shot of
walter cronkite announcing the
president's death in dallas in 63 the
whole studio looks like chernobyl
so ashtrays stretching as far as the eye
can see
and i also appreciated you calling me
david on that show it kind of was
humbling well it's the name was then the
name of the very distinguished los
angeles times africa correspondent ah
that was the reason it's david yeah
anyway sorry all the same i think it's
very important to get people oh that was
it was
it's fun to see this
for both of us go back at that time but
but you know in those days you were
fairly there's a lot of bravado about
smoking and drinking
and i beca for the first book notes book
we did i went with you to a bar i
remember and you had your computer and a
glass of something and a cigarette yeah
i used to write my columns in
timberlake's bar on connecticut avenue
do you do you ever think that this all
this wouldn't have happened without that
and did your father smoke is that where
my father was a pipe smoker
and a reasonably
consistent drinker too
and i can't but think that that's what
contributed to it
we didn't learn much from his death my
brother and i because
he was diagnosed and died almost right
away um
we didn't find out much about i know it
was lower down than where mine is and
probably inoperable then
but it wasn't a teaching moment um is
your by the way is yours inoperable
well it couldn't yes it can't be cut out
no it's spread
metastasized yeah it's spread it can't
be cut out and it's too near my lungs
and my heart to be properly radiated so
it has to be
chemo and or targeted
gene therapy but over those years when
you were smoking so to answer your
question of course
i always knew that there's a risk in the
bohemian lifestyle and i decided to take
it because
whether it's an illusion or not i don't
think it is um
it helped my concentration
it stopped me being bored stopped other
people being boring to some extent
it would keep me awake it would make me
want the evening to go on longer to
prolong the conversation to enhance the
moment
if i was asked would i do it again
um
the answer is probably yes i'd have quit
earlier possibly hoping to get away with
the whole thing
easy for me to say of course not very
nice to my children to hear it sounds
irresponsible
if i say yeah i'd do all that again to
you but the truth is it would be
hypocritical for me to say no i'd never
touched the stuff if i'd known because i
did know
everyone knows
and i decided all of life is a wager i'm
gonna wage on this bit
and i i can't make it come out any other
way
it's strange i almost don't even regret
it
though i should
because it's just impossible for me to
picture life without
wine and other things fueling the
company and and
keeping me reading and um
traveling and energizing me it worked
for me it really did
what
over the years has bored you you use
that word more than once and you're
right yes
well it's a vice of course
accident i think it's actually one of
the deadly sins
boredom what's the anti-room to despair
it's sort of the feeling that
anime that nothing's interesting and
that's work
i i'm too prone to it i i get easily
tired of
um
so i don't know
committee meetings or
not that i have to do many of those or
waiting in line or i mean i'm very very
impatient person
um
so
and i'm very happy by myself i'm lucky
in that way if i've got enough to read
and something to write about
and a bit of
alcohol for me to add an edge not to
dull it
um
it's been a formula
during this time of your illness um
how have you passed the time when
and have you had a lot of pain during
this time yes well i especially before i
found out
it was the gallbladder not the side
effects
i was becoming worried that i was some
overdoing the painkillers
i actually it should be the other way
around but i said to the doctors look
i'm living
i'm in danger of moving from pill to
pill i i surely shouldn't be taking this
much morphine or codeine based stuff
i was going to feel woozy um
but i i'd like to think that the
gallbladder was the cause of that
because before then the pain hadn't been
all that acute
it was quite dealable with quite
manageable you had became unbearable
when we're talking how many days ago did
you have your gallbladder around 10 i
think
8010 and did you have the
uh
laparoscopic
yes it was all over very quickly once
they found it and do you feel better
because of it not yet because the
general anaesthetic takes a long time to
to wear off
at least it has with me given how weak i
was already and how
much weight i've lost and how little
food i've been taking
i couldn't have done this yesterday for
example
really no absolutely not i could hardly
get out of bed
about 30 some years ago 36 years ago or
seven years ago a man named stuart alsop
yes columnist for newsweek right
had leukemia the aml
acute
difficult uh leukemia and
wrote about it i don't know did you have
you gone back and looked at any of his
columns no i've not no and he and he
told the story he was at nih and i
think he might have had bone marrow
transplant i can't remember for sure but
i remember i was glued to it and he took
us all the way through his process
um
how much more are we going to hear from
you about your situation i hope a lot i
mean i don't say that just
for my own sake and then what kind of
things are you thinking about telling us
about
well i think the main thing is to
emphasize the the extraordinary
innovations
in this kind of it's branching medicine
that are becoming available
based on our new knowledge of our
genetic makeup
and um
so in so far as these treatments are
applicable to me which they some of them
are
i'm hoping
to write in some detail
um and alert people to possibilities
that they may not yet know about
um
that exist even for quite hard cases
quite advanced cases any thought of
writing a book i mean you mentioned
earlier yes i thought i'd write a book
that was
both about facing death and about the
struggle for life um
and how one motivation for the latter in
my case apart from the obvious ones
is precisely to see if i can participate
in
pushing those boundaries back and
enlarging the area of scientific
knowledge
have you lost interest
in certain things in the world no
not at all
and as you sit here today what would be
your number one interest
of things going on in the world
right now right now
well
looking at today's paper
which is the first thing i do every day
still um
i suppose it would it would it would
have to be
one version or another of the
confrontation with islamic jihad
in particular the appallingly serious
news in pakistan in the last few weeks
where the whole
the whole threat seems to me to be amped
up
noticeably in a way we haven't quite
internalized
where the chief minister of the
country's most important state mr salman
sierra
is murdered in cold blood by
someone pretending to be his bodyguard
on the grounds that he opposes
an existing blasphemy lord not even that
he's committed blasphemy
and so that anyone
claiming to be a muslim is entitled to
kill him
and that this god the endorsement of all
the religious authorities all the
mullahs and imams in pakistan
so it used to be bad enough
on conviction by a court
of the charge of blasphemy you could
face a death sentence but you've been
through a jury an appeals process the
rest of it
bad enough in all conscience
but warranted by the quran if you care
which i don't
but now
permission to anybody to appoint himself
an executioner on the spot
and be the agent of the religion in
murdering anyone they like
this is fantastically dangerous
and we've decided to invest ourselves
completely in the idea that
there are moderates to be found if we
can pay them
um who will um
fend this off i don't think there's a
prayer of that to coin a phrase
especially if we appear to be
their patrons how do you i mean
i think we're totally fooling ourselves
about it what about this process of
having to face this illness
are you surprised about and the reason i
ask you about i mean you went off on
some substance there and some people
just give all that up when they are
faced with this kind of
situation i mean what what's changed
what what about this process surprised
you
my internal presence your process of
becoming ill and they tell you you've
got stage four yes esophageal cancer and
all that i mean are you surprised about
any of this
the last six months
because you've obviously thought about
you wrote seven pages about death no
yes well i think a memoir of a person
who just passed 60 has to face that
um so i thought i heard that much to the
readers um
no it hasn't been all that surprising
actually no
it's a commonplace thing
i mean i don't
i wrote this somewhere i mean i don't
sit around asking myself
why me and if i did the cosmos wouldn't
bother to favor me with a reply i
wouldn't even say why not
um it's a commonplace thing
for some of my age and previous habits
it's almost laughably predictable
um
the only interesting thing about it is
its possible immune ability to
treatments that were unknown until very
recently the outcome of brilliant work
by devoted people some of whom i'm very
lucky to count as friends
you know there there are many
examples we hear from friends and people
we've known over the years where a
doctor will
say some very straightforward and crude
things and
make life very uncomfortable i remember
there was a reporter in this town
worked the washington post he told me
one day he's no longer with us the
doctor called him after he'd had tests
and he said guess what
you got the big c
and you mean i couldn't believe that he
actually would you know
it happened but the reason i bring this
up is that is a bit crass what what
marks would you give the medical
profession in the way they've treated
you and they give you hope that this
thing can be licked
they've given me more than a margin of
hope it can be licked yes and they
haven't pronounced on my
chances unless i've asked them
um which i decided not to do at first
until it occurred to me that it would be
very useful for
if you like accounting purposes
to have a rough idea because one has to
plan for one's loved ones and
descendants
i thought so for actuarial reasons i'd
like to have a guess
they don't like being asked because they
don't really know
um
and the best
answer i got was the following if if you
took a thousand people
who were myself in other words my age my
state of health my gender i think
a thousand of us
today half of us would be dead in a year
of the remaining half others might hope
to live more than a year and
of that number quite a number to live
for a considerable number of years they
can't do better than that
that was from a very senior person at
the nih who was expecting the question
what is your reaction to people like me
i mean we come to your apartment we want
to sit down and talk to you you know why
we're here we want to hear this story
and you've had a bunch here
are you surprised
at that
a little bit yes
i was
but a lot of it i know it has been to do
with my
stance on religion
i mean
a very large number of people have asked
me
um
doesn't it change your attitude to
the infinite the eternal the
supernatural and so forth and i i've
said that i really don't see why it
should
i've never thought of it as a
particularly searching question i mean
if i i spent a lot of my life deciding
that there isn't any redemption that
there's no salvation
um that there's no afterlife that
there's no supervising
boss
to if i was to tell you well now i've
got a malignancy in my esophagus that
changes everything you would think i
hope that
the main effect had been on my iq
it's a complete logical non-sequitur
that's nothing to do with it
so i've enjoyed taking part in that
argument
um
and there's a certain ghoulish element
even about the nice people who've been
praying for me because they are not just
praying for my recovery they're praying
for my reconciliation with religion
and i
i proposed a trade-off the other day i
said tell you what
what if we secularists stop going to
hospitals and walking around the wards
and asking if people are religious
when they're an extremist in the last
days and saying look you've still got a
little time why don't you live the last
few days of it as a free person you'll
feel much better
all that nonsense they taught you you
know you still you could still have
every chance to give it up
experience the life of a free-thinking
autonomous person don't live in fear
don't believe don't believe in mythology
they i don't think they welcome it
and of course we don't do that
but it seems to be considered the right
of almost everybody to do it the other
way around i don't resent it at all
because i like every opportunity for the
argument but
it a lot of it has been to do with that
i don't flatter myself that as a
public figure i i rate
all that highly
the booknote show we did in 93 um
it's a short clip i want to run this and
get your reaction to it
a lot of people their first love is what
they'll always remember for me it's
always been the first hate
and i think that hatred though it
provides often rather junky energy is a
terrific way of getting out of bed
in the morning keeping you going it can
be if you don't let it get out of hand
it can be catalyzed into writing
and um in this country where people like
to be non-judgmental when they can be
which translates us on the whole lenient
there are an awful lot of bubble
reputations floating around that
you know one wouldn't be doing one's job
if one didn't itch to prick
so is it still a good idea to hate
people
well since it's not really avoidable
um
i think the question is how to
if you like
uh
turn it to advantage
um one of the things i don't like about
christianity is the idea of compulsory
love
because it's bound to lead to hypocrisy
people pretending to love more than they
do and also since it's coupled with
the injunction to love a god who you're
also supposed to fear there's every
chance of that sort of curdling there's
something very honest by contrast to
finding someone completely unbearable
someone like henry kissinger for example
it's bad to let it it's a bit like
alcohol if you like it's a it's a good
servant but it's a bad master
i mean i have a completely cold hatred
and contempt for henry kissinger but it
doesn't waste much of my time
it's just that it enables me to
penetrate i think the sort of fog of
sentiment and bogus reputation in which
he's shrouded and protected
and um it doesn't eat away at me it
doesn't keep me awake at night doesn't
poison me he doesn't fill me with bile
but i can't pretend that it's just a
matter of political disagreement
i mean i think there is such a thing as
evil in the world
and sometimes personified
um and i think was under no obligation
to be ambivalent there
oh
change your mind at all about mother
teresa
what would change my mind about her i
didn't never couldn't one couldn't
exactly hate her
um
because in a way she was a pathetic
figure
but i detested the influence that she
had and i can tell you why in a sentence
if you want well
the very reason
that she's so celebrated the this
apparent concern for the poor of the
world or the poorest of the poorest she
was always obliging us to say
well as it happens we know what the cure
for poverty is or what a certain cure of
poverty is and it goes under the name
the empowerment of women
it works everywhere bangladesh bolivia
name it
give women some control over their
reproductive cycle get them off the
animal routine of breeding machine
and the
the level of
poverty will will decline
sharply it's never never known to fail
it's a consistent finding
just for an example this is my central
point about it mother teresa spent her
entire life opposing the only thing that
works
opposing all forms of birth control
comparing them to abortion which she
called murder i mean directly in her
nobel prize speech said that was the
main
threat to peace in the world which is a
fanatical stupid thing to say
that's basically it
that plus the reputation for sanctity
that she got for preaching this nonsense
but one could add her friendship with
the worst the richest of the rich people
like charles keating of the savings and
lonely was a great friend of hers she
took stolen money from him refused when
the court asked
to return it took money from the
duvalier dictatorship in haiti which
treated the poor like pigs worse
bless them in return gave him divine
sanction
goes on
her whole effect was entirely retrograde
and no one ever wrote any but one story
about her till i wrote my critique and
in that book it's very short
i make five or six other direct
accusations against her
backed up with fact and that book's been
reviewed by every newspaper in the world
including all the religious press
no one's ever pointed out a mistake in
it
not one
and if half of what i say is true about
her then none of what is commonly
believed about her is true
but i'm used to this now
people need every now and then a
complete illusion and this was one what
would you do if henry kissinger
decided to call you and try to bury the
hatchet after all these years that would
be
extremely interesting
but one of the reasons i detest him is i
sort of know that couldn't happen he
wouldn't even agree when i was writing
my book about him to have questions
submitted in writing
let alone to meet me
he's made it a condition when he appears
on television programs that he not be
asked about the book i know this from
the producers several of them
he made a condition of his appearance at
the national press club which i don't
think should have agreed that he not be
asked about the book
um
never mind his attitude to me
there's no reason to like me but i mean
i would have pretended if i was here
might have pretended who's this guy
hitchings i don't care
but i know i needled him
but more important if you think of the
things he's been found out as having
done
lying about vietnam lying about chile
bangladesh east timor the deaths of so
many people needlessly for the vanity of
himself and his criminal president
we have other people from that period in
our history robert mcnamara the bundy
brothers
others william colby who in their books
and their memoirs tried to make some
kind of restitution they said actually
this was pretty bad policy we sort of
suspected at the time
that it was bad maybe worse and we're
sort of sorry
and actually we have some evidence we
feel we should share with you
some disclosures that you should have
had at the time mid-summertime kissing
has never said a word
of self-criticism not one and he gets
very petulant and
angry
and spoiled
and ugly when he's criticized
so the as jeeves says in another context
bertie the contingency sir is a remote
one
but if he was to try it i'd be
fascinated to meet him of course we
don't have much time ed
look don't say that
i'll be the judge of that if you
knew that there was a certain amount of
time left
i have no idea six months a year or
whatever
things
do you want to do
i mean you've gone through that process
yes but what they don't tell you is what
kind of months these would be that's the
other reason they don't like being asked
what have you not done if i was in um
you probably remember stephen silas the
late congressman very interesting man
had the same thing as me
died recently but he before he died he'd
had about four or five counts of three
years and he'd done a lot of traveling
he kept up his interest in human rights
and international policy
and then he got
word that it was back and probably that
was it and he
made fairly short work of dying this was
a few weeks ago
um
that's what i need to know i mean the
great loss to me in the last few months
is the inability to travel i got to
toronto for thanksgiving that wasn't
that hard
i've been to california i've been to
with a private plane
very kindly that was sent for me to do a
speaking engagement in montana i finally
got to see the little bighorn which i've
always wanted to
and um
the wonderful national park
so i've now only got three american
states unvisited which ones
the dakotas in nebraska
i've done all the others plus puerto
rico any plan to go back to your home
country or american citizens
it's sentimental i know but um
someone said to me randomly the other
day are you afraid of not seeing england
again and i realized yes i was i can't
bear the idea of not going back
at least once but like i couldn't do it
now
um i'd have to be told i was
on what they call a chemo holiday
we are out of time and i think the best
way to end it is to say i'll see you in
a couple years absolutely this again you
bet
thank you very much my pleasure it is
bright isn't it
[Music]
for a dvd copy of this program call
1-877-662-7726
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
q a dot org
q a programs are also available as
c-span podcasts
[Music]
coming up next on